He is a totally fake person. He is a
>> I'm not Yeah, but I can't just let you lie to my audience.
You understand that, right? That I do have some amount of integrity
and I'm not just going to let you lie to my audience. The reason
why you answer in sneaky way
>> If she just felt confident enough to call him on this,
he totally made this up based on some stupid comment from his
>> That that that that this that that these >> This
is the point where I'm like, "Holy Are you good? You having a
stroke?" >> I'm not asking questions. I'm asking you was
Chorus was solely funded by the 1630 Fund that you know where
the Chorus money is coming from.
>> That the Taylor Lorenz convo with Destiny, I Why did
they end up talking? So, I saw a tweet.
I did see a tweet here. So, Taylor posted about this a couple
hours ago. Taylor Lorenz is still lying about Chorus. This is
so strange. Destiny claims without evidence I take dark money
from a Qatari dude. I don't take any dark money and never would
because I still write for mainstream media and that would violate
every basic journalistic ethics clause out there. Is this in
the preview for this video? >> What else? I wouldn't take
dark money personally as it She does, by the way. Like she literally
they I mean yeah, whatever the [__] that Qatari dude
or whatever the [__] like she literally takes just
as much um like in kind of like a dark money thing as she was
accusing Chorus of. But you know, it's funny that she >> So,
like what do we think dark money is? Dark money is, at least
in politics, dark money would be The concerns there are around
Citizens United. It's around people funding some PAC without
their identity being known. It's difficult to
what the intentions of somebody is or what the intentions of
like a PAC is if you don't know where the money is coming from
at all, right? Right? So, it's like it's something that's basically
sort of spun up. It's It's not a company that has a reputation
or a PAC that has a reputation, right? These things sort of just
spin up and then because you don't know anything because they're
very often like new, made per election cycle. The way you can
determine what they want to do is by looking at who's funding
them. And they will have names that are misleading for the things
they want to do. It's a common thing, right? So, you want to
look at the where the money is coming from because you want to
know what the motivations of the person are. Uh the thing I said
about Progressive Victory back maybe 2 years ago now was, "What
would you say if you found out that Peter Thiel was the person
funding Progressive Victory?" And you saw that they were like
going and finding the most like offensive
like inflaming and trying to get them money to keep make getting
them to make content so people could rage take the rage bait
and like counter signal with it.
Wouldn't that be concerning to you if you found that out? Right?
So, dark money, you don't know the source and you basically can't
discern their motives because you don't know the source. This
video led to Taylor Lorenz tweeting about it. And then from Taylor
Lorenz tweeting about it, I'm guessing she Oh, like at the OmniLiberal,
I'm guessing she asked him to talk. You know this is not true.
What on earth are you talking about? If you want to have a discussion
on the things I cover, I'd be so happy to join your stream. But
to go on your stream and just make things up about me is really
ridiculous. So, she asked for a conversation. Okay, that's where
we get to here. I just wanted to catch people up if you didn't
follow the Krystal
It was Brian Tyler Cohen's sort of hybrid PAC that he set up
to try to get Democrat messaging on on side. Like basically get
them all so they're saying the same thing. And you see a lot
of this stuff happening now where you'll see like influencers
come out who are seemingly independent who all have like the
exact same like the same day. I think you're seeing this influence
spread far and wide right now. >> How you doing? What's
up? How's it
>> I was laughing so hard because somebody put in my group
chat who's this Qatari
person that you're accepting money from? And I was like, "Qatari
person, what are you talking about?" And I >> You know
what happened there, right? You know exactly what happened there.
Is Destiny just does the webbing thing where he's like, "Oh,
who funds who counter signals Israel? Who funds propaganda that
counter signals Israel? Well, it's the Qataris. Well, she's funded
by Qataris.
You know that's like that's the only thing he did in his head
to come up with that. That was it. It was just like a little
web immediately like throws out the allegation. Very goofy. >> a
link to your stream saying that I'm funded by some Qatari Qatari
person, which is very silly and not true. Anyway, I will not
>> Do you Oh, wait, wait, wait. Hold on, wait. Just check
it real quick. Um are you not a recipient of money from the I
want to call it the Amigdala Fund, but I know that's not what
it's called. Who There's a guy who Do you know what I'm referring
to or are you going to >> Are you talking about the Are
you talking about the Omidyar >> Yeah, that one. Yeah.
>> Okay, so Pierre Omidyar is not Qatari as far as I'm
aware of. >> Uh Taylor's already explained all of this
to Destiny. I'm pretty sure we covered this before, where they
had a conversation and Taylor explained exactly this to Destiny.
And he got totally obliterated in that conversation. Had no way
to like talk back against against her and then just reset and
started throwing out allegations again. >> He is a >> I'll
watch him. >> billionaire that create that has his own
political action dark money group that I'm not affiliated with
and have never accepted money from. And then he also funds The
Intercept. He funded very famously funded The Intercept, funded
Honolulu Civil Beat. He funds a bunch of journalistic institutions
and he funds a non-profit non-partisan
non-political reporting fellowship that I did last >> Yeah,
that thing that you're referring to, that would be dark money.
>> No, it's not dark money. I know exactly who funded it.
It's not a 501c4 whatever it's structured as an LLC. >> Are
you sure? >> know. They had They had to issue a
>> I thought I thought the Omidyar group was structured
this way. Um to be honest with you, I thought when we looked
into it it had the same
But I'm not totally sure. >> They They literally had to
issue a statement about this because >> We We looked into
it the last time
like this all came up and I could have sworn it was that structure,
but I
They already had this exact same conversation, but then apparently
Destiny started talking [__] about her with respect
to Corvus because Pisco talked to her. So, I guess he watched
I guess he like camps Pisco's content now.
Uh I don't know why.
He's the Pisco police, but um So, he was watching that and he
was talking [__] about Taylor and then Taylor called
him out on Twitter. So, now they're having the same conversation
again. >> Cuz people were going online and making these
ridiculous claims. Destiny, I freelance from the mainstream media.
I can't I just wrote a big piece for Vanity Fair and The Guardian
last week. I can't write for those organizations if I was accepting
dark >> Well, first of all, yes, you can. Of course, you
can. You don't have to declare every single income source or
any Of course, you can. Yeah, of course, you can. You don't have
to declare every No, no, that's not Dude, if you're working for
a mainstream publication, that's not Dude, could you imagine
like Wolf Blitzer accepting random PAC money?
Could you imagine?
Like of course, you're not allowed to do that. Now, if you just
wanted to like take money under the table, you wanted to be like
blatantly corrupt and maybe people wouldn't catch you, but >> every
single source of income and every single thing in your life.
>> Trust me when I say you cannot be accepting political
dark money and working as a mainstream media journalist. You
cannot. You You could write You sure you could write an opinion
column
he does just do this with like no idea of the problem space at
all. Destiny just makes assertions
that aren't remotely close to reality. Like all the time. It's
I feel like that should cost you something in a conversation
like this, right? You just make some [__] up. You
just totally make some [__] up and then they're like,
"No." And you're like, "Well, I don't know about that." >> Maybe,
but certainly you cannot do reporting. You cannot. >> Well,
am I blocking Taylor at all? >> policy of any place that
I've ever worked for. And a bunch of digital media places that
I've worked for. You cannot do that. >> Okay, I don't believe
that's true. But so the money the money that you've
The money that you've gotten well the money the money you've
gotten the money that you've gotten comes through something called
the Omidyar Network. >> Oh, I would say possibly if you
just do opinion stuff, maybe you could Kilinger. Like I think
they let lobbyists go on CNN and be on like the the opinion polls
and stuff, right?
But I'm guessing you couldn't be like a journalist doing like
actual investigative reporting.
Like if you're just an opinion if you're just like a talking
head, you're probably fine. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Work. Correct.
>> No. No. No. It's it's a separate it's a fund that is
specifically it's not it's specifically just a journalistic
fund that is for journalistic reporting. So it's not dark money.
It's not a dark money dark money all all the money from who knows
where goes into a big pot, right? And then it's distributed and
you don't know your funders. >> Yeah, so like the money
goes into something called the Omidyar Network. The Omidyar Network
launched a program called the Reporters in Residence Program,
which is what paid you out, >> No. No. >> So you
weren't part of the Reporters in Residence Program? >> The
Reporter Destiny, they issued a whole press release. If you want
to go and you're confused about this, they issued a whole press
release explaining this. You can just go I'll try to find the
link and send it to you so it's a little bit clear for it. But
I it's not dark money. I have to know who funds me. I have to
know who funds me. That is for for myself as a journalist. So
it's not a dark money fund. I know that Pierre Omidyar a billionaire
funded this journalist fellowship. >> What was the name
of the I mean I can just look it up right now. So what was the
name then of the thing that funded you? What was the name of
the thing that published the >> Pierre Omidyar Pierre Omidyar
funds funds it. >> It's the Omidyar Group and I think it's
a program as a part of the the Omidyar Group, right? >> Directly.
Pierre Omidyar. It's in it through an LLC.
>> Wait, if you just you just said it's through an LLC,
then that means it's not directly funded by him. The LLC is what's
cutting you the money.
I'm sorry that you're confused by this. Let's let's >> Taylor,
I'm so sorry. Listen, I've I was nice to you in the past. The
these little strategies don't work on me,
When I got ripped before, that's cuz I was trying to be nice,
actually. When I got totally destroyed before, that was because
I was trying to be nice.
These little strategies don't work on
Uh it's so funny, man. It's so funny. >> I'm not confused,
Taylor, Taylor, Taylor, Taylor, Taylor. Taylor, just to be clear,
right? Very this is very easy. That LLC that pays you, do they
publicly publish all of the recipients of income to that LLC?
Are those revenue statements publicly
>> Yes, they they they publicly issued a statement because
there was so much >> Taylor, you're not answering the question
I just asked. I'm going to ask the same question again. Does
that organization, that LLC, do they publish
their tax returns? All their schedule Cs, all their schedule,
everything else. You can see all of the income sources of that
LLC. The answer is no, Taylor. They Of course they don't. And
so which means >> Oh my god, yes they do. Literally, Destiny,
go on the website and look at the press Can you pull up the press
release, please, that they issued that explains this to you?
>> Taylor, what's it called?
What am I looking for? >> Let's find a link. Hold on a
second. Let's see cuz they had to issue a whole statement explaining
this cuz people like you were very confused, which I >> You
keep saying confused, but you're just you're being slippery,
very >> I'm not being slippery. They issued a statement.
I I couldn't Trust me, I could not write for mainstream media
if I was taking dark money. I cannot I cannot do that. That is
against the the journalistic ethics >> Oh, this is the
statement they released. Omidyar Network receives no funding
for the Reporters in Residence program via the 1630 Fund or any
other outside
So they're saying, we explicitly do not accept any money for
the specific program from outside sources. Okay? That's just
on their site. And this was published before and they would have
gone over this before.
Like all of this where Desti is like, "Well, but the Ammediar
Fund is like the Ammediar Network, that's like an LLC, blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah." Programmatic work is supported entirely
via our foundation and LLC. But any other outside sources. I'm
assuming that means anybody who is not literally the like PR
of Ammediar.
Right? There's no way they would say this would make no sense.
If they what they meant here was, "Well, we don't accept any
other outside money except the money we solicit publicly through
It's like, "Okay, but like is there a limit on the donations
or
like that wouldn't make sense." >> Oh, here we go. Here
we go. Ammediar receives no funding
via the 1634 or any other outside
>> Wait, wait, I don't know what you're reading. Wait,
wait, link me what you're
>> Okay, so here we go.
They make it very clear and say on the
they do not receive funding from So again, basically what you'd
want to look at is where the 1630 Funds Foundation and LLC are
getting their funding sources from and if those are totally anonymous.
Right? Are they totally anonymous? Cuz I would assume this is
going to be a big difference between the 501c4 and 501c3
I don't know what you're reading. I'm waiting for you to link
me what you're >> Wait, I sent you the link. >> Oh,
okay. >> Ammediar Network receives no funding for the Reporters
in Residence program via the 1630 or any other outside sources.
That's really important, Desti, because I could not work as a
freelance journalist if I accepted dark money. I couldn't. I
would be fired. If a journalist did that, that would be a scandal.
We are not allowed to do that. Cut and dry.
That's not to say that political influencers aren't allowed to.
Political influencers, commentators, you're right. You could
write for the opinion pages of certain outlets, for sure.
Okay, so at its on its on like the
the fact that it's the Omidyar Group, that's already telling
you like Omi- Pierre Omidyar has like they have very like dedicated
things they're donating
Right? They have stuff they fund. They have like a whole history.
They have a whole reputation. Okay?
It's different than like a random PAC that spins up out of nowhere.
It's different than all of those things. This is like the argument
would be similar for like, "Yeah, I work at like
and technically I take like dark money cuz I don't know who funds
like my paycheck. I don't know like where that money actually
comes from, how it like flows through revenue or if it comes
from like investment money. I don't know where the money So I
get dark money." It's like, "No, you get paid to be a part of
like this organization with a reputation that does a thing, provides
a
Like the Omidyar Group is already something with a reputation.
The reason the dark money stuff is confusing or is concerning
cuz you don't know where that money's coming from. You don't
know who's sending it in. And then with this it's like Pierre
Omidyar is a billionaire who's giving a bunch of this money to
his own thing.
If you accept these, you know, sorts of deals. But I am not I
am a working journalist. I cannot accept those deals. And this
is not the Reporters in Residence program is not a political
It we have people with all over the political spectrum that are
part of >> Well, the funny thing is is I think what they
do for the Reporters in Residence is this group is basically
it's a philanthropic group that has a couple different areas
of focus. And I think they basically try to fund journalists
who specialize in one of those areas of focus. They try to make
sure that somebody is reporting on those areas of focus. Right?
So I think for Taylor, I don't know what it would have been specifically.
It could have been money in politics. It could have been
What are some other like internet privacy? She could have gotten
money for like those reasons and it would have been basically
saying like, "Hey, we like that you're doing the thing that we
want to support. So here's some money."
Right? But again, these are explicitly non-partisan things.
Tech writing? Maybe it's tech writing. >> program. I'm
not a Democrat, I'm in that program, right? >> I think
there's credit >> Can you explain to me how do you think
these the hybrid funding mechanisms >> Oh. But also,
that the funding is public, they list who they're funding, and
the people themselves talk about getting funding. Right? So,
one half of this entire problem, possibly the bigger half, the
actual like consumer protection part, that's all taken care of.
Right? So, that whole problem with Chorus, that whole thing's
taken care of. You just want to say, "Oh, well, there's a hybrid
pack that funds this." It's like, dude, I don't think so, man.
Back on Twitch? I've been back on Twitch for a long time, man.
>> There's no hybrid funding mechanism. The money is directly
from Pierre Omidyar. Pierre Omidyar funds this reporting residence.
It is a fellowship. He funds a lot in journalism. I am allowed
to take part in the fellowship. Again, through these journalistic
ethics codes. Now, if it was a dark money fund, if it was the
1630 fund doing a journalistic fellowship, I couldn't take part
in that, because I don't know who's funding >> Okay, so
the reason why the Omidyar Network says that they don't receive
outside funding is because it's one of these dual-structured
hybrid dark money funds. They themselves don't get money from
an outside fund. All of it comes from the dual the hybrid entity,
the LLC half, which doesn't report where all of its money comes
from.
>> So, like, this would be a huge scandal. If you could
just prove her wrong here, if you could just prove that they're
taking a whole bunch of money that's not from Pierre Omidyar,
that most of this company's money comes from like a whole bunch
of different billionaires who are trying to who aren't named.
Like, not even billionaires, sorry. If you could just prove that
like large sums of money are coming in from identities unknown,
just people unknown,
then you would have like a story here.
Right? Cuz that the The reason she's saying that you could do
the reporters in residence thing is because you know most of
that money, if not all of it, comes from Pierre Omidyar himself.
That it's not dark. But if you could show that a significant
portion, maybe half or more of it, is coming from like a dark
source, then wouldn't that be wouldn't you just win
I think we kind of looked through their their billing or whatever,
like how they had their funding set up actually. I remember looking
through Open Secrets on this stuff back when we originally covered
it in August last year. >> report it it comes from Pierre
Omidyar. It's his money. >> it doesn't. It doesn't all
it is his fund, but it's not just him funding it. Our programmatic
work is funded entirely via our foundation and LLC. That foundation
and LLC
Okay, no, money can come from anywhere for that. >> Show
me one piece of Show me one piece of evidence that any money
for the reporting in residence fund did not come from Pierre
Omidyar.
It comes directly from Pierre Omidyar. He funds it. >> Do
you understand You know that a person in an LLC are two different
things, >> Yes, but he funds the program. He funds the
program and it's his money. >> I know I know that the Occupy
Wall Street people, corporate people, you seem to be confused
on this, okay? An LLC is not a person.
>> You're You're confused, Taylor. You're
You're You're just confused, okay? I'm so happy that she does
this back to him all the time.
That she can be passive-aggressive, too, cuz Jesus. >> Right,
so when you say he's funding it directly, that's not true. Even
if what you were saying was true, you could say he is the sole
funder through an LLC.
You don't know who funds it cuz it's a dark money fund. That's
the whole thing. You have NO IDEA WHO FUNDS THE LLC. >> But
But the thing is is nobody would have a problem with the dark
money funds if the person giving the money just said, "Yeah,
it's me."
That's the whole problem is they don't say, "Yeah, that's me."
The thing here that's happening is Pierre Omidyar is standing
up and going, "Hey, that's me. I'm doing that. I'm doing that
thing. That's me doing that thing. That's me. Me, Pierre Omidyar,
I'm doing it. Look, it's got my name on the thing. See Omidyar
Group? Me, Pierre Omidyar. Hi.
Right? That's why it's not dark money. I'll tell you. >> I
Destiny, I promise you I do know who funds it. Pierre Omidyar
funds it directly. We know that. He brags about it. It's a whole
thing. That's the reason why he does this program. I don't know
what to tell you. I couldn't freelance Do you think all of these
journalists, all of these mainstream
>> Oh, hold on. Somebody linked something in the chat.
Page 11, private equity from 2023.
Oh, there's a problem here is basically, I think this this thing
does like investments or something. The Omidyar Oh, Omidyar Network
Fund. They have like a They have like an investment arm or something
like this. Like they actually do investments.
And so, I think for the investments, it's entirely possible they
get some money from outside places. But I do believe for the
for the program stuff, is like specifically this journalistic
they they have they probably have a thing set up, right? They
would have to. They're going to fund journalists, they would
need to have like a like a provenance for the money to for the
journalist to say when they go to some employer and they say
that employer goes, "Oh, I think you took money from like Qataris,
let's say, like Destiny said. I watched this stupid Destiny video,
and I heard you take money from Qataris." They'd probably need
some way to go, "No, no, no, it's this is what it is, actually."
>> I couldn't freelance Do you think all of these journalists,
all of these mainstream journalists that work at at major mainstream
outlets, do you think that they would be allowed to sign ethics
policies that we sign if we were part of a dark money org? No,
we're not. >> None of you I don't think there is a policy
that says you could have never accepted money from any other
type of super PAC or hybrid 501c401c.
>> my god. Absolutely. You cannot work as a journalist
and take super PAC money or dark money from political orgs. >> Dude,
dude, that was just an insane thing to say with no basis for
saying
That's like a totally insane thing to
Uh there's no way that they'd make you say that you like haven't
lobbied for like Raytheon if you wanted to be a
Uh, yeah, I I think there would be, wouldn't there? Like I think
there would be a lot of questions like that. Like, hey, you need
to either if you've done something like that you need to disclose
it or you need to have not done anything like this. Obviously,
you can't do it while you work for us.
Right? Obviously, that would be the
>> You absolutely cannot do that. You would never ever
be able to do that. That would be very >> Oh, this is another
good point. Yes, Kilo, exactly. That like when she goes to do
freelance work for a place and they're going to put their name
on it, yeah, they're going to want it like want a guarantee from
you that you're not taking money from somebody else to publish
that work. For sure. >> very unethical and it would be
against any journalistic code of ethics that you
>> Dude, Destiny's secret power is just sounding super
confident when he doesn't know what the [__] he's
talking about. And him and Andrew Wilson are the exact same in
this precise way. That when they are uncertain of something,
they will just their way through it. They will just act extremely
confident and say things and and basically challenge the other
person to try to take them on on that front. It's very funny
to watch. Cuz they're honestly so good at it that people who
know what they're talking about get like scared and don't call
them out. Like I swear, that my favorite example of this is Andrew
Wilson debating with Destiny actually. And Andrew Wilson goes,
"Huh, okay, Destiny, you don't think that if we cut all the women
out of the workforce, you don't think wages would go up? Do you
not understand how supply and demand works, Destiny? Are you
a
And he said it so confidently, this thing about removing 50%
of the workforce or ostensibly about 50% of the workforce and
how it would have positive effects on the economy, that Destiny
didn't call him out. Now, Destiny's an
But I was I was freaking the [__] out when I heard
that. Dude, that's the most incorrect thing I've ever heard in
my life. Like you don't understand economies of scale, you don't
understand anything. You're a total [__] if you say
[__] like that. It's like, oh, are you referring
to like in the 2 weeks before everything crashes, like people
would pay a lot more for labor? Yeah, probably.
>> possibly agree to. That is like basic 101 journalism.
>> Another good point, Tim Pool. Yes. >> That would
be crazy if a journalist did that. Because then they would they
could be getting secretly paid by political by people with political
agendas.
>> But you can always be getting paid by people with political
agendas. >> No, you No, no, you can't. Not through a Not
through a PAC or a or a dark
>> This is the whole thing with with Tenet,
No, you can't. Chorus is Chorus is something that just spun up,
And Brian Tyler Cohen's put his name on it. In fact, like I think
you kind of know that Chorus is going to fund Dem stuff. You
you just know that, right?
But where the money's coming from in all of this, like that does
get concerning. And again, it's the same PV hypothetical. You
don't know who's giving the money. I think with BTC it's a little
less concerning in terms of their purpose, but like that is not
the case with the Omidyar Group. That's not the case I just I
had another point I was going to make. Hold on, let me make it.
>> Because then they would they could be getting secretly
paid by political >> The idea that you could always be
getting No, no, no, this was the thing with Tenet. That's what
I was going to. So with Tenet, that's a new place that's spinning
up. They're getting money from somewhere, and it's totally shady,
And so you think, "Oh, that should be As soon as you can't see
where the money's coming from, and people are just making promises
to you, ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding." Some alarm
bells should be going off, right? It's much easier It's much
easier than anybody will admit, I guess, to you know, have some
idea of where your money's coming from. Have some idea that it's
not coming from an improper source, at the very least. And I
would say none of the creators who are doing the Chorus stuff
know for a fact that it's not coming from an improper source,
because they can't know the source at all.
It's not a business that makes money. It's just taking donations
from someone,
>> by people with political agendas.
>> But you can always be getting paid by people with political
agendas. >> No, you No, no, you can't. Not through a Not
through a PAC or a or a dark money group and and be a working
journalist >> could just I could just pay you. If I were
to give you $20,000,
how would the New York Times know? >> You can't accept
I guess technically you could lie, but that again that would
you would be fired and it would be a big news story. That's crazy.
You couldn't That you you're not even allowed to accept a gift
over $50 if you're a journalist. >> Yeah, but who wouldn't
I'm just saying that the idea that this is I'm guessing that
if you like I'm guessing there's probably a precedent for like
journalistic organizations to ask for somebody's taxes.
Right? Like I don't know I don't know if you would ask for straight-up
all the time, but I'm guessing you would want somebody's like
tax returns at some point to make sure that they're not like
declaring income that you're not aware
Right? I'm guessing there could be some circumstances that lead
to this beyond the fact that like if you're just taking money
from somebody to write totally
crazy [__] Right? They would have to start looking
into you if your opinion start diverging if there's some something
improper seems to be happening.
Cook those easily though, couldn't you?
I don't know if you can or not. I'm guessing there's some way
if you're if you're trying to do due diligence like that, I'm
guessing
I'm guessing there's some way to do due diligence like that that
wouldn't allow you to cook that [__] There has to
be, right? There just has to be cuz there's too many lines of
work in the US that would require you not getting payments from
undue like improper sources. There has to be some way of checking
this, right? >> This is like an impossible thing or whatever.
Here, I'll back it up just a little bit. >> Technically
you could lie, but that again that would you would be fired and
it would be a big news story. That's crazy. You couldn't That
you you're not even allowed to accept a gift over $50 if you're
a journalist. >> Yeah, but who wouldn't I'm just saying
that the idea that this is like an impossible thing or whatever.
And the And this focus on like Oh, see this is where you're confused
here, King Ghidorah. He's not questioning her impartiality. He
doesn't actually believe she's like done something wrong in terms
of accepting that money. He's saying that she's a hypocrite and
that she shouldn't criticize Cenk Uygur for taking money from
something that he deems similar. But it's not similar. He's wrong.
And so, he's not even concerned about her impartiality. He's
not calling her biased. He's not like even doing anything like
that. He's just trying to do like a hypocrite check on her and
he's failing.
>> quote unquote dark money. Like you don't have any idea.
Like I'm sure that they ask you for political >> They can't
There's no way unless they have your tax returns. Nobody can
know who you're getting paid from unless they have a copy of
your tax return. >> You're I get >> Like Like you're
basically arguing that politicians can just take bribes.
And there's nothing you could ever do about it. Right? Like
Like I
Yeah, this is technically true and until you get caught, like
there's not a problem technically.
But you're like risking everything by doing it. We don't just
assume this bad conduct without any proof.
That's It's insane.
Yeah, technically anybody could be taking like bribe money from
Russia to do any number of things at any given point in time.
But if we operated that way with that level of like schizo concern
about everyone in the world, the world would fall apart.
Is like obviously we're to do? >> I mean, sure you could
go steal something from a store and nobody would know. That doesn't
mean that it's not a crime. Like what are you talking about?
It's not a crime. >> on. Ethics agreements are not going
to be the same thing as like a crime. If you violate an ethics
agreement for something that you signed for a journalistic thing.
>> be You would not work in journalism. You would not work
in journalism. And let me tell you, there's >> Does anybody
find it funny that this is coming on the heels of Destiny entertaining
like taking a paid killing trip to Israel where he's like pretty
much saying outright on his stream, "I'm pretty sure they just
want to pay me to like super hardcore shill for Israel."
I I feel like these are coming together at a really coincidental
time.
Did you guys see that or am I Am I only one who saw that?
That Destiny was like on his stream the other day talking about
how like someone from Israel basically had a He had meetings
with them, too. It's funny cuz he didn't let that on right away.
Originally, he's like, "I got an email from people who said they
wanted to fly me to Israel, and they wanted me to like pay for
And then And then eventually it gets to the point where he's
like, "Yeah, I like took some meetings with them." And she's
like, "Dude, you you 100%
know for a fact
that he just wants that money, dog. He just wants that money.
All right, here it is. Here's the scree- Destiny taking paid
trip to Israel. Seems Destiny is considering taking up an offer
for a paid trip to Israel. A sponsored trip to Israel to enjoy
it as a free vacation. Dan tries to talk him into not going in
order to maintain the supposed optical high ground over Hasan
with respect to having never taken money to do any content for
another nation.
>> It's like isn't the fact that isn't the idea that Destiny
would even
entertain this?
Like this is incredibly low IQ behavior to like entertain this
and talk about it on your stream.
It's like incredibly low IQ.
Right? Like to not connect this to This is like some hutch stuff.
To not connect this to like other concepts in your head at all?
I don't get it. Like it's actually really stupid. >> Some
company reached out to give me a huge sponsored trip to Israel,
and I'm considering whether I want to take it or
>> Yeah. Yeah, that's what I thought, Placido, when I first
saw it. Was like I I thought he was going to go, "Oh, I fooled
you guys." And then he literally just like goes on and it becomes
very clear that he's not joking. Yeah, that's what I thought,
bad ABB. But then he like literally talks about taking a meeting
with them. And she's >> Yeah, cuz I just don't want to
give a [__] anymore about this country. >> But
wait, but what company though? Like to go like look at their
data centers or just to like go over there and do
>> No, it's like
this is definitely Israeli, and it's definitely like slanted
in that direction. Like I think like I think like five of the
nine days are in Tel >> So Hasan can do his China trip?
>> Who Yeah, who is I don't know the name of the company
is. They reach out to you with people. I had a Zoom call with
like four of them and then Yeah, I don't
I don't know. I'll think about it.
You can do whatever, but does it actually sound interesting?
No offense, but I hate these really public almost as much as
the American one for contributing to MAGA.
Um I just don't The thing is it's just it's just all it just
wasted on me. I just don't It's travel and care to see [__]
and I'm not like a party person at all, so Um Are you really
seeing the Israeli interviews from 2024? I have my They're loaded
up. Okay. >> Oh, maybe it's nice that you can say
like I've never taken money to do any content ever and [__]
you cuz you have. I don't think it's worth it. >> gives
a [__]
>> Yeah, but you can say it and feel good about saying
that and they won't be able to respond with yeah, you did and
here's where you admitted it. Like they can conspiracy post it.
>> Uh Krieger, there's just no reason to believe that if
he planned this to go in like a month that there's any going
to be any capacity for people to actually hit him in that country.
It's just it like you you you'd be fine.
The only people who are By the way, the only people who are getting
hit in one of these cities are people who don't care to leave
when the missile sirens go off like me. I would probably get
killed in one of these countries in sorry, in Israel. I'd be
like, "No, I'm I'm playing video games. [__] you."
Wee wee wee. No, I don't care. I'm sitting here. Okay? But if
you just go into the missile the missile shelter, you're not
getting hit. >> Saying that you did. I I just I don't I
don't think it's worth it. >> Well, I'm not how am I getting
[__] Like Mike got what 20,000 likes on a tweet a
few days ago saying I got paid $7,000
a post.
>> Yeah, but it's untrue, right?
>> The largest leftist streamer literally did like a paid
propaganda trip to China like an unfathomable
I don't know where the cope comes from that Hasan did that for
paid propaganda. Hassan is like a total campus. He believes America
bad. He loves China.
Like Hassan is like every possible way on China, okay?
Hassan absolutely did that [__] for the love of the
game. I'm sorry. He 100% did that [__] for the love
of the game. He thinks China's awesome. He's like like That's
just like that just like I kind of believe, although it's getting
less certain, that Destiny's original trip to Israel was just
for the love of the game. But Jesus, he probably did take money
for it. But so what what's weird to me is Asmongold came out
and said, "I know because I talked to certain people and they
know for a fact that he didn't take money from it." To me, that's
him signaling that he's got connections and that they looked
into it, right? And unfortunately,
in the year of our Lord
Asmongold is probably talking to like half of the Republican
cabinet. I hate to say it, okay?
Yeah, I know Vrain. I know the tweet. Mike said, "Oh, you know,
Israeli influencers got caught taking $7,000 a post." Or actually,
they sued Israel because they weren't getting paid $7,000 per
post. And it was the lawsuit coming out and then Mike joked that,
"Oh, this must be why Destiny doesn't talk about Israel anymore."
>> Only crazy propaganda pro-China pro-CCP China propaganda
trip. >> What do you get? Like like how much are you really
saving here to to give them the ultimate forever du >> I
can I can take all this money because Hassan is bad. >> W,
aren't you? >> It's How is it a W, though? It's It would
be These guys would be covering my uh travel and it's not like
they're going to be telling me like you have to film this, you've
got to put this out or whatever. Like I'm a a viewer and it's
really going to be a >> It would be the conspiracies afterwards
and all this >> What would be different? It's just It's
just like that whether or not It just comes down to whether I
want a free vacation out of it. That's all it is. >> Well,
well, yeah. Do the pro >> No, it >> This guy really
doesn't have like um a conscience or a like soul. You know what
I'm saying? He like doesn't He I truly believe when he says this
that this is what he means. That he doesn't see a difference.
That like acting good doesn't matter unless people think you're
good.
Right? Being a good person doesn't matter unless people will
tell you you're a good person. Being a bad person doesn't matter
if people will tell you you're a bad person without you doing
the bad thing. Like it it actually it's so soulless. It's so
God, I This is why like if you watch both streams, I'm like more
and more over time. I'm just like, "Dude, you uh you got to go.
I don't want I don't I want total separation from like um audience-wise,
I'm totally fine covering Destiny. I like covering Destiny stuff
when it's like the Taylor Lorenz thing cuz it just reminds me.
But like if you're if you're a viewer legitimately, I just I
sit here and I'm like, "Dude, you you need help. You need help.
You do." >> ethics? I cannot I mean >> People write
op-eds. I don't understand Anyway, back to this. So that whole
thing that whole aside was just to be like, "It's very funny
that he's like talking [__] about Taylor Lorenz at
this precise moment in time." Like two two days I guess when
his video would have come out would have been a day or two days
after he contemplated taking the the paid he he contemplated
taking the shekels, okay? >> And op-ed is not the same
as a report. So op-eds are not written by >> Hold on. I
need to go >> That would be such a major news story if
a big-time journalist did something like that. Would be such
a gross violation of journalistic ethics. I cannot I mean >> People
write op-eds. I don't understand People write op-eds.
THAT'S NOT WHAT THIS WAS. THAT'S NOT what this was.
This stream was a while ago, wasn't it? You might think that.
Actually, it was 6 hours ago.
You might think that because it is a replay of a conversation
that Taylor Lorenz Taylor Lorenz already bodied Destiny in, but
he decided that he didn't get bodied hard enough. And so he had
to come back for seconds, I guess, and be even more this time.
I don't know why. Just like >> And op-ed is not the same
as a report. So, op-eds are not written by reporters, right?
Op-eds are something different. That's an opinion piece. So,
a senator can write an op-ed, right? >> If you're a news
reporter, you are bound by journalistic ethics. >> Okay,
can you sort through this Can you sort Help me Like, and so,
she's not doing what Destiny does, right? Destiny's going to
Anytime Destiny's correct in the conversation, he will make a
huge deal out of it, right? But, Taylor, when she's correct and
he says something dumb, she just like lets it go and explains
and they continue moving forward, right? What she should do here
is point out, "Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Did you just confuse
like an op-ed and a regular journalistic piece, like a news piece?
Did you just confuse these two things? Why are you even criticizing
me when you don't understand the difference? Why would you bring
up op-eds? Anybody can write an op-ed. What What the [__]
are you talking about, right?" She should have done this. This
is what Destiny does to make it look like he wins
She's not doing it. But, I just I do this for like, you know,
sometimes there'll be people on YouTube who are Destiny fans,
aka very low IQ, and they need it explained to them in those
terms so that they can understand,
right? Otherwise, they're just going to be like, "You hate Destiny,
so you think he lost." Nope, I'm just going to point out to you
where she had like obvious winning points in the conversation.
You know what I'm saying? >> Help me understand this, okay?
So, like, on page 11 here, we can look at the Omidyar Network
Fund, and we can see that there is money that they get donated
to them from like private equity and other sorts of people. We
don't know who these are. This is a statement about >> That's
a link from the chat, by the way. We looked at that link from
the chat. I paused and highlighted it. That's just a link from
his chat. It's not his opinion. Um probably, if you looked into
that because you didn't have time to vet it, it would probably
just not prove his point at all. It'd probably be like explicitly
wrong.
But, nobody knows to do that because they don't understand how
he basically flows into debates and just takes points from chat
and tries to wing it. >> a political fund that's not related
to the reporters in residence program, which is solely funded
by by Pierre >> solely funded by the LLC that has a network
fund that receives dark money. That's how these entities work.
I can break it down We can go through a whole thing and break
it out if you want it, >> Destiny, I'm sorry that you feel
this way. I don't know what to tell you. If you think that there's
a secret scheme where somehow >> It's all public. It's
all known. >> Again,
this
Well, that's funny that you bring it up. It is public and known,
unlike these dark money programs, which are not public, which
are in fact >> They're also publicly known. They say, "We
have this entity. It raises money. We don't have to report everybody
that donates to it, but we report who we donate to." >> They're not
They're doing political The reason my story was a story is because
it was not politically It was not publicly known. They were not
publicly disclosing, right? >> wasn't publicly What do
you mean? >> The 1630 >> So, the the primary donor
discloses himself, and then all of the people who receive the
money disclose that they received the money. The fund itself
discloses everybody who receives money under that same program.
Dark money. >> engaging
in these influencer >> Are you twisting your mic? No, that's
one of them. >> schemes. That was something that was not
publicly known. That's engaging in these influencer schemes.
>> What do you mean? >> That's him. That's
>> That's Destiny moving his mouse or scratching something
on his keyboard. >> 1630 fund engaging in these influencer
schemes. That was something that was not publicly known. That's
why my >> fund donating money or giving money to Chorus
should be in their filings. >> It was not publicly known.
That's why it wasn't known. >> their filings.
surprise, surprise, it was never known. It was never revealed.
None of these were disclosed. >> I understand. And again,
I know you do this to other people. You keep saying it wasn't
known as in it wasn't part of the mainstream news outlets, but
you're not responding to my question. Okay, hold So, here, let's
see. So, this is page 11. Program and mission-related investments.
Program and mission-related investments are strategic investments
aligned with the foundation's mission. These investments are
primarily composed of equities, equity funds, and debt.
Okay. Private equity investments
There's no way There's no way that this is their investments.
They're like as a private equity holder, their funds investments
they're holding. There's no way that
There There must be Hold on. There's no way that the person who
linked this This is page 11.
This Am I wrong or would this be not that they're getting money
from private equity, but by that but that they as a private equity
fund hold investments.
Am I crazy? There's no way it could be that bad. There's just
no possible way.
I don't think so. I don't I don't think it could possibly be
that bad, right? As of December 31st, 2023 and 2022, the foundation
had unfunded commitments of 1.5 million and 1.6 million dollars
related to program and mission-related investments in companies
and limited partnerships, respectively.
The unfunded commitments to private equity and venture capital
funds can be called at any time at the request of general partners
and are not accrued until
Private equity There's no I can't tell. I can't tell. It seems
It seems like what they're holding, right?
Investments. Convertible security This is like what they're holding.
It's not Right? It's not
These are investments in private equity. Yeah. They're not They're
not like them taking money from private equity.
So, okay. Fantastic. Unfunded commitment equals capital you pay
into a private equity fund as a limited partner. So, this is
The Omidyar like network fund putting money into things. So,
it's not them taking money from private equity. And he just brought
this point up because he's a
who grabbed some stupid like from chat.
Sorry, sorry. I didn't have time to read the entire document.
Dude. Yeah, we we read this already, Canadian caller, earlier
in the stream. It's just dude, it's it's
tragic. It's tragic. Although, maybe hold on. Maybe investment
valuation.
Maybe it's this paragraph No, it's not this paragraph either.
I can already tell it's not this paragraph.
They read the words private equity and their eyes lit up and
they're like, "Oh, we got them. We got them, boys. We got
It's It's so tragic to watch.
>> And Destiny, I'm sorry that you feel this way. I I don't
know what to tell you. If you think that there's a secret >> I
love that I landed right there. I'm so sorry that you feel that
Dude, her like patronizing tone is so funny to me every single
time. It's so funny.
I'm so I'm so sorry you feel that way. >> you feel this
way. I I don't know what to tell you. If you think that there's
a secret scheme >> It's not secret. It's all public. It's
all known.
>> Again, this
It Well, that's funny that you bring it up. It is public and
known. Unlike these dark money programs, which are not public,
which are in >> also publicly known. They say, "We have
this entity. It raises money. We don't have to report everybody
that donates to it, but we report who we donate to."
Outside of the thing that's explicitly the problematic thing
that's not disclosed, they disclose everything.
Outside of the explicit thing we're talking about, they disclose
everything else. Yeah, I Okay.
Bro, it's like the weirdest sophistry all the time.
It's It's crazy. >> They're not They're doing political
The reason my story was a story is because it was not politically
It was not publicly known. They were not publicly disclosing.
Right? >> Wait, what wasn't publicly? What do you >> The
1630 fund engaging in these influencer schemes, that was something
that was not publicly known. That's why >> fund donating
money or giving money to Chorus should be in their filings. >> It
was not publicly known. That's why it >> in their filings.
surprise, surprise, it was never known. It was never revealed.
Not a bit. >> say I understand and again, I know you do
this other people. You keep saying it wasn't known as in it wasn't
part of the mainstream who's that guy sitting there, but you're
not responding to my question. You're very good at these conversations.
You're very tricky. You're very tricky. I'll give you one example.
Is showing up in the media? No. But you're alleging you >> So,
even if the 1630 fund discloses, like the thing with dark money
isn't that they don't disclose disclose who they give the money
to, right? Super PACs disclose what candidates they fund.
That's not the thing that makes it dark money or not dark money.
Like the fact that 1630 was funding Courier's was not something
that was mysterious or confusing or unknown. That was known.
The problem is is you don't know where the money is coming into
1630 fund from and that you don't know the influencers it's going
to. That's the problem. The dark money aspect is is how the 1630
fund gets money in, right?
That people know that they fund random groups, other PACs or
other
>> You acknowledge that what you're alleging would be like
an FEC violation, right? If these entities were giving large
sums of money to people and they wasn't showing up on any of
their filings, that this would be illegal. >> Um first
>> Like there's just a better argument here and that's
that I believe Courier's just announced that the 1630 fund was
helping them like funding their incubator
Like it's obviously publicly disclosed that the 1630 fund is
funding the incubator program. I believe there was a news there's
like a press release on this. You don't have to go to filings.
That was known that they were going to fund influencers to do
the Democrat messaging thing. >> First of all, it's not
an FEC violation because there's no FEC ruling that says
you know, you have to disclose your influencer sort of efforts
or whatever, >> disclose your efforts. No, no, no. For
these hybrid entities, the ones that do this the pairing of the
I haven't read about these ones. I was like the C3 C4 pairings
or whatever, these hybrid entities. You don't have to report
where the money is coming from, but you do have to report where
the money goes to. So, on the So, my understanding is I would
have to go back and look at all this cuz the the >> The
funny thing is I do believe Progressive Victory operated this
way at
Where they didn't have to Maybe they never had to disclose. I
I could You tell with Progressive Victory if they made a mistake
by doing the public disclosures, the public filings, or cuz they
said they made a mistake. But I couldn't tell if it was like,
"Oh, we got caught. So now basically now that somebody's pointed
out that we're not disclosing all of our payments, we actually
do have to make the payments publicly." Cuz I know people were
waiting for the FEC filings for a while from Progressive Victory.
So I just can't remember if if it was truly a mistake or if they
sort of got caught and they're like, "Oh, we probably should
be disclosing all of this stuff." >> Tax structures
You might want to go back and for my edification because you
don't see you don't understand how these things work. >> The
C3 or the C4 whatever will receive money and then they don't
have to report where the money's coming from, but they can dump
a lot of that money into a C3 that does have to report where
it's coming from. So like we'll say like we're getting money
from the 60/30 Fund and then they'll say that we're paying it
out to >> Wait. The C4 doesn't go to the C3. That's not
how these things work. I believe it's the LLC can take the and
that's like opaque. And then the LLC can dump money into the
501c4, C3, or whatever, right? Or vice versa. It's one of the
two. It's It's the LLC interacting with the C3 or C4. It's not
the C3 or C4 into each other. >> certain creators or whatever.
You have depending on the type of entity that they're structured
under, but >> So show me where any of that happened prior
to my story. >> Well, I want to see where the I want you
to link me where the reporters and resi-
>> C4s don't have to disclose donors, C3s do. Well, then
why are we even having this discussion, Porter Ballard? Because
because the Omidyar Fund is like a or the Omidyar Network is
a 501c3 LLC
If they just have to disclose their the people funding that it's
over already.
I think it's the LLC that can take the money in and pay it out.
I think. >> the LLC that they're getting the money >> Destiny.
Woah, woah, you just changed the topic. >> Well, no, no,
you This is how you changed No, no, no, you changed this from
this and you changed the
Sorry, let me go back. >> You have depending So like we'll
say like we're getting money from the 60/30 Fund and then they'll
say that we're paying it out to certain creators or whatever.
You have depending on the type of entity that they're structured
under, but >> So show me where any of that happened prior
to my story. >> Well, I want to see where the I want you
to link me where the reporters and residents, the LLC that they're
getting the money from. >> Destiny. Woah, woah, you just
changed the topic. Well, no, no, you Don't show me that they
like after I reported it, after I had a Wired publication on
this topic, don't show me they disclosed then. Show me where
they disclosed before that. Is it you changed No, no, you changed
it from this and you changed to this. So, I'm asking you, can
you show me what Show me where No, no, you Wait, you acknowledge
the conversation started with the Omidyar thing, right? Yeah,
that's what I said you started. >> Yeah. Before you derail
>> I'm not derailing. I'm rerailing.
>> I want to close loop on what you said. You said that
there was disclosure about >> Oh, man. >> this funding
program before my article. >> There are a bunch of places
where There are a bunch of places where basically the chat starts
calling him out. I do believe he starts banning people.
Say he's losing. >> Well, show me where that was. >> I
would have to go and look up the web archives of the page to
see if it to where it was I don't have this information offhand.
>> have it because it doesn't exist. >> Well, I don't
have it offhand because I wasn't ready for it that conversation.
I have to go get the links through this. >> All right.
I very much would love for you to find that. And I think that
when you go to find it, you will find it doesn't exist because
prior to my article, none of this was public. And that is the
whole problem, I would argue, with these funding systems is that
unless a journalist gets a hold of it, they're not inherently
public or they're not inherently disclosed to the followers of
these influencers while they're creating this content. And that's
a problem. I'm a journalist, I disclose where I get my money.
Now, you seem to have some issue with the Omidyar's reporting
and residents program. I can promise you that it is not a grand
conspiracy that myself and all of these other journalists have
taken part in this program and that it's somehow, you know, I
don't know, you're sort of conflating it with the 1630 fund.
It's nothing like that. Not to mention >> like that. It
is. >> It's not It's not like Not to mention Well, I'll
say the second part. Destiny,
an investigative journalism fellowship is nothing like a political
a secret political influencer program at all. >> What was
secret? Wait, what part is >> It was never public. The
The funding
program with chorus was never public. It was never public. It
was never disclosed. None of these influencers disclosed it.
That's the whole problem. >> Hold on. Hold on. Wait. Wait.
You're What you're You're making different statements. Whether
or not an influencer disclosed whether or not they're part of
chorus is a fundamentally different claim than whether or not
the chorus reports where their money comes from or if the 1630
fund reports >> disclosed that they ran a secretive
funding program for influencers. That was never public. That
was never public. That's why my story was a story because >> I
thought they did say that the 1630 fund was funding them, but
maybe that might have been after the story after her story dropped.
Uh 1630
funding chorus.
Wait. I didn't see that this happened. How did we miss this?
Comer launches investigation into 1630 funds reported secretive
chorus program effort to evade campaign finance laws. This was
100% by the way like a explicit effort to evade campaign finance
law.
Like that's it it was like when Brian Tyler Cohen set it up,
he made the pitch decks and everything. It was obviously made
to put out dem messaging and then the way they set up the the
structure was as a non-partisan
PAC. Like it was just explicitly
dodging campaign finance
Not good. Okay? Not good. I assume tons of Republicans do it,
but for whatever reason these are super they have like maximum
solidarity. They'll never rat each other out. I don't know what
it is.
Basically, the issue was they didn't want the creators known,
but they did say that they were starting like an incubator program.
I could have sworn that they might have even gone so far as doing
a 1630 announcement like a we're being funded our incubator thing
is being funded by the 1630
fund. The vest or whatever stuff Any kind of like thing like
that from the 1630 fund, all of that has to be on a public tax
filing. >> I have no idea, but regardless >> Wait,
how can you have Taylor, if you're reporting on this, how can
you have no idea if the statement I just said is true or not?
>> Show me where it was public. So show me where it was
public. Before I publish my story, show me where it was public.
>> Okay, so here's a form 990. This is 117 pages long.
This is of the 1630 fund. This is for 2024. I would have to I
guess go find their 2025 one, but this here should have every
single thing listed in terms of where their money
>> So show me where So show me where So show me where it's
disclosed.
>> I don't even know I don't know what the entity is registered
under. I can find this information for you, but it's going to
take me some time. I can't I don't have this right on my fingertips.
>> If you're going to But if you're going to say this argument
that this was was all public and that it was disclosed,
where was it disclosed? >> Oh, you Okay, so then let me
understand. You're saying that they hid this, that it was not
disclosed on legally required
>> I No, if you read article >> Do you see how tricky
you're being? I can see how tricky you're being. I don't make
my life >> Where did they break the law? >> Uh no,
I'm saying it's like a ethical failure. I'm saying it's like
a professional failure. I'm saying it's like a problem. It's
a moral problem. Like you Destiny of all people understands the
difference between like a moral issue and a legal issue, right?
And he just he's going to like go, "Well, wait, where did they
violate the law? How could bad behavior have occurred if they
didn't violate the
>> A lot of people can't see how tricky you are sometimes,
but like you're not answering that question. >> Destiny,
I mean I'm answering your question, but I don't know >> No,
no, my question Is he Is he objectively doing like the He's doing
a little thing here, right?
I've heard this before. People can't see how tricky you're being.
People can't see how you're being you're really manipulative.
I don't want to bring it up, okay? He's kind of doing the Kelly
Do you remember the Kelly Jean tries to be a human being thing
where she was like writing down notes?
And then Destiny talked to her was like, "Oh, this is how you're
being so manipulative the all the time." Right? I feel like it's
the same thing. Same thing going on. Except far less valid this
time. >> Question very specifically was we here Okay, it's
two questions and then you can answer to both of these. One is
would it be legally required for the 1630 fund to disclose that
money was flowing out to an entity like this? Number one. And
number two, are you saying that they did not disclose that against
the law? >> None of neither of those things were were in
my article. Neither. >> Can you answer either of those
questions or no? Can you not? You're really not going to? >> actually,
if you if you pull if you if you want to make those claims, I
think you should be the one to back it up. >> I'm not the
journalist. I'm just a lowly influencer. The 1630 fund paid me
$900 million this year to to press you on this article. >> making
claims, so back so back them up. So show me where your receipts
>> Pisco should debate Destiny while using his Destiny
impression from a couple weeks ago.
I don't know where Pisco is on this. I feel like Pisco
What the What the actual What's that
I don't know what point he's making here. He Like the whole point
of this conversation is to get mad at the article, right? Like
I would even say, "Bro, there are actual criticisms you could
make." Uh why do I have to I kind of agree with the criticisms,
but uh sorry, like Taylor's side. But there are actual criticisms
you could make. Like, "Oh, well, in practice, they don't actually
do this, right?" Cuz the implication is like, "Oh, there's something
really shady going on here and they're like trying to bully people
into doing something." And it's like, "No, they're like trying
to flout campaign finance law for the sake of like funding Democrats
and like left more left-leaning aligned candidates or sorry,
influencers. Right? Like that's the goal of what they're doing.
Is they're trying to dodge campaign finance law to fund people
on your side. And so, while they are doing something that's probably
like maybe a little unethical,
it's being done for like a good reason. And so, maybe like drawing
only attention to that could be bad. But I don't even hear that
argument, right? I just hear like
Wait, what are they doing that's illegal? And Taylor's just like,
"Well, why are you critiquing things that aren't even in the
article?"
>> Can you answer either of those questions or no? Can
you not? You're really not going to? >> Actually, if you
if you pull if you if you want to make those claims, I think
you should be the one to back it up. >> the journalist.
I'm just a lowly influencer. The 65 fund made me $900 this year
to to press down on >> You're out here making claims, so
so back them up. >> I did. You can go back. I did a researcher
with this like 6 months ago when the article came out. You go
look at the VOD if you want. Or I can find this information >> I
proved you wrong 6 months ago. If you
I believe you talked to her after that and still got blown the
[__] out 6 months ago. Why is he rewriting everything?
>> Yeah, we can have a talk in a few days if you want.
>> in that in the VOD, you don't you you don't you don't
ever show proof, ever. >> In the one where we went over
this like 5 or 6 months ago? >> You do not show proof that
there was disclosure prior to my article. You do not show that.
>> are public.
>> Show me where it was disclosed. Show me where it was
disclosed prior to my article that there was this political influencer
your program that they were funding.
>> By the way, I can't find this either. So, I I literally
can't find it either. It might be that they didn't disclose it
until after. >> that they were funding influencers. Show
me where that was disclosed. >> Okay, I will add this to
my >> me where the and show me and also >> Horus
1630 fund
uh form 990 disclosure
before Taylor article. I will look this up for you >> And also,
will you do me a favor as well? Show me the list of influencers
that received the funding. Can you show me that as well cuz you're
arguing >> to disclose that part. I don't know if the Horus
entity
>> Oh, well, since you're so confident >> it? We're
talking about multiple entities here. I don't know if you don't
know how these are working in in conjunction with each other
or if you're just relying on like the tricky language in order
>> There's no tricky language. She's complaining about
the funding to the influencers specifically not being
Cuz obviously, that's like that is the primary like um what would
you say? Like the primary comparison to political funding is
basically there's the joke about how, you know, politicians you
want them to wear like NASCAR jackets that show all their sponsorships
on it, right? Where they get money from? It's like the same thing
for streamers. If your streamers are getting money from someone,
you want to know where that money is coming from.
Like if they're getting, sorry, politically motivated for money,
like a significant portion of their income is coming from somewhere,
you'd probably want to know that, right? If it's totally disjoint
coming from a bunch of different sources that are all donations,
then maybe that's less concerning, right? Probably. Maybe. >> To
not actually have to answer any questions related to any of this
stuff. >> All of these ridiculous attacks, and I'm just
asking you to back up your claims. If you claim that it was all
public, show me where it was public. >> games. I never
claimed it was all public. I claimed that these should show up
on public filings. >> Show me where they showed up. >> Okay,
I'll I'll look it up for you. I will look it up for you. I'll
find the forms. I'll throw them at you. I'll have you I'm sure
you'll wiggle out of it another way. So, back to the Omidyar
Back to the Omidyar thing, the thing that we started talking
about, the Omidyar Taylor. For the Omidyar thing, the LLC that
funds it solely, what is this LLC? Can you give me information
about this LLC? How do you know that it only receives money from
Pierre?
>> Because again, this is a this is a investigative reporting
fellowship. >> the question. How do you know that that
LLC only receives money? I don't know I'm not asking you what
it is. I'm asking how do you know it only receives money from
Pierre? >> You're You're interrupting me. Are you ready
to listen or are you going to continue to interrupt?
>> If you can answer the question, I'm ready to listen.
>> Yes, I would not be able to participate >> answering
the question again. >> I am I am telling you the answer
to the question, and I'm sorry that it doesn't >> We already
agreed that you could just lie about your source of income, and
nobody would know, so that doesn't >> couldn't No, no,
you can't. You can't do that. I I mean
certainly I of all people could not do that. I am a very high-profile
journalist. To argue that journalists that such as myself, which
are under enormous scrutiny, are all secretly taking PAC and
dark money. Which I just want to emphasize to you, Destiny, please,
please. You continue to conflate a political influence program
with a non- non-partisan
>> You're All you're doing is All you're doing is you're
you're continuing to squirm away from the point. >> It's
not you I could say the same thing about you. Can you actually
stop making these ridiculous com- >> Okay, I'm back. You're
continuing to squirm away from the point. I'm back. I'm back.
I'm back.
It's like Okay. Like would there be a problem with me taking
Russian money to start like a like a data center? Would that
be a problem if I took Russian money if I just took like capital
investment from Russia? Like probably not, right? It's way different
to take Russian money to give your political opinion
and to extricate yourself from like how that might affect your
political opinion. Which is the problem with Tenet Media, right?
Beyond the fact that Tenet Media was also illegal. Like illegal
funding from foreign sources.
it's like it is important that it is for political speech that
you're being paid and that you don't know the source of the money.
That is an important thing. It is not exactly like the Tenet
Media thing, but it is a little just a tiny tiny bit like it,
okay? Is Destiny and Destiny's chat spitting venom about how
Taylor needs to get out of the tent? I don't believe so, no.
>> Comments about your You're squirming You're squirming
away. And can you actually engage with what I'm saying? A non-
a non-partisan journalistic investigative journalism program
is nothing like a paid political influence scheme. They're not
even remotely
That is what I was reporting on. >> Is your claim that
that LLC is solely funded by Pierre? >> That is what we
are That is That is how we are able to take part in this program.
Do you think all of the >> Are you telling me that the
LLC is solely funded by Pierre?
>> I would imagine yes, because that's how we're able to
take part in the program. >> that you would say I would
imagine seems to necessitate you using your imagination and the
reason why you have to use your imagination is because it's dark,
because you don't know. Which is fine. I don't even think it's
that big of a deal. I'm sure the Omidyar Network and everybody
they state that >> So she's getting over by the fact that
she doesn't know
precisely
like the funding mechanism and like how it trickles through and
everything. But I think she probably knows. What I'm guessing
happened was she was given like she probably asked a question
and she's probably given like some explanation of how it works
and knows the other journalists and knows that they were like,
yeah, yeah, it all checks out, it's all fine. I'm guessing she
didn't like take a ton of time looking into it. She probably
relied on other people who had gone and said, no, no, no, the
money is like clean, it comes from like here's how it actually
works, right?
His loser audience actually thinks he's so smart. It's just very
funny because again
it doesn't go to all of the things that we just when you're talking
about dark
it's just not the same. It's really not.
Right? It's It's not. >> their goals and everything, which
is why it's not a huge deal. Sending it to the 1630 Fund and
the same thing with Pierre >> To answer your question,
yes, it is funded by Pierre Omidyar. Yes, that is what we are
told when you're starting >> I didn't ask if it was funded
by Pierre Omidyar. I said it was the sole funder, Pierre Omidyar
is the LLC that it gets >> If you found out that Omidyar
was like funding 90% of it, I think you would still say that
that's like the sole funder, right?
Probably from the only person What I'm guessing happens is they
just say, like I know money's fungible, but they probably say
like explicitly no outside funds, no funds we take in from outside
from like externally.
Right? Legally speaking, no. Well, I'm not saying legally speaking.
I'm saying the the question is, is the Omidyar Group funded in
a way that makes it like really hard to know where Taylor Lorenz
is getting her money from?
And what I'm saying is probably not because it's the Omidyar
Network. Cuz it's not like a random faceless, nameless company.
Like the 1630 fund,
That is literally this guy's thing that uses his reputation,
that that takes money and uses his reputation
>> So he puts money in the LCS Pierre
>> Or or perhaps his, you know, maybe he puts it in through
something else. But yes, it's Pierre Omidyar's money. Yes. Yes.
It is Pierre Omidyar's money. >> It's a dark money fund.
The reason why you can't answer the question, you know, it is.
It is. Which is fine. It's not a >> It is not. It is not.
I don't know what to tell you other than I could not participate
in doing journalism if I was And do you think all of the other
journalists, putting me aside, there's major journalists, right,
that take part in this investigative non-partisan
reporting fellowship. But I I am I believe you that you think
all of this is some big collusion. Regardless, Destiny, why don't
you engage with the fact that a non-partisan,
non-political investigative reporting fellowship is nothing like
a secret political influence cam- campaign that is aimed at fixing
Democrats Democrats messaging problem problem. >> So just
as a quick thing, okay, I just want to say cuz you're again,
I have to call these out cuz I know I'm not receiving cuz you're
very tricky and you're very good. So you're arguing you're arguing
you're arguing No, I am. >> You're so tricky. You're so
tricky. You're so tricky. You're so tricky. >> She's not
trying to be tricky. She doesn't know the actual legal ease,
She doesn't know it. She actually doesn't know.
She doesn't know specifically like how the entities are set up
and how but I promise you it's like she she talked like somebody
who cared, right? She's not being tricky. She's She doesn't want
to say it cuz she knows she's probably watched some Destiny content
before. She knows when she goes, "Oh, well, no, I talked to like
this person and that person and that person and they looked into
it and they assured me it was good." And he'll go, "OH, LIKE
GOT YOU, BITCH."
>> I am going to call her out. You're arguing that you're
not receiving a dark money thing. You're not You're arguing that
you're not receiving a dark money thing. But then you're saying
that what you do is a lot different than what Cenk does, which
I agree. You are correct. No, no, you are correct. Cenk and what
you do are different and they're they're different, which is
why the reporting requirements are different, but you both receive
dark money. But I think that they should have a higher onus to
report, but I believe they were doing their legally required
reporting. I don't think they were doing like concealing anything
that needed to be legally required. >> They did not disclose
it. Not what Again, show me one influencer that disclosed that
they were part of this dark money political scheme. Show me one
influencer that disclosed that >> influencers were part
of a dark money political scheme. The influencers getting money
from Corus. These are different These are different entities.
Do I have to explain it to you again? Corus gets money from a
dark money influence scheme, okay? But Corus they once that money
comes in, now it's not dark anymore, okay? Now it's not dark.
What? What the [__] you saying?
the whole point is you don't know if that's um Oh, I just lost
the name. You don't know if that's like Linda McMahon, okay?
There's another Republican donor. I was going to do Oh, uh Miriam
Adelson. You don't know if it's like Miriam Adelson giving that
money. You literally don't know. You have no idea. You got no
clue, man. Yes, right? >> Influencers Corus is described
as a project of the 1630 Fund. >> But it's a separate entity.
Why would this
I I watched this earlier. I didn't pick up how particularly this
argument is. That Corus when Corus gets the money from the dark
money group, it's actually not dark money anymore. That's what
he's trying to do right now. Like what kind of super like just
incredibly pedantic like gotcha is this? Oh, you think it's the
dark money group funding them? No, no, no, no, no. They're part
of Corus. It's just Corus that gets all the money for this incubator
program that allows them to pay the influencers. Like it's only
Corus accepting dark money, okay? Come >> It was solely
funded by the 1630 Fund, right? I believe, right? >> Corus
is described in documents >> You can't answer the question
as a song. Sorry, go ahead. >> Okay, if you know what?
If you're going to keep making these aside comments and say these
things it's not going to be we're not going to >> The Yeah,
no no doubt Kennedy caller. This also totally invalidates his
own argument. But again, this is why he's trying to make a hypocrisy
argument. Because he's probably just going to go, "Yeah, but
well, if everybody's bad, nobody there's no nothing means anything
Nothing means anything actually, guys. That's what he's going
to That's what he's trying to do, right?
It won't It won't be a good argument on his part. It's obviously
a bad argument. But he's just trying to get it back to like nobody
criticizing anyone. >> going to be able to have a conversation.
>> I'm not Yeah, but I can't just let you lie to my audience.
You understand that, right? That I do have some amount of integrity
and I'm not just going to let you lie to my audience. The reason
why you answered in sneaky way
I have I HAVE SOME AMOUNT OF INTEGRITY. I'M NOT JUST GOING TO
LET YOU LIE TO MY AUDIENCE. YOU'RE LYING TO MY AUDIENCE. BRO,
she's not like making This is
I wish she knew how people in like this space operate more, that
they'll just say things confidently with no idea of what they're
talking about. She does catch it a couple times, though. A very
early in the conversation she caught it. But right there, it's
like
You can tell she's not lying because she is like hesitant and
then she's not quite sure what she's supposed to say. Like she's
not saying, "No, no, no, I I know exactly where this money comes
from. It's all from like like this is how they get funded." She's
not trying to go into any of the specifics cuz she doesn't know.
That's why she's not Like that's how I know she's not lying.
She's actually, you know, apprehensive when she doesn't know
something.
>> Yeah, pretty much. Yeah, exactly. >> Wait, it's
because you know that you can't answer the question that I'm
getting you. >> You're not actually engaging with anything
I'm saying. >> You're not engaging with my questions. I'm
asking you was Course was solely funded by the 1630 Fund that
you
>> Dude. Uh this this should be I would If we could gif
If we could make this into a gif, I would love this for like
a gif, okay? This reaction right here, I'd put it on like Streamlabs
or something for >> I'm asking you. You're not engaging
with my questions. I'm asking you was Course was solely funded
by the 1630 Fund that you know where the Course money is coming
from. >> questions. I'm asking you, was Course was solely
funded by the
fund
that you know where the money is coming from and it's going to
an influencer program. >> You just yell like this over
people and then your audience thinks that they that you know
what you're talking about cuz you say >> Yep. Yeah, that's
pretty much yep. That's pretty much exactly how it works.
It's It's pretty much exactly how it works, yeah. He just literally
like spurges over
and then goes, "Now you can't answer any of my questions." Yep,
that's it. You figured it out. >> Say, "You're sneaky.
You're sneaky." and you interrupt and you don't >> did
a whole reporting thing on these hybrid entities. You know what
a 4990 is and you're claiming that I don't know what I'm talking
about.
I'm saying that you continue to >> Because you're not answering
my
>> Why was that required for the piece? >> I'm not
talking to you condescendingly. I'm treating you like an adult
when I ask you an actual question and you're not giving me the
actual answer. You're just speaking around it. >> Are you
telling me that that journalist can't just accept money from
PAX and
There's no way that's true. >> You're just being really
sneaky. You're not giving me the actual answer. You're talking
around it. You're being very tricky. You know, I want my audience
>> I said multiple times if you want I can go back and
I can re-research the Course and the 1630 >> Uh so real
this Dude, how do we ever dislike Taylor Lorenz? How do we ever
dislike this
That's awesome. >> Fun. Yeah, but you article you misquote
your article over and over again though. You do trickily cite
your article. We can go back through your article if you want.
You still haven't published any of those public contracts, right?
You make strong claims about the fact that people weren't allowed
to disclose that they were part of Course. That was never substantiated.
Those are only according to the secret >> mean it's Show
me one example of an influencer that disclosed. >> That's
not the same thing. That's not the same thing as them saying
as them not being allowed to disclose, right? >> think
that they the seven influencers who spoke, do you think that
they spoke because and and made those claims saying we aren't
allowed to disclose and that's the part that we cite in the contract
that says >> I just sorry sorry sorry. I just I lost the
thread on what you were saying there precisely. I need to listen
again. >> Show me one example of an influencer that disclosed.
>> That's not the same thing. That's not the same thing
as them saying as them not being allowed to disclose, right?
>> Do you think that they the seven in >> So, oh,
here's the entirety. I just know the facts on this, okay? The
contract said you're not allowed to disclose. They were told
in meetings, you're not allowed to disclose. After that, then
eventually they had some meetings saying like, well, you need
to talk to us if you want to disclose.
And then they said, well, we're not going to punish anybody who
did
So, the way that in totality what you could expect here or what
you what you read from that is they don't want people to disclose,
but now they kind of been called on it and they don't want to
look you know, they don't want to look shadier. So, now they're
like, well, we're not going to tell people that they
But realistically they just tried to get away with that being
in the in the contract and the understanding that people wouldn't
unless they asked explicitly like, can I talk about it? But I
don't think anybody did publicly disclose before the article
came out. Nobody was like, I'm a part of the the creator incubator
program for Chorus. >> Well, yes, but I believe the contract
explicitly states this and I do believe there were like Zoom
meetings as well that explicitly stated this. And all you need
to know to basically understand that's true or all you need to
really think about is that if they had proof that they'd given
people different advisement that they that this was not true.
If they had any argument at all,
then I do believe they would have messaged Wire and said, here's
like our evidence that we actually didn't have this in our contracts.
Here's our evidence that we actually didn't say this in some
Zoom meeting that you claim to have. But they didn't do that,
right? They just basically took it on the chin and said we updated
this after the fact as And it's like less murky now. Like it's
it's like less less menacing now or something. I forget what
the update they did an update to the article later that basically
said we had something that explained how you could disclose being
a part of Chorus, I >> influencers who spoke, do you think
that they spoke because and and made those claims saying we aren't
allowed to disclose and that the part >> Yes, exactly Pensive
Goat. Well, this is this is more on the um this is more on
what is it? The the networking side? The the getting
how would you say? It's like talking to politicians and stuff,
right? Cuz there's technically a clause in the contract that
says you have to funnel all of your political bookings through
Chorus, and then some people didn't do that, and then those people
weren't punished. And it's like but the reporting isn't saying
that Chorus strictly enforces this. The reporting is saying the
contract says Right? And then they say what is said in the contract.
That's what the reporting says. So, you could say, "Well, we
didn't enforce the contract." But it's like, "Okay, just you
can contend with what the contract says." If it's If this wasn't
in the contract, feel free to send us whatever the contract was.
>> part that we cite in the contract that says that they're
not allowed to >> You can publish that part if you want.
It's not necessarily saying that. Number one. Number two, I don't
know who those seven influencers were when you publicly identify
their identities. And then number three, we did we did read it.
We read it tons of times. If you can publish that If you can
publish that clause, why can't you publish the whole thing? >> He
didn't publish that clause, some influencer did. Right? Somebody
on TikTok posted the contract. I remember having to look around
some green-screened in TikTok
to try to read all of the language in the contract. >> Because
it would be identifying. But I would ask the same thing of Chorus
creators. I would ask the same We can't publish direct source
material. >> You just did. That's coming from a direct
source. That's from the contract, IS IT NOT?
IT'S COMING FROM A DIRECT SOURCE.
>> publish the full contract that are
>> Watermarked? What are you talking about? Just re- type
it into a >> I think she should probably stop coping on
this and just say, like, realistically,
we're just we're a bit concerned that some people could get caught
out and we don't want anything cuz we don't know how they they
formulate the language or anything, but basically, she didn't
even publish this part. It was the company No, it was an influencer
for the company that published this part of the contract and
so you could just go look at that. It doesn't have to be nothing
else has to be published. >> Lobby, what do you mean you
can copy paste the thing? What do you mean you can't republish
it cuz it's water >> you we don't publish our source material,
but we quote from the >> your quoting the source material.
You published it. It's literally I was reading the article. I
remember the >> So show me So show me the article. Show
me the article. Show me the article. Show me the article. No,
show me evidence from any of these creators. If it's false >> Taylor,
that's not how journalism works. I don't display your story.
You have to provide proof for your story.
>> This guy
So apparently, all journalism works by like all sources are on
the record and need to be included. All of their statements,
everything about them need to be included in the story. Yep,
that's how journalism works, guys. When When actually when people
want to report on like a story from the Trump White House and
it's classified, you actually just publish like classified documents.
Straight up. You just throw them all out there. I'm sure we would
have held the What was it? The
the signal leaks, right? Remember when they didn't publish everything
from the signal leaks immediately?
But apparently, you just have to publish
Dude, this this is like a crazy standard and I'm almost positive
that you went If you went and searched Film Mod and you looked
for like the standard when we were talking about Trump. Let's
say we were talking about, you know, private
But uh uh speaking of private private hop, thank you for the
gifted sub to my wand. If we're talking about basically the the
anonymous sources for those articles on Trump, I'm I'm I can
guarantee Destiny defended that kind of anonymous sourcing. Like
needing to protect sources and stuff cuz he totally understands
it in other situations. He just wouldn't understand it in this
situation where he can like perform Yes, yes, exactly BBB gun.
You're exactly on my page. That during Russia Gate, this was
exactly what everybody would say when there's a bad report about
Trump. Also, lots of other just bad reports about Trump that
it's like anonymously sourced through like some Dude,
basically, the way that works is you can actually sue them. And
Trump, by the way, there have been cases where anonymous sources
have gone forward and Trump has sued them immediately and won
because the source was they didn't do a good enough job validating
it. Trump has literally won money from these publications, okay?
That's how it works.
Why doesn't she just say the contract She did say that. That's
what she means by watermarks, I think, but Destiny's going to
be pedantic, be super pedantic the whole time. It's assumed false
until you have proof for it.
>> You literally don't publish the contract. You cite three
sentences or whatever from it. >> This is not Twitch. You
understand that, right? If there If this was wrong, they could
go to Condé Nast lawyers and get a correction. They could go
to the editors and get a correction. If any of that was wrong,
they could go and get a >> could be a variety of reasons
why they don't want to fight you on the story, but regardless
My standard for good reporting My standard My standard for good
reporting is not did the other side come out and file a correction
or whatever. I'm just reading the article and seeing if the claims
in the article are substantiated. Most of yours are >> So,
he's basically arguing that journalists can't um make claims
that can't be substantiated publicly.
This is obviously insane. This obviously Nobody thinks this.
He is using like Twitch politics standard, like if I'm going
to do a Twitter post, right? That's the standard. But when there's
Wired with a reputation behind the article, obviously they can
do this and obviously they have a whole process for saying, "Hey,
you know what? Something you said in this article is untrue."
Even Even if they thought, "Hey, something in this article is
untrue. I can't explicitly disprove it, but I think I know it's
not true, so I want you to show me in private like what you have
so that I can look at it and figure out what the [__]
is going on here." Right? You could ask for more information.
You could have a conversation with Wired. Wired doesn't want
to publish false stories. Wired is a journalistic publication.
They have integrity, right?
They don't want to publish false stories. I don't know why he's
explaining this isn't like the This isn't how journalism works.
Yes, it is. You You publish for a journalistic outfit outlet.
You publish for like a like a You publish for their editors and
for basically their word behind your story that they checked
it so that you can have some like backing, some some prestige
to your story. So, it's not just you with your blog post.
Like it's It's obvious. This is the reason you'd sell it to to
some outlet.
Also, they tend to have insurance.
I think that's another thing that will come up is is basically
if you're going to get sued, they'll have insurance that deals
with that and pays for legal fees. >> initiated by by quoting
directly from the contract, which not a single one of them has
disproved. >> Oh, no. Society is indeed built on trust.
Dude, I forgot. This is like the whole argument for the Trump
thing, wasn't it? That like, "Oh, you can't trust You're just
claiming you can't trust institutions?
Oh, are you like totally invalidating institutions now? You don't
trust the institutions at all. Institutions are invalid. Is that
what you're saying?"
Wasn't this the whole argument for the entirety of the first
Trump term, the first Trump presidency?
Like this. "Oh, you're totally destroying You're You're totally
discrediting our institutions."
>> Not a single one. And by the way, even Chorus doesn't
doesn't dispute that. >> I'm pretty sure multiple people
did dispute it. I think Brian himself came out and disputed it
and said that we didn't forbid anybody from saying that they
were part of Chorus or whatever. >> No, no, no. Exactly.
And that's very tricky, right? They could say that they were
part of Chorus, which has always been public. But what they were
never which they never disclosed and they weren't allowed to
disclose is that they were part of this secret funding thing.
>> not part of 1630. They're part of Chorus. They're not
getting paid by >> Chorus's secret funding
>> Dude, there's no way. What does he think that Like I'm
actually going to try Can we steelman? What what the [__]
does he
They're not a part of 1630. They're a part of chorus. Okay, she's
talking about how they're funded. Chorus explicitly the incubator
fund is explicitly funded by 1630.
They are getting money explicitly directly from 1630 for this
incubator
What could he possibly mean? No, no, no, no, no. They're being
paid by chorus not the 1630 fund.
Like there he can't possibly think that the fact that chorus
takes the money and then hands it like forwards it directly to
influencers. He can't possibly think that renders it no longer
dark money.
So what is he what is the argument he's trying to make?
Cuz I I actually can't tell. And this sounds so stupid that it
to me even with how badly he's fallen off, he can't be this stupid.
This is a level of stupid that goes beyond
how far he's fallen off. I don't I can't even begin. I I actually
don't know what he's talking >> Pink Ski. >> No,
they're not. They're part of chorus. Whether chorus wants to
make that announcement or not, you don't have to go back and
trace every single line of income that you receive in order for
driving. Also, you completely change you're confused Taylor.
You just completely change your No. >> Yeah, he is making
he it is just that argument. I it is he is just making the argument
that like because it's a different entity and they get the money
from a dark money group that it no longer she she's ignorant
on her own work. It's not a secret funding scheme.
It's a dark money
fund that's funding the the program.
He is so sh
I started the live stream late I da da da da da
She wouldn't be talking to Destiny right now if he wasn't nice
to her before. This paid dividends.
Uh-huh. Okay. >> But which I'm glad I'm glad you've now
conceded. Wow. What it shows is that they were part of chorus,
but that doesn't mean they have to disclose all of chorus's mechanisms.
>> Because not everyone who's involved >> Actually,
they could just say they were getting money from Course as a
part of the incubator program. But I I don't think they said
that either. I don't think anybody disclosed that they are part
of this incubator program, right? >> Authentic Course is
involved in the funding scheme. And Course is a separate big
thing. And not everyone that's involved in the funding scheme.
The point is is that this secret funding scheme was not disclosed
and these creators every day are attending messaging sessions
and getting out there and giving Democrat, you know, talking
whatever, covering the news and they're not disclosing that they
are part of a secret funding scheme aimed at pushing Democratic
messaging. That is a huge problem with our media ecosystem. They
should disclose that they are receiving money and participating
in a in a secret funding scheme that is aimed at at shift at
pushing Democrat messaging. >> Were the influencers themselves,
were they getting paid by Course or were they getting paid by
1630?
>> So he actually just doesn't understand this. I think
he actually doesn't understand that 1630 explicitly funded the
incubator program.
So he's been arguing from ignorance this entire time, I guess.
>> Who is signing the paychecks?
>> They were the paychecks were signed. So is Course a
separate entity from the >> Wait, 1630 was literally signing
the paychecks? Oh, that's even worse.
I mean, I thought they were just figuratively signing the paychecks
cuz it's like a a handoff of the money.
But if 1630 is literally signing the paychecks, then he's just
been making the entirely wrong argument. And again, so what she's
trying to do is just explain where he's wrong. If she
was actually
doing the same thing he was, if she was actually trying to like
win the conversation, the minds of the audience, she would go,
"Wait, you don't even know that they're being paid by 1630 and
you're calling me out? You're like a
for even attempting to have this conversation. You've just embarrassed
yourself again. How do you show up and act so confident?" Like
she would start actually attacking him and how stupid he looks
making the points he's making. They're not being paid by 1630,
they're being paid by Chorus. He said that like eight times already.
Like eight times he said this in the conversation. I didn't realize
the paychecks were literally signed Queen To be honest with you,
that was outside of my I for some reason I just missed that specific
thing. I knew that Chorus I knew that the Incubator program was
funded explicitly by 1630. I just didn't realize the money was
coming to accounts based on like other 1630 payment system or
something. That's interesting. >> 1630 fund or >> Chorus
is described as a project of the 1630 fund.
>> I don't I don't know what that means. What is the business
structure
>> You can ask Chorus. >> No, I'm asking you. You're
the one that wrote the article on it. >> I I I I'm and
we described it the way that they describe it. They describe
themselves It is described in the
as they describe themselves as a project of the 1630 fund. That's
how it was >> And that's what we're quoting. >> If
it is the fact that the 1630 fund was cutting paychecks to some
of these influencers, isn't that legally required to show up
on a form 990? Don't they have to publish that publicly where
that money flows out to? >> You tell me. >> I don't
know. >> Shouldn't you know? If this is your >> Wait.
What?
Sorry, I looked I looked up to the side for a second. I
If it is the fact that the 1630 fund was cutting paychecks to
some of these influencers,
isn't that legally required to show up on a form 990? Don't they
have to publish that publicly where
Uh no. I You know this because of Progressive Victory. That if
they have an LLC where they're doing this that they're doing
this through, that's exactly how Progressive Victory worked.
But this guy
I actually I Do you want to know the real reason I can't watch?
Cuz I found this person compelling at one point at one point,
and I can't watch him anymore because it is painfully obvious
how stupid he is without a ton of people feeding him information
all the time. It's like actually it hurts so badly to watch just
knowing that I found this person compelling at any point. That's
what makes it so unbearable now. It's not even the voice or the
mannerisms, which are in themselves in of the in and of themselves
painful.
It's that he just looks so dumb all the time.
Like how does he not understand that that's the way progressive
victory worked? That they had this LLC this hybrid structure,
and they paid out through the LLC to the influencers individually.
And then they I believe they just have to list like essentially
giving out some money to the LLC, right? Isn't that how this
worked? I I know they were able to obfuscate paying the specific
in influencers, and then they accidentally filled out a form
that docks those influencers, or at least that's their their
claim, okay? But that money flows out to. >> You're telling
me? >> I don't know. >> Shouldn't you know? If this
is your beat, if this is your reporting on, shouldn't you know
the answer to this? Isn't this kind of an important part of >> I
think that they should I I think that at the time I don't even
think, I know that at the time of my story
none of that funding none of that funding structure was disclosed.
No none of the the content that was being
>> It's like it's really funny. It's actually awesome that
he's so incorrect in this conversation the whole time, and you
can watch it cuz Taylor does start stuttering now. I think Taylor
thinks the conversation's going badly for her because Destiny
just does the thing with the bravado and like the signaling.
She's probably got like the YouTube video or the chat open somewhere
as well.
And I think she thinks she's like losing the conversation in
some way like right now that she just had like a really bad point
go against her. And it's like no, this guy is just stupid.
I think she's grown tired of him. She's she does start like stuttering
at some point here in the future. She hits one point where she
like stutters so badly, I'm like holy
I've never even heard something like that in a debate before.
She like stammers super hard. >> Using money from this
funding program was not disclosed. The fact that these influencers
who are out calling themselves journalists
were taking part in daily messaging sessions and receiving thousands
of dollars from this group. And they're going out and they're
producing news that people think is 100% independent.
They never disclosed that they were part of this funding scheme
or that they were part of this political influence scheme. They
never disclosed that. And that's a problem, I would argue, for
our broader media ecosystem. I have concerns >> it is if
it is legally required for them to report this and they're not,
would you are you accusing six the 1630 fund of committing a
crimes?
>> Um I would imagine that they know what is required to
disclose and what is >> Dude, should we find the Where's
the old man laundry article on PV? Old man laundry progressive
victory. I think he took all the docs out of the primary article,
right? So if you look at the original article,
I do believe somewhere in here will have the like how they were
funding people,
Like I think he explains exactly how this works with a 501 This
is 501c, but I do think in here it explains exactly how it works,
like how they use the the LLC to hide or obfuscate payments directly
to people and not say exactly who is working for them. >> is
required to not disclose, but as you know very well, these groups
are very good at um >> No, no, no, no, I think he took
he took the docs out of the specific article now, My Word. I'm
pretty sure. He took the docs out of the article and put it into
like a side piece. He like put it in a spreadsheet or something.
You have to dig pretty deep into it. >> kind of navigating
disclosures. And as you know, >> network is, right? Like
the fact that your residence and reporter program can say it's
open, but it's receiving money from the hybrid dark money part.
>> No, because I'm not part of a political No, because
I'm not part of any political influence scheme. I'm not a political
influence scheme. A
No, a non-partisan investigative journalism fellowship funded
directly by one person is nothing like a political influence
scheme or these influencers
>> It's just funny that he thinks that it has to be publicly
disclosed.
Like, that's the whole point of the LLC in these in these packs.
And Progressive Victory was the 501c4 with the LLC.
And like Laundrie goes through this article and he's like, "Oh
yeah, the big thing that we're noticing is there's missing financial
information. Based on publicly available information, including
a stunning interview with Progressive Victory PAC's founder,
Sam Scola, we know that there are dozens of staff and influencers
being paid by Progressive Victory who are not shown anywhere
on PV PAC's expense reports."
Like I just find it like staggering that all of this stuff like
people know all of this stuff and then he's trying to like big
dog her on
on not knowing these things. Well, actually she they're like
legally required to put all of this stuff out, aren't they? No,
they're not. >> with that. >> That has nothing to
do with what I just said though, but I agree with what you're
saying there. >> It is. But anyway, regardless, Destiny,
the point is is that none of this was made public to viewers,
to consumers. And I would argue that that's a problem. And creators
in the program
wanted to disclose and were told that they could not disclose
per the contract. We quote the contract. I know that you think
again this is Twitch receipts culture or whatever, but but Wired
is a very legitimate
journalistic outlet that frankly has no loyalty me to me. I'm
just a freelancer. If there was anything that that these entities
had and don't act like Course didn't fight that article, okay?
If they had anything to disprove those claims, if any of those
those creators had contracts that were not accurately represented,
they could absolutely disprove that privately, even if they don't
want to publicly disprove it, they could disprove it privately
to the Condé Nast lawyers who went out and sought that information
from people online that were making those claims. But they don't
have it because what we reported was correct and true, which
is that it was not disclosed. It was not publicly disclosed.
And these influencers themselves did not make any disclosures
that they were part of this paid influence program. While they
were identifying themselves as journalists.
>> That's great and all. Do you acknowledge that at least
this is the same thing as your funding through the Omidyar Network?
>> No, it's nothing like it because I'm not a political
influencer. I'm a >> that. You're you're you're I understand
that you're not but you so you can say yes, the funding mechanism
is the same but I don't have the same requirements to be transparent
about that because I'm >> They're not paid by an LLC. They're
getting paid They're not paid by some LLC that is solely funded
by a billionaire. They are paid by a dark >> any proof
First of all, the Omidyar Network that fund is literally a fund
that solicit public donations. They're not solely funded by Pierre.
I don't know why you keep bringing that up. >> I again,
I'm telling you the we're talking about a non-partisan,
non- non- partisan journalistic journalism fellowship because
to conflate a journalism non- of non-partisan journalism fellowship
with the political influence program is frankly exactly the whole
problem with our entire media ecosystem. The fact that somebody
cannot comprehend that journalists are held to very strict different
standards than political influencers is a problem and I think
that that that that fact that you are not sort of making that
distinction >> I literally have made it over and over again
but you're you're making you're making this distinction now.
Originally when you came in here, you were upset that I said
that by your dark money standards, you get paid via dark
It's not It's just not the same. Sorry, I'm also I'm doing something
on the side here. I'll be honest, I was kind of tapped out for
the past about 70 seconds. Cuz I'm trying to look through and
see if somewhere in here
if somewhere in here we've got
Yeah, sorry. I'm looking at like Luna boxes notes. I could have
sworn that somewhere in here there was something about how they
receive money for these for the reporters in residence thing.
>> dark money. Initially, you wanted to refute that claim
and now you're saying well my funding mechanism standards should
be different than partisan people which I agree with. I agree
with you. You do. You do. You do. >> I don't. I am I don't
First of all, I that fellowship was only a couple of months last
year. >> Sure, so just a couple of months of dark money,
sure. Which I think is longer than Quartz. >> It was never
dark money. I It is. You think all of these journalists, all
50 journalists that have been able to participate in this program
and we have to sign again ethics clauses saying that we are not
accepting dark money, we're not accepting PAC money. >> said
it was only for a few months. So, did you write any articles
for any mainstream publications while you were being funded by
the Omidyar Network dark money fund?
>> It was not a dark money fund and I literally wrote this
story for Wired, literally. So, you and you you believe that
somehow there's a >> There's another tactic is basically
he's just going to keep like talking and try to put the other
person off balance.
Her being like a normal human being, right? She's going to start
getting like upset cuz he keeps saying something that's not true
that she like doesn't So, he's going to keep doing it over and
over again just trying to make her upset. Right? It's pretty
funny. >> major conspiracy We're Conde Nast >> say
anything about a major conspiracy. I think you can probably as
long as you disclose your funding source >> story. I wrote
this exact story for Wired. If you believe that that all of Conde
Nast all like it's just ridiculous. I would have had to if I
was accepting dark money when I wrote this story, I would have
had to disclose it. I am not accepting dark money. I have never
accepted dark money. >> did disclose it. You probably told
Wired these are these are the people I've got to work for. >> be
No, you It would have to be publicly disclosed. >> How
would you you you wait wait If I >> You have to have a
disclaimer. You don't understand how disclosure works. If you
have a conflict of interest >> Correct. Conflict of interest.
What is the conflict of interest between the Omidyar Network
and the Quartz or 1630 fund or whatever? >> Again, he just
literally has lost He's just totally lost on this one. I think
he's trying to ask what the
Yeah, the He's trying to He's trying to say what's the conflict
of interest between 1630 and Quartz, right? The conflict of interest
here is that
you're taking money from like a specific politically partisan
pack. You're attending meetings and you're not disclosing that
you're getting a large portion of your income from this, right?
That's the problem. That's obviously the issue.
It's like What is the I guess you could say what is the conflict?
Testing is wrong on Omidyar. I noticed Tom was in chat for this.
Tom's got a bunch of things that he says in chat
Uh but he he just [__] that up. It's not the Omidyar
Network. It would be I think he's trying to ask what's the conflict
between Course and 1630.
Um you don't know that it's hard to know the conflict if it's
literally dark,
That's the that's another problem. It's another massive issue.
>> If there Well, there is none, but it's >> So then
you wouldn't be required to disclose. I do know how to disclosure
works. Disclosure works there. Oh, wait. No, but like you have
to avoid the appearance of impropriety. It's not like a direct
The problem is is you're not the person who should decide whether
or not there's a conflict there, right? Like if you were taking
money from 16 I'm sure if she was writing articles while she
was getting paid by the like Reporters in Residence thing, she
wouldn't be against like putting a whole thing in her like at
the end of the article saying, "Hey, she's a part of the Reporters
in Residence program for the Omidyar Network" or something. Right?
I'm sure she's done something like that before. And I'm sure
she'd have no problem with doing it. And the Omidyar stuff was
announced publicly.
On a public website. She's she's like it's I think it's something
of like an honor when you get picked for it, right? Like conflict
of interest. I don't know if journalists would even disclose
it if they were working on a project. >> You're so you
don't know what you're talking about. >> You can keep saying
that, but you don't even know what a Form 990 is and you're reporting
on these hybrid pack entities, which is insane.
>> do. I certainly We're just making up that I don't know
things. I just I want to go back to this claim. >> I That's
so it's completely unrelated to the she's talking about now.
Her not knowing about a Form 990 would be understandable, but
you're now talking to her about the way journalism operates and
journalists have to operate. And obviously she would have some
experience
Right? How are you supposed to tell me what journalists can and
can't do ethically if you don't even know what a form 990 is?
It's literally unrelated to what you're talking about right now.
>> You believe that you This is so silly. So, you believe
that a journalist reporting on a dark money political funding
scheme, you believe that that a mainstream media outlet, a mainstream
very traditional to traditionalist traditionalist one, would
not make that journalist put a disclosure up top if that they
were receiving dark money. >> That's the flops in another
TAYLOR LORENZ DEBATE.
SHE'S LYING. He has no idea.
I Now, I'm actually for the first time in my entire life, I'm
actually interested in Don Flurry's content for a second. I do
wonder where he thinks she's lying. Would be kind of interesting
maybe to check out later. Maybe we'll we'll think about it. But
I I just did the title is funny as good stuff. Good stuff, Tom.
>> The idea that a journalist could receive dark money
while reporting on a dark money political scheme and not openly
disclose it. They No editor would allow allow that. That would
be ridiculous. >> is I don't think this is even Dark money
doesn't even mean anything. This is just like a random >> Okay,
so now you're making a totally different claim. I just >> When
people talk about When people talk about dark money
Saying that Well, if the way that you're using it doesn't The
when people talk about dark money, they're talking about a quasi-political
entity that's not supposed to be about the political that can
solicit donors but doesn't have to report who the donors are.
Your definition of dark money is every single person down the
stream from that dark money entity that gets paid by them. That's
what you're saying.
>> But that's not even true. This might have been his argument
when he decided he wanted to take this conversation.
But she literally just said they get their paychecks signed by
1630.
Which if that's the case, like this argument's totally defeated.
You're completely and you have Like why is this being brought
up again? This is old. He just hasn't
Dude, wait. This is kind of like Hutch behavior. This is actually
like unironically Hutch behavior.
Like he's forgotten that this has already been disproven earlier
in the
Like he's just reset and trying to restate his original premise.
But he's already been blown out on it.
I don't I don't know what we're doing, man. >> dark money
is. >> That's not true. >> It is true. >> It's
not. It's just simply not true. >> It definitionally is.
If dark If If the 1630 Fund wanted to pay If the 1630 Fund wanted
to pay me money for a thing, I'm not taking dark money. I'm taking
money from the 1630 Fund. I can say publicly where it comes from.
>> notorious, which is a
>> No. No. No. Like
I would assume I assume what he's trying to get at is like if
you were a janitor
in a place that like Let's say you were No, no, no. This is a
bad Let's say you're a hotel that rented out convention centers
and you got paid by the 1630 Fund cuz they wanted to rent out
your convention center, right? You're one of your like What do
you call them? Like uh
I It's not a convention center. Whatever the rooms are in hotels
where they hold con- conference rooms. One of your conference
rooms.
I'm having a hard time speaking. One of your conference rooms.
Would that hotel be taking dark money? No, but like they're providing
a service directly. They provide a service that's like
He's trying to make that argument that basically because it's
downstream, it's like not dark money, it's not concerning because
it's like downstream and it's not a part of the equation anymore.
Like where that money's coming from. But that's not really true.
Especially Well, it's obviously not true if the checks are being
signed by the 1630 Fund. Which can I get a source on that? Is
Is QueenB still here? Do we know like where that Where is that
from that the paychecks are literally signed by the 1630 Fund?
Who says that?
I I've I've not seen that before, but if that's true, then yeah,
this whole argument's blown out. I still think this argument's
because the 1630 Fund is funding something. explicitly they're
like in an agreement to fund the incubator program. So it's it's
basically a collection of handoffs, but they are paying for those
donors are paying for
these people to like do Democrat
It's not like some It's not like the influencers downstream are
totally disconnected in a way that makes it that the makes it
so that they don't have some conflict going on. It's very different
than the conference room thing. >> Or if it is known as
I think Google like if it is referred to in major political headlines
as a very as a well-known dark money group. >> No, yes,
wait, wait, 16
Somebody just got banned. Hold on, what did the guy say? What
did the guy say? Commer The chatter's acting like Destiny's clearly
winning this have brain parasites. >> Like if it is referred
to in >> The chatter's acting like Destiny's clearly winning
this have brain parasites and then >> headlines as a very
as a well-known dark money group. >> Catch that guy. IP
ban commer 27. Get him out of here. You say I'm losing? Yes,
wait, wait, 16/30
is a dark money group, but everybody downstream from that is
not automatically a dark money
>> They're accepting dark money.
>> They're accepting money from a dark money group. Sure,
you can say that, but they're not >> Dude, I Wait, did
I stop? I must have stopped watching it at this point. Because
this is actually
This is worse than I thought. This is so much worse than I thought.
Dude, this Did you watch the Pisco one? No, I didn't. This is
actually so much worse than I thought it was. No, no, no, no,
no, this is It's not dark money. They're getting money from a
dark money group, but that doesn't mean they are taking dark
money. That doesn't mean they're like
What I have to listen to it again. I can't even I can't even
recreate it myself. I have to listen to him say it again. >> major
political headlines as a very as a well-known dark money group.
>> No, yes, wait, wait, 16/30
is a dark money group, but everybody downstream from that is
not automatically a dark money group.
>> Oh, so pedantically that would be true that everybody
downstream of that would not be a
with as with the hotel convention center or whatever, like for
meetings and stuff. Like not everybody downstream of that would
be like taking dark money or could be said to have some kind
of conflict, but the influencers obviously
>> They're accepting dark money.
>> They're accepting money from a dark money group. Sure,
you can say that, but they're not but that doesn't make them
a dark money
>> Sure, nobody would claim otherwise.
>> You're saying that they're that Chorus and all these
people are all dark money
>> No, I never said
>> Chorus was a dark money group. I said that they've received
funding and they are described as a project of a dark money group.
>> Okay, so then the program that you're a part of would
be a project of a dark money group. >> He just has to go
back to the thing that like rattles her cuz he's he just said
something so cataclysmically stupid that he has to go back to
well, you take dark money. Well, you take dark money. It's so
transparent, dude. It's so funny.
It's so funny.
Also, that is not true, but even if that were true, it he's still
saying things that are just
>> receives money from a dark money group. >> No,
that's not that's not how any that's not how it's described anywhere.
I'm sorry, it's not. >> Can you show me evidence of the
LLC that funds the Residents Journal program, the hybrid entity
that you're describing? >> He has to keep going back to
her thing. Like I'm sure there's some kind of argument for how
like you can't as a third party confirm that Taylor is getting
money not at all attached to any other donor other than Pierre
Omidyar. I'm sure there's like that that could be true, right?
That through public filings you might not be able to track her
money that goes into that program and figure out exactly who
is donating such that it was like set aside or allocated for
that
Right? You might not be able to track But it's certainly not
the same as the chorus thing and and the 1630 fund in >> No,
you can go on the website. I don't know what to tell you other
than I I'm telling you I I'm allowed to take part in this journalistic
I was allowed to last year take part in a non-partisan
you know, fellowship which again dozens and dozens of other mainstream
reporters have participated in and I have never accepted dark
money and I never can accept dark money because I have to know
where every dollar
I I accept comes from. I have to know where it comes from because
>> Can you explain to me on Amida's website, can you explain
what this means? Amida Network is a hybrid structure. By the
way, I don't know if you've learned this or not in your reporting,
but that's code word for dark money hybrid entity, but so they
say because Amida Network is a hybrid structure that includes
a limited liability company, the LLC, that's what you referenced,
that's the dark part because they don't have to report where
the money comes from, with a private philanthropic foundation.
What do you think private philanthropic foundation means? Is
that all money from >> So like I'm Now I need to go through
this again cuz if the 501c3 is what's getting the donations and
then those that money is put into the LLC to obfuscate who's
being paid
like I guess technically the LLC could get money from something
else, but I don't know if it takes donations in the same way.
The 501c3, the hybrid structure would be irrelevant then. It
would just be like the fact that she's being paid by a corporation.
Like Do you know what I mean?
But the 501c3 would have to disclose I believe the donors to
that would have to be disclosed.
>> If it's just money coming into the LLC and you don't
know how money's then that's just anybody who's being paid by
an LLC anywhere is taking dark money. >> which is not the
foundation and has no affiliation
with the reporters in residence program. >> They're the
ones that donate >> But but I'm not sure if it if it goes
the other way
then is there
Dude, I don't know.
I did Now I need to see how this money flows again cuz now I'm
I'm like actually I've I feel like I had this down before this
conversation and now I'm like mindful of it. I don't remember
I don't remember for sure which way it >> money to the
LLC to make the reporters and residents program. >> it's
not from the foundation. No, it's not connected to the foundation
at all. I know for a fact it's not because I can't do anything
with the foundation. >> Not directly. You go through the
LLC the middle man. That's the whole point. >> no, no,
it's not it's not related to the foundation. The foundation is
separate. It's the foundation is something >> Regardless
of how she's paid, it's still like all under Pierre Omidyar's
name and not only that, but it's publicly disclosed that she
does this, right? And they publicly disclose their goals, what
they're doing, everything. Everything is all publicly disclosed,
who's in the It's like categorically different to begin with.
>> something completely separate. I know it's confusing
cuz they all have the name Omidyar in it, but it's not >> It's
not structurally this is literally how they are set up. >> It's
not. It's not. I'm sorry. You can speak to them yourself. I honestly
think I would be happy to connect you with their comms person
>> Sure. If any of them are willing to come on and have
a public conversation, I would absolutely love that. Any of them,
>> But I promise you, Destiny,
none of us working in in mainstream >> repeating this one
point like it's helping you or it's saving any part of this conversation,
but it's not. You can keep saying you would have to disclose
or whatever. You're you're doing this in in in in as a substitution
for having any evidence. You keep falsely asserting that you
would have to There's no way this could be >> crap. Destiny
hasn't looked into this.
What else did Tom say? No, and the LLC reports all donations.
So like it's all Is it all transpa- Oh, no. Is it all transparent?
Is Tom going to have to blow him out? Oh, no. Oh, no. Tom, no.
Don't do it. >> have been able to write for Wired, which
I don't even think is true.
well, no, but seriously, I I'm just wondering kind of what you
think. Knowing that journalists can't take part in dark money,
you know, schemes and and can't accept money from like political
groups and so again, we can't even accept gifts over like >> If
I were to ask if I were to hit up somebody at Widen, I would
have asked them, in your contracts that you have for people that
write op-eds or for people that do reporting or for people that
work for you, you have the term dark money shows up in those
contracts. >> I would I don't know if the term dark money,
but certainly yeah, you can't accept political funding. You can't
accept You can't take part in political >> Notice how you
changed it again. Okay, but thank you for admitting that. Okay,
go on to the next part. Yeah. Okay. >> they I don't know
the way that they word it specifically,
but I can promise you that journalists that are that this is
a very important thing that I think a lot of people don't realize
about journalists, yourself included,
that we cannot be we can't accept that sort of money. That would
be very unethical.
And I know that you believe that this nonprofit non >> So,
she she's doing like a bad job of I and I think it's because
she probably did the due diligence by relying on other people
who have talked about the same thing. Right? She's having a hard
time explaining why it's not dark money or why she knows it's
from like some different part of the fund. So, I understand how
like he's going to keep pressing on that cuz she clearly hasn't
done so she doesn't know it like cold. You know what I'm saying?
Or maybe she just looked into it back then when she was offered
it and she was like, oh, this is satisfying and she can't remember
precisely why she thought it was satisfying. >> non-part
or sorry, this non-partisan
journalism fellowship is similar to this secret political influence
program. >> Because it's funded by the foundation.
>> It's not funded by the foundation. I don't know what
to tell you about it. It's simply not. >> It's not funded
by the foundation,
>> Do you think Do you think that the Omidyar Foundation
The Omidyar Foundation, by the way, like is completely like diametrically
politically opposed to me. So, it'd be very hilarious. It's not
>> these It says on the site, Omidyar Network receives
no funding for the Reporters and Residents Program via the 1635
or any other outside sources. Our programmatic work is supported
entirely via our foundation
and LLC. Can you break that down for me or am I confused with
what foundation means? >> They operate
a a nonprofit. They operate a political group that is political
work.
>> So, the other thing is I do think the like there's I
don't know if we have proofs that for this program like if they
just handled it all through the 501c3,
if they didn't go over to the LLC at then wouldn't they just
be fine, right? I unless I'm missing something. >> know
what to tell you. Again, they're PR person on the line and they
can explain it to you. The point is is that
even Here's Here's the thing. Let me also just like get this
to you. >> Go for it. >> The The what's so funny
about all of this is that everything I do is public and disclosed,
right? So, you can like litigate all of this stuff. The The The
The whole point of my article is the fact that this political
influence program was not publicly disclosed and these influencers
are out acting like journalists but saying that they're journalists
without publicly disclosing their funding. >> What Do they
have to be journalists?
>> They are describing themselves as >> I thought
they were just like influencers or streamers or whatever. >> Well,
they're describing themselves as >> journalist is not like
that's not a protected Anybody can describe themselves Nick Shirley
describes himself as a journalist. >> Sure. Sure. And right,
and Nick Shirley is probably also doing a lot of unethical things.
I think it's really in the public's interest to know again
that that you if you are out there talking about the news and
pretending that you are an independent journalist, which comes
with certain levels of
>> By the way, this is the entire purpose of the article
is basically calling out that side of it. It is bad that it's
from a dark money group or whatever, but I think that the real
purpose of the article is saying, "Hey, you may not realize this,
but influencers, people you think are independent, are not independent.
They take money and they don't disclose it." This is the primary
thrust of the article that has not been addressed whatsoever
based on all the arguments about whether or not 1630 is dark
money, whether or not Course takes dark money from 16/30, whether
or not the influencers themselves take 16 dark money, which by
the way that's all true.
But it's it's literally just about the influencers not disclosing.
Like that is the broad thrust of the argument is these people
don't disclose that they're being paid to give political opinions.
>> But and yet you are taking part in a secret political
influence scheme.
I think that's that's in the public interest to know. You're
attending daily messaging check-ins. Again, you are you are part
of a scheme that exists to promote democratic messaging. The
public deserves to know that. Wouldn't you >> I don't know
what the report I would say the public deserves to know at the
bare minimum whatever the legally reported requirements are.
It sounds like you're saying that they weren't violating any
laws in terms of what they're reporting. >> think Do you
think it's okay for influencers to take a lot of money for a
political influence scheme and not disclose it to their fans?
>> I don't
>> He obviously doesn't think it's fine.
I'm trying to beg.
He obviously doesn't think it's fine. And when we were arguing
the progressive victory stuff, I think I've talked about this
on stream.
He was like he was getting upset when Wicken Counterpoints were
on the stream and messaging me like arguments I should try to
make to like pull apart them trying to sweep for the fact that
they weren't disclosing.
So like I know from that he obviously didn't like that things
were kept secret. Okay?
Clearly he didn't he didn't like that. And even now he's not
going to be able to say just with his chat like oh no, you shouldn't
have to disclose that at all. I think it's all the arguments
around not disclosing oh well, these people are getting harassed.
They're all stupid arguments, man. >> It's okay for influencers
to take a lot of money for a political influence scheme and not
disclose it to their >> I don't like that, but I think
that my push, if I wasn't being politically partisan, would be
to push Congress or to be to push legislators to make it so that
there were stricter
>> What is What do you mean politically partisan? What
the [__] is that supposed to mean? Do you think Taylor
Lorenz is a secret Republican? The person who doxed Libs of TikTok
is a secret Republican? This guy doxed these people who cover
his like crimes. She doxed like Republican influencers who are
trying to like dox random Libs on TikTok, okay?
Her doxing is way better is way is actually helpful. It's actually
in the public interest. His doxing purely spiteful purely like
trying to manipulate his own narratives online about his crimes.
All right? Her
Her doxing public interest trying to prevent people from shaping
American opinions without having their names out there at all,
okay? Altruistic doxing from Taylor Lorenz. >> their FEC
requirements around what had to be disclosed rather than to partisanly
attack only some organizations because I don't like them because
it gives the impression that everybody else is above board especially
when your funding mechanism is the exact same as the one you're
criticizing. >> No, no, no, no, no. I am certainly not
I am certainly >> Oh, by the way, I don't think I don't
know that I'd be able to find a source on 1630 the checks. But
I do think that when when 1630 signs on explicitly to fund the
incubator program, I do think that actually makes all the difference
in the world and that is like
that is they are giving this money to chorus like explicitly
and I don't think that one level of indirection changes things.
That money is coming from 1630 from dark money group. It changing
hands once but still being totally in the political and explicitly
like the partisan political realm, it doesn't change anything,
>> Certainly not. I I absolutely And also a few months
fellowship is nothing. Like I I know exactly where every single
dollar of my money comes from and I have never ever ever taken
money without disclosing
>> But your money >> but the but the funding mechanism,
I read it. The thing it said the work for the reporters and residents
program is >> about it and >> via the foundation
and LLC which is you don't know where the money all comes from.
That is literally how it works. >> I'm sorry that you're
confused by this. And again, you can speak to the PR people at
Omidyar because you're confused by it. >> I'm definitely
not confused, I promise. >> Can you stop Can you Now that
we've gone in circles enough, I think, on that, can you engage
with the broader points which you were saying on your stream
earlier of all of this stuff that um that that you know that
there was disclosure, that this was public, that influencers
were talking about being part of home. You don't have any evidence
of that. So, if you're going to make those claims, you better
have evidence because I promise you >> what claims am I
making that you're not comfortable with? >> But you said
on your stream, which is what I'm trying to do sort of debunk,
is that you said this was public. You said that there was >> My
understanding is that there are there are public filing requirements
for these programs. My understanding >> said that influencers
had dis-
>> Now who's being tricky and slippery? Oh, >> and
could talk about the fact that they were part of this funding
program. >> is influencers weren't forbidden from disclosing
it. I don't know if all of them did. I don't know if they were
required to. >> from disclosing it, and you have no evidence
showing that they weren't forbidden from disclosing >> So, the
onus is on you to make that to prove that. >> the contract.
And we cite the contract. >> from the contract You cite
First of all, you cite a part of the contract. >> We quote
directly from >> quote from it. You paste a part of the
contract on your article, but then you also simultaneously you
can't post the whole thing, which I don't understand. >> contract.
We quote directly from the >> You you you could you Am
I remembering or was it somebody else that posted this picture?
Am I mixing your article up with somebody else's? Is it a picture
of like three clauses as part of the >> That's somebody
else who posted that. >> contract or was it just a quote
from the >> That was one of the influencers that showed
the contract. >> I just wish that when when she finds him
saying something ri- I wish she would like do the whole song
and dance every single time of like are you a [__]
for saying something so [__] stupid that you can't
back up that is just clearly wrong like
humiliating him every time he says something wrong. The debate
would take another hour cuz he's done it so many times. But unfortunately,
unless she's willing to do that every single time,
his audience will still think he's like correct cuz obviously
what you do whenever somebody's even slightly wrong on anything
is you do a whole song and dance about how wrong they are, right?
That's obvious That's how you have conversations with other human
beings,
That's not That doesn't make you like a totally unbearable like
dredge like uh Yeah, human like just human drudgery. Like nobody
wants to be around you.
It's terrible. >> that validating confirming our reporting
because the one influencer that posted part of her contract actually
validated confirms she inadvertently confirmed our reporting.
And that's if you look at response, people are like, "Oh, this
what she what she said." >> Then why not just publish the
contract? If they're showing you that to bolster it, why just
publish a part?
It's It's just like them looping on the same points. It's so
funny cuz I think they looped on these same points the
that they did the first conversation. It's like the same points
that they're looping on again and again and again and again.
Why didn't she publish this? They didn't want to. Wired didn't
want to. But you could by yourself. I don't want to either. But
like Wired Wired didn't want to. Wired said we should not publish
all that stuff.
And he just like it's it's the same response as all of it is
the same.
>> Well, you'll have to call the lawyers up and ask why
they don't let people publish source material. But what I will
tell you is that >> telling me you're telling me that they
would allow you to publish a part of a contract but not more
parts of the >> You can quote from you can quote from a
contract, but you but you can't publish the full contract in
full. Again, that's just the decision made to not publish the
source material, which is pretty standard. Pretty standard. It's
very rare that you're allowed to publish your direct source material.
Again, cuz this is not Twitch receipts culture, it's >> Well,
it's not Twitch receipts culture. I You keep saying this like
very derisively, but the problem is that your
>> Sorry, I got up and walked away for a second. I was
going to go grab a drink. And he said something so stupid
again, that I have to go back. He just asked why you would publish
part of a contract, which they just finished litigating, that
she didn't do, that one of the TikTok people did. He She just
explained it to him. I didn't post that image, somebody on TikTok
did. And then he reset immediately and asked about it again.
He He tried to make that point
Listen, after she cleared it up >> You can quote >> telling
me that they would allow you to publish a part of a contract,
but not more parts of the contract? >> You can quote from
You can quote from a contract, but you but you can't publish
the full contract in full. Again, that's just the decision made
to not publish the source material, which is pretty standard.
Pretty standard. It's very rare that you're allowed to publish
your direct source material. Again, cuz this is not Twitch receipts
culture, it's >> That's the publish part of a contract.
He's talking about the picture again. No, the influencer released
it after watching you back, so it's not even in the article.
They were just explaining what the clauses of the contract were
in the article, right? And then somebody posted they're like,
"No, no, no, it doesn't say that." And then they posted the clauses.
And the clauses basically lay out exactly what she said.
>> Well, it's not about Twitch receipts culture. I You
keep saying this like very derisively, but the problem is that
your article contains so much like half-truth or just information
that wasn't substantiated at all, that it seems like there would
be a larger There'd be an onus on you to actually show that what
you're saying is true, rather than >> That's the whole
point of trying to go through a publication like this. Cuz for
Ken Klippenstein, when he does his Substack, he does show like
a ton of stuff, right? He has to show all of the evidence that
He He can't just, you know, quote people off the record and then
everyone takes him seriously. He often has to do a lot of stuff.
He often has to like show a lot of [__]
Like when he was doing the NSPM 7 stuff, he had like slideshows
from the
Right? He has to. But when you have Wired or you you have the
New York Times or something like that who have an editorial staff
who will take lawyers and and put them on like basically they'll
use their own lawyers or they'll get insurance so that you can
publish pieces that make these claims and don't publish the source
material. And they'll say if you want to disagree, you can come
to us and we'll talk about it privately, but otherwise we'll
go through like you'll speak to our lawyers and if you want to
sue us for defamation or or libel I guess in this case, then
go ahead cuz we're comfortable. We're putting our reputation
on the line. We're comfortable going to court over
That's how journalism works. That's how they protect sources.
That's how they That's how this stuff all works. It's just crazy.
>> from the contract and and and the influencer that showed
her contract that showed part of her contract confirms our reporting
and also not a single influencer in in the program, privately
or publicly, has been able to provide any evidence that what
we reported was
It's just simply that that's that's why it's it's actually correct.
I'm sorry. That's why I want you to engage with reality, which
is that >> No, no, no, no, no. I don't trust the wire I
don't trust institutions. I don't trust journalists. I I don't
trust uh what would you call them? Publications? I don't trust
these institutions. Wired, The New York Times, The Washington
I don't trust them. Okay? You have to show me everything so I
can be the judge.
Where have I heard this before? Uh why am I supposed to trust
the WHO?
They say the vaccine works. Um show me all of the study information.
Show me all the data. Show me everything because I don't trust
these people. Wasn't there a whole thing where this guy was like
trust the institutions? You have to You can't evaluate every
single thing in your
Is Is this not Is this the same What the [__] is
going on here?
>> This is the program that they were running. And by the
way, they still have not been public about who's in the program,
even now, even currently, there is no public disclosure of who
they're funding. And I would argue I I agree with you that Congress
should take this up and that there should be filings, but I would
argue in the meantime, all of these groups should be public.
And >> So just went on So in your article here, so you
have According to copies of the contract viewed by Wired that
creators signed, the influencers are not allowed to disclose
their relationship with Chorus or the 1630 Fund or functional
that they're being paid at all. I never saw anything
that that was
that that that this is from in in any of the contract. What?
>> I got >> Yeah, that's not a part of the contract
that was leaked, [__]
that wasn't leaked by the person. But all they'd have to do is
dispute
Right? That's all Chorus would have to do is dispute not dispute
that they not dispute anything, but
the contract didn't say that. Cuz that's what they reported.
The contract says
So what Chorus would have to do is they go, "We've never done
a contract that says that."
But they didn't do that, did they? They never did that.
again, every single creator, we we have multiple copies of the
contract from all the creators. None of the creators were able
to provide a single shred of of evidence that this is false.
None of the None of the contracts >> the onus I'm just
engaging with your article, and I'm I'm You made a claim, so
you have to prove it. She did to the editors of Wired magazine.
That's who she proved it to. And they were like, "Hey, we believe
this. We think this is 100% true, and we're willing to get sued
over it.
As is the case with tons of other pieces we run. Hey, we're not
going to publish so source material. We're going to say this
is what happened.
Because it's not actually relevant to the story.
And if they want to dispute it, then we could go to court, or
we could like have this dispute in in private or in public.
>> I'm wondering >> is correct, we cite the contract.
We have copies of the contract. We cite them. We say according
to copies of the contract viewed by Wired. And again, none of
the creators that have come out since in all of the controversy,
if that was wrong and if their contract >> I don't know
where the Where are the quotes in here? Where is the site Where
is the citation or quotes here from the contract? I see you're
quoting like two or three words at a time. >> You see according
to according to copies of the contract viewed by Wired, right?
You You can read that, right? >> Yeah, so that's your interpretation.
I'm reading an op-ed. This is basically an op-ed right now. Yeah,
it's an op-ed. I'm getting an op-ed. >> No, it's not an
op-ed. It's a No, it's not an op-ed. It is reporting No, it's
not. There is no It is not an op-ed. Go look at what It is in
the news section. It's not an op-ed. It's not subject to any
of that sort of >> your opinion on what the contract said.
You're not giving me I don't see any >> No, there's no
opinion there. It is according If we are quoting we are >> This
is an op-ed. This is No, it's not. Do you know what the difference
is with an op-ed? She could make this claim and they wouldn't
go according to contracts reviewed by the Wired editorial staff.
That's how you know it's not an op-ed because they wouldn't give
a Why is he >> Citing directly from >> Okay, yeah,
you're not quoting. I don't know what you're citing. I mean,
if you're saying not a quotation, this >> We cite the contract.
And again, Destiny >> Yeah, this is your interpretation
of what the contract said. I want to see the contract. >> our
interpretation. It is not our interpretation. It's what the creators
were told. It's what the contract says. It It's what the >> Did
you post proof that the creators were told that? Were there any
text messages or emails or communications that were published
in this? >> We cite Actually, we cite a bunch of that stuff.
If you go through and read the story, you can see that the story
is based on our article. >> of things. >> No. I don't
know what to tell you other than like, do you think that these
hundreds of creators hundreds of creators in this program. If
this was never in the over 100 creators, I think the initial
class, right? If this was not in the If this was actually not
in the contract or we got it wrong,
why why when Wired lawyers reached out, why wouldn't there be
a correction on that article? >> It could be a variety
of reasons. It could be that they don't want to get into a protracted
war with you if they feel like you have nothing to lose and things
to lose. It could be that they feel like your initial reporting
uh could never be uh countered with any number of contract releases
because you'll always find some other thing to fight them on.
It could be that they don't feel like they they don't want to
give away some amount of information that they have a right to
retain privacy to. It could be they feel like their influencers
are going to be harassed because you called out so many specific
names in this article seemingly just for the purpose of directing
harassment at them. I don't know if there's going to be a million
>> Uh okay, hold on. Hold on. Hold on. You're just trying
to harass these people. Hold on. Where is this here?
Graham Wilson. So, a screenshot from a slideshow was shared with
Wired. So, hold on. The contracts reviewed by Wired prohibit
standard partnership disclosures, declaring that creators will
not publicize their relationship with Chorus or tell others that
they're members of the program without Chorus's prior express
consent. A screenshot from a slideshow was shared with Wired
following this article's publication by Graham Wilson, a lawyer
working with Chorus that offers several talking points if a member
of the cohort wanted to discuss Chorus Chorus publicly.
after after they reached out for comment and after a lawyer from
Chorus reached out and said, "Okay, here's how here's like a
screenshot of how we told them to talk about it publicly." It's
like, "Okay, but that's not saying they can disclose it if they
wish to, right?" They also forbid creators from disclosing the
identity of any funder and give Chorus the ability to force creators
to remove or correct content space solely on the organization's
discretion if that content was made at a Chorus organized event.
So, the only thing I don't even know what what would be the only
thing disputed here is basically like about how you could publicly
disclose, okay? And then they said, "Wilson did not reply to
a request for comment before the article was published. Uh there
are some real great advantages to housing this program in a nonprofit."
Wilson said to creators on a Zoom call reviewed by Wired. "It
gives us the ability to raise money from donors. It also, with
this structure, it avoids a lot of the public disclosure public
disclaimers, you know, paid for by blah blah blah blah that you
see on political ads. We don't need to deal with any of that.
Your names aren't showing up on like reports filed with the FEC.
So, here's the quote from a Zoom call that's explaining how your
names won't show up. So, again, clearly Dessi didn't read the
article cuz he's totally talking about in this in this whole
thing he's totally explaining, "No, no, no, it has to show up
on public FEC filings, guys. No, they're required to do that
legally."
And then there's the lawyer that's doing the Zoom call going,
"Well, we get to It's nice that we're housing we've structured
things this way cuz it allows us to avoid putting your names
in any reports and we don't have to publicly disclose it and
you don't have to publicly disclose it. Isn't that cool, guys?"
And so apparently
apparently So, by the way, this guy commented. He did not correct
this
He does not correct this quote. He basically says, "Well, actually,
here's some additional stuff we added later."
Right? That quote is not corrected. So, let's see at the bottom
there's a thing. Updates from a couple days after the article
was published. Graham Wilson of the Elias Law Group, whose participation
in Zoom calls was reported upon and who did not respond to Wired's
pre-publication email requesting comment, reached out to Wired
on several points. These include whether members of the cohort
can publicly talk about Chorus or about working with Chorus and
Chorus's connection to Good Influence, both of which Wired has
clarified. We
We have also included comment from Wilson regarding Chorus placing
restrictions on content and whether V Spehar was included in
any Chorus materials. I don't even know what that
he doesn't correct like what he was saying in the Zoom call.
Right? So, they don't have to publicly disclose. It's not going
to be an FEC
none of those things that you gave are are any sort of legitimate
because it would be it would be we could be legally sued if we
didn't correct it. That we would I would be sued and Wired would
be sued. If we if we knew
All of those things that you said are irrelevant. If you if if
we knowingly printed false information and refused to correct
it, and chose not to correct it, then you have a lawsuit on your
hands. So, it's just And by the way, they were so eager, right?
Remember they were like, "Oh, we'd love to sue." Da da da. I'm
sorry. They would issue a >> I don't I Well, they did issue
a correction. Brian Tyler Cohen made a video speaking about the
stuff. You don't like it, but he they did issue what they felt
like
>> He didn't No, no, no. He just put out a video. It's
not issuing a correction.
That's not issuing a correction. Issuing a correction is what
a publisher does when you prove that they said something wrong.
They'll issue a correction.
No, no. He's saying they issued a correction because Brian Tyler
Cohen posted something about this. Guys, that's issuing a correction
now, apparently, according to this guy. Do I have the BTC thing
here? I had it open earlier. I lost the tab for it. Give me a
second. >> don't need I'm sorry. You meant Wired would
issue a correction. Sure. Wired has not corrected anything in
this article. That's fine. But my one I mean, my guess is going
to be just the optics of it alone of a media interest group I'm
sorry, some partisan interest group suing Destiny Box. >> some
examples of creators disclosing their relationship with Corvus.
Except Oh, he's about to pull this point from chat, isn't he?
So, it's not about it's not disclosing the relationship cuz that
wasn't disallowed. You could say, "I'm working with Corvus. We're
working together."
You could say that if you wanted to. You can't say, "I'm being
paid by Corvus." That's what you're not allowed to say, >> political
outlet or a media outlet probably is a really bad look irrespective
of >> Again, they don't have to sue. They could just get
the article corrected. And the fact that it's not corrected is
because nothing It's because it's not false. It's simply not
false. I'm sorry to tell you it's not false. And by the way,
that influencer that shared a portion of her contract only confirmed
our reporting.
So, I would love if the contract was uploaded publicly by these
creators. They could go for it, go for it. But the regardless,
our reporting stands completely confirmed. And if it was false,
there would be a correction. Because even if they don't want
to do it publicly, they would they would happily provide the
lawyer with proof that I was wrong. They would happily get the
article corrected. That's all they would want to do is get that
article corrected because they don't they don't >> That's
fine. That like if if that's your perspective, that's okay. My
standard for journalism is a bit higher. No, no, this is your
This is slap journalism that you're describing. Is that I publish
a thing
>> My standard for journalism, as somebody who is never
done anything like this, uh maybe he'd argue that DG Cheers writing
the Keppels article for him was doing something like this. My
standard for journalism is higher than your standard for How
many times have you called random people with no evidence, knowing
full well that you're just lying about them? What's your standard
for journalism again?
I mean, he he just lies about people for
I took
He's got one Keppels article that was written primarily by other
DG Cheers. That's sourced and researched entirely by people who
actually wanted to put work into that, not him. Okay. That's
slap journalism, by the way, in Wired magazine. Well respected.
By the way, some people think Wired magazine is like, oh, well,
that's not really that big a That's not really that big a thing.
No, it is it is that big a thing, actually. They are very well
respected. They do not have to correct stories often.
>> thing. And if there hasn't been >> Cuz even if
they don't want to do it publicly, they would they would happily
provide the lawyer with proof that I was wrong. They would happily
get the article corrected. That's all they would want to do is
get that article corrected because they don't they don't >> That's
fine. That like if if that's your perspective, that's okay. My
standard for journalism is a bit higher. No, no, this is your
This is slap journalism that you're describing. Is that I publish
a thing and if there Dude, he's so out to lunch on this entirely.
It's actually I feel like people don't cover this stuff when
Destiny's like a complete like this cuz they see his like old
reputation. This isn't This is like tragic, man.
His My standard for journalism is you have to publish all of
the material. You can't make claims from anonymous sources. You
can't make claims for materials that you're not willing to publish
in full or even publish the parts of, right? It's It's just crazy.
It's crazy. I do want to see if we could go back to either COVID
stuff or any of the stuff around Trump Russia and see what his
opinions on anonymous sources and [__] like that
was back then. And if you could just trust the institutions.
I guarantee you I feel like I'm positive he has a whole epic
soy rant about how these institutions are important and you can't
trust everything you you can't validate all of the information
in the world by yourself. And so trusting like a a well-respected
publisher is actually really important to do. You should be able
to trust them basically blindly. Right? That's the way these
things work. I guarantee you this this rant exists
There hasn't been a retraction or correction on it then the thing
must be 100% true even if I do a really shoddy job at just must
be 100% true. Do you see how he like sets up the hyperbole?
Right? It's like well, no like technically I could have gotten
something wrong around the edges, but substantively it's true.
>> justifying any of it in the article. And the reality
is that you don't justify any of your stronger claims in the
article. You don't justify that content restrictions exist like
you put what I think in the headline of the article. You don't
justify that the people were totally forbidden from disclosing
anything which is seems to be contradicted by the fact that as
soon as this article came out a lot of people started talking
about them.
>> I don't have to prove mine. I'm the reader. The onus
is on you, Taylor. Taylor, you're not the journalist. You have
to prove your claims.
>> You don't have to prove your claims.
>> Not in like news articles where it's being reported
like Dude, when when they have off-the-record sources, when you
look at that whole New York Times article, okay?
Uh let's see Trump.
How Trump decided to go to war with
Right? This whole article is sourced
But nobody says, "Well, I don't believe any of this. He's not
proven anything." This whole article I say I say dubiously, it's
sourced from like anonymous people, someone close to the situation,
according to someone close to the situation, according to somebody
in the room. Right? Over and over again, these are the sourcings
for this entire article. But, it doesn't make the article false.
The New York Times is literally putting their dick on the table
and saying, "Hey, Trump admin, go ahead
and try to say any of this is false. I dare you. It's It's obvious
this is how journalism works."
>> Uh you know, some some evil monster, you know, "Oh,
I don't have to claim other I don't you know, I don't have to
I can just say whatever I want. It's up to you to disprove it."
Like you're you're just making these ridiculous claims. >> WELL,
I AGREE. THAT WOULD BE A ridiculous claim. But, what you just
did is what you just is what you did before. You made a random
claim, and now you're telling me that I have to disprove it.
I CAN'T DISPROVE IT. BUT, you never even proved your claim.
>> She's I I hope she doesn't make this argument when she
doesn't have a team of editors behind her. But, the whole reason
she could do this is because she has an institution behind her.
That institution is validating her
That's the whole point. I She doesn't do a good job of arguing
this, by the way, cuz she's not like a debater. But, that is
like the thing she should hammer again and again and again and
again. You are I'm not making random claims. I'm making claims
backed up by an institution, by a fairly storied institution,
by an institution that is a part of Condé Nast, one of the largest
and oldest
institutions that exists. What about our god? >> The article
I really think you have a a deep misunderstanding of journalism.
>> you keep saying these words, and I appreciate you saying
them and spinning people around in circles. >> can just
go and I know and I I understand the distrust in journalism.
I really do. >> But, mainly all media journalism, especially
because of subjects like >> Oh, uh-oh. Uh-oh. Uh-oh. Uh-oh.
>> I don't trust >> to trust I have to You have First
of all, you have to trust third parties to some extent. >> I
don't have to trust them. >> you do. YOU DO EVERY DAY.
When you turn the keys in your car, you hope your engine doesn't
explode. When you're drinking water, you hope that the public
water or whatever tap or bottled water you got it out of isn't
contaminated or poisoned with cholera. >> I do that as
a consequence of consensus. >> Of course you do. >> No,
I don't. I do that as a consequence of observing multiple times
that when I put the god key in the ignition, the truck started.
>> Why do you know it's going to start the 50th or 100th
time? Why do you How many times do you wear them?
>> Luckily for us, luckily for us, it's actually both ways
for for Taylor and Wired. It's actually both ways. They're an
institution that is that has consensus behind it, but they also
have a repeated track record of publishing things that are true.
Oh my god, worst both ways. >> I know perfectly well Hume,
you don't know if the denim in those jeans isn't leaking into
your bloodstream. To some extent, we have to trust third-party
institutions to make a determination. >> force staff. >> When they
use force, we trust the police officers, we trust the judicial
system. >> I don't don't care beyond that. >> You on
the left trust the police, do >> To some extent do it.
If somebody's breaking into your house, who do you call? I'm
not a defunder, but if somebody's breaking into your house, you
can be the most defunded person in the world, who are you going
to call? Are you going to call your neighbor? Are you going to
call Joe Biden? Are you going to call Obama? Are you going to
call the Black Panthers? You're going to call the >> How
do you How do you How do you control yourself and not say who
you're going to call and then make a Ghostbusters joke? I said
I don't even know how I couldn't >> So so tell me this.
Tell me this then.
>> Couldn't imagine. Couldn't say who you're going to call
eight times in a row in a conversation and not say Ghostbusters,
man. I just I couldn't
This real patch is there. It is there.
Yeah, it's the whole thing there.
All All of those are reasons why Taylor Lorenz has legitimacy
with this article.
God, I'm so curious what kind of state JBP is in right now. Uh
as far as I know, he is like near death and has been near death
for a very long time and Michaela talks about it occasionally,
like once every 6 months.
Talk about how this guy is dying. He's He's totally
Some people think he's been dead for a while. Yeah. That's but
yeah. >> Sure, but like to to act like, you know, my whole
article is secretly untrue and it's a you know
that that that that that that that these >> This is the
point where I'm like, holy are you good? You having a stroke?
This is like she is like I don't know if she's rattled. I don't
know if she's like exhausted. I don't know what happened there,
but
yeah, that's but she's not wrong in any part of the conversation.
It's just funny that she dude, that was
>> to act like, you know, my whole article is secretly
untrue and it's a you know
that that that that that that that these influencers that are
so desperate to prove me wrong
would somehow be withholding that information that would prove
me wrong and actually vindicate that, but they're all withholding
it. I don't even know why just because just in order to let my
article stand for some reason. It's just very silly. >> Wait,
that was bad? That was pretty rough. Yeah, that was like eight
or nine stumbles in a row. I think she does one more here coming
up in just a second. You can I was doing something else and watching
this when I was originally watching it. So I I like would check
out for large portions of the conversation, but then I'd hear
like it it it it's just a bit
I'm like, dude, are you good? >> in order to let my article
stand for some reason. It's just very silly. Like I'm sorry.
>> You can keep repeating this line over and over again,
but to me, I'm not looking like for a debunk
Sorry, I'm saying basically like optically in the conversation,
it just looks bad. It's it's not it doesn't mean anything, right?
Like it literally doesn't mean anything. She's still totally
correct in her perspective.
But I'm just saying it looks goofy. It sounds goofy. >> when
I'm looking at an article, I'm just looking to see if the original
article even substantiates what's being said in the article.
>> We cite we cite the contract, we cite text messages,
we cite recordings of the phone calls. We we we >> I would
just It would be cool if she could just say, if this story was
sourced anonymously,
how would it be substantively different? Like have you respected
articles that quote anonymous sources? Have you ever like looked
at an article that says, well, we quoted these two anonymous
sources. And then how do you substantively differentiate that
from my article,
That's the I think those are the two
>> We've got actually recordings of their onboarding zooms.
We we cite all of >> those things that you're referring
to substantiate the video that there were content restrictions
or that disclosure was banned from the from any of the influencers
participating. >> We we literally again it's cited in the
article. You don't like that you don't have the primary sources
and that's what's upsetting to you is that you don't have the
primary sources and I understand why that's up >> Oh man,
I can already tell what Tom
uh coverage would be because he's been in here saying like Destiny's
wrong but he doesn't understand what or Destiny's wrong but also
Taylor's lying.
I think like he's going to think that basically when they come
out and say, well, I can talk about Israel-Palestine and I can
be super pro-Palestine.
And then when they come out and say, well, no, they they didn't
stop me from
I I think Tom is expecting Tom feels like that's disproving stuff.
But realistically the article isn't saying uh these people will
be fired immediately. These people have been fired or will be
fired automatically if they ever disclose. It's not saying that.
It's saying in the contract it says you cannot disclose without
talking to Course first.
That's what it says. And so the obvious the obvious reason you
put that in a contract is to say we don't want you disclosing.
Right? That is the thrust of that. We don't want you disclosing.
If you need to disclose or if you think you need to disclose,
you have to come talk to us. Doesn't outline any punishments
but it it says that explicitly in the >> setting to you
as a as a news consumer, that's something that I hear constantly
when I cover news is I want to see the receipts. I want to see
the primary sources because people don't trust journalism anymore.
They don't understand how the process of journalism works. They
don't understand the amount of vetting and fact-checking that
go into producing an article. So the only way that they can sort
of understand how to consume information is to sort of see things
directly and kind of try to make their own interpretations because
they don't understand the fact-checking process. What I would
tell you is that there is a fact-checking process and again,
these influencers would love to discredit me. They would love
nothing more than to discredit me and they would love to prove
me wrong. And I don't know what to tell you other than our story
is based on facts. It is remains factually true and there has
been no not a shred of evidence
that has disproven any of the claims that are made in our story.
Now, I totally hear you. >> It's legitimately insane how
similar to this last to this is to the last conversation they
had. Yeah.
I just don't understand why you'd accept another conversation
with this person and get bodied on the exact same points with
no updates at all. Like you would
you would think that something would have had to change for you
to go and
demand a conversation on the same topic again and then to go
back and get bodied without changing any of like updating anything.
You didn't look into anything
It's so goofy to me. Is anybody else two and 0 versus Destiny?
No.
And it's
it's actually super funny to me.
Why are they doing this? Cuz Destiny Oh, Missy, you must have
missed it earlier. Okay, I don't know who was here earlier or
who wasn't, but I'll just do I'll do a quick reminder of why
we're covering this and why this popped up. Okay, so Taylor Lorenz
actually tweeted at Destiny. So Destiny published a video on
this topic. Destiny reviewed the Pisco Taylor conversation.
And when he put the video out >> What else is going on?
>> When he put the video out, it has an intro and it basically
makes some claims. So, this is so strange. Destiny claims without
evidence I take money from a Qatari dude. I don't take any dark
money and never would because I still write for me mainstream
media, and that would violate every basic journalistic ethics
clause out there.
Right? So, Destiny just got like ass mad watching Pisco and Taylor
talk, and he just made some [__] up.
However, very dangerous. Pretty [__] sus. Pretty
[__] sus, if you ask me. I don't know what the [__]
else is going on in that sussy baka
Yeah, that's not what anyone said. He's just making this up.
Like, it's it's actually funny how inaccurate and he is with
all of this stuff.
Yeah, you can tell he like kind of sort of paid attention to
it, but he's speaking out he's speaking like confidently as if
this is what happened. It's not what happened.
Yes, the audio mixing was terrible.
Do you see how good she is? Do you I'm I'm not exaggerating when
I say that she's probably like in terms of like like I think
that Kelly Jean was one of the most kind of like effortlessly
manipulative Oh.
There There's the name.
I told you it was like the same He was doing the same thing.
I saw how it was like playing out.
I actually I called this just from like I backwards
I inferred this from how he was treating Taylor in the conversation.
I'm like he's trying to make this look like she's Kelly. Like
that's what he's He's trying to lean on the Kelly thing. It's
like Nicholas De Oreo when this fat talks flamenco or whatever,
right? He's just going to take it and like oh, if I just web
this person to somebody else my my community hates, then I can
win. >> with people I've never heard speak before. She
is like the Kelly Jean. Like you see how many twists and turns
she um maneuver Pisco through there. So, I think we would have
agreed most stuff, you know, um Oh, wait what like what not or
whatever. Like oh, you know, like the the chorus drama. Oh, like
what do you think we wouldn't agree on? Well, you know, like
I think that maybe they um something something. It's like oh,
well, maybe they should have released her contract so they have
more transparency and they would have gotten a single correction
in the story, right? Like she's so good at just like Oh my goodness.
Oh man. I wonder if Pisco's going to I don't know if he's aware
of this or not.
>> Yeah, I You just need to like wish cast to try to make
Pisco wrong in some way. I guess. I guess so. I guess you just
need to make things up to make Pisco
>> who by the way that there are a lot of >> How
should somebody Let's say that I say Let's say that I claim I
have seen a contract and it actually fully uh invalidates everything
that you're saying about >> You went to war with me. >> Does
he Weasel little liar dude, thank you for the gifted sub. I appreciate
it. So, again, if you have like a institution with the like prestige
of Wired who's going to stand behind you and say, "Hey, we validate
that he actually this this contract actually does." Then you
can One, you could like take that to Wired, make the argument.
If they didn't want to retract it and you were correct, you could
sue them.
>> about chorus. Now, what do we do? If neither one of
us is willing to publish the original contract. >> true
if that was true, then you could just go to the um the the Condé
Nast lawyer and say, "Hey, I was a course creator and >> Yeah,
she's not again So, Destiny's going to pretend not to understand
what she's saying because his audience he needs to win the conversation.
So, what she's saying is I have an institution standing beside
behind me that is validating the things I'm saying that are putting
themselves on the record saying we actually this is our opinion
as well.
Do you have somebody like that doing it for you? Cuz if you don't,
I can just dismiss you cuz you're a you're just a random person.
And if you did then we would probably get in a room and try to
figure out exactly what's going on here, how we [__]
this up. Right?
>> And I have a copy of the contract and it's not what
you claim and they would immediately issue a correction. >> What
if they don't want to be involved with the harassment campaigns
and everything else that goes on from all of >> This is
Wired. They're reporting
on Trump and Doja. This is nothing for them. They >> This
but this this particular article There's no way hold on. I could
have sworn he was referring to like chorus didn't want to go
and get involved and like try to correct.
But that would have been cuz BTC already corrected publicly.
But what is he Yeah, is he like saying Wired fears like Kiwi
Farms Wired fears snarkers?
That's what Wired is worried about? Is
Is this real? >> This is Wired. They're reporting on Trump
and Doja. This is nothing for them. They >> This but this
this particular article that you wrote was a huge hit piece and
all the people involved and like the center-left sphere of politics.
Maybe they don't want to be named. You I know you love dropping
names in these paragraphs and knowing that you will direct harassment
to them. >> They don't want to be named. No, no, no. The
people if you're providing if you're providing information
you know, to to fact check the piece that you wouldn't be named.
>> Is this all it's like signaling? That was just signaling.
I know you like dropping names to drive harassment. Wait. So,
what happens By the way, this guy is still like on a on a stream-to-stream
basis
still talks about what a [__]
disgusting clout chasing gold digging pixie is. Like Like every
streamer every other stream he talks about it.
What is he doing there? That's crazy. >> the article. You're
not agreeing to go on the record. You're just providing You're
providing your contract. >> Do you think that if a correction
was even issued at this point it would even correct for any of
the damage done at this point?
>> Well, I think if a correction was issued that would
be huge. >> It wouldn't be. >> because Oh my god,
yes it would. Oh by the way, I had dinner with just a few chorus
creators the other night. Yes, it would be. Yes, it would be
because they would all They would love nothing more than to disprove
this article. They would love nothing more to do that because
they think that it has been damaging. And what I would argue
is that the damage and I do think actually again some of the
creators that I even have hung out with recently were sort of
talking about this. Like I would argue the real damage is in
the response to it. And instead of sort of
>> Wait, did I hold on? I didn't just miss the part where
he cuz I did catch this later on. He didn't just do the thing
where he was like, "Oh, even if um even if they corrected it,
the damage is already done." Did he just say that? Did I miss
it? Did I misreact to it? I have to go back and watch it again.
There's no way I just missed that part.
>> Because Oh my You won't be named. You won't be named.
No, no, no. The people who are writing If you're providing information
you know, to to fact-check the piece that You You wouldn't be
named. Why would you be named in the article? You're not agreeing
to go on the record. You're just providing You're providing your
contract. >> Do you think that if a correction was even
issued at this point it would even correct for any of the damage
done at this point? >> One, like I don't know any of the
damage done. It's literally just like lefties who point this
out. And I thought they weren't even a part of your coalition.
So, I don't know why you care about their opinion on this.
But like even then, they're not going to directly like if if
this article were to be totally corrected, they wouldn't be referencing
it all the time. They wouldn't be. They would stop referencing
it. Hasan wouldn't talk about it anymore. Mike wouldn't talk
about it anymore.
Right? I know they do talk about it. But if it were corrected,
if it were like categorically false or even mostly false, like
substantively false, they wouldn't bring it up anymore. They'd
look stupid.
>> Well, I think if a correction was issued, that would
be huge for because Oh my god, yes, it would By the way, I had
dinner with just a few chorus creators the other night. Um They
Yes. >> It wouldn't be. It wouldn't make a difference if
it was corrected.
>> It would be. Yes, it would be because they would all
they would love nothing more than to disprove this article. They
would love nothing more to do that because they think that it
has been damaging. And what I would argue is that the damage,
and I do think actually, again, some of the creators that I even
have hung out with >> Bro, I actually agree with this point,
which is sad cuz normally I don't really like this. Like, "Oh,
I actually think your response is But their response was
Their response was to go like, "Oh, actually, there's just no
reason to really You could tell the response was coordinated,
which was really unfortunate. That like the So somehow they're
all like, "Actually, we'd be harassed too much if we if we disclose."
It's like, "What? Why would you be harassed for disclosing?
You don't want to disclose cuz it makes you look bad.
They don't want you to disclose cuz it makes you look bad. Right?
You lose legitimacy with your audience. You're not this edgy
outsider if you're getting all of your If you're getting a ton
of money from this company to go and do your political content,
>> recently we're sort of talking about this. Like, I would
argue the real damage is in the response to it. And instead of
sort of >> It went to audience. >> Oh, anonymous,
thank you for the gifted sub to
Thank you. Thank you. >> discussing these things in a normal
way. Like, it's been litigated into this thing where people again,
they they end up sort of doubling down on the
claims made in the article instead of what I think they should
have done, which is just proactively disclosed it. I think that
would have completely
it would have hamstrung the article. Um I think that's the reason
>> Can you Can you tell me explicitly why is it that you
would never publish the contract in question if you had a hold
of the original contract. >> The we were the lawyers the
lawyers make those decisions. >> journalist. Tell me why
the lawyers make those decisions. >> Yeah, for for all
for all different reasons, but basically what >> She shouldn't
she shouldn't give any reasons. She should just say, oh, yeah,
they they made this decision. I don't know why. As I engaging
in this at all when it's just like sophistry is stupid. You just
say, no, they said no.
I didn't question them. They're paying
for honestly, I'm not a lawyer, so I don't understand you know,
I don't have >> literally have people that publish like
Trump's tax returns and stuff? Like you're telling me that like
nobody's
How is that analogous?
Who are you protecting by not publishing Trump's tax returns?
Your your argument your argument there is that this is all in
the public interest. She's saying the contract isn't in the public
interest. That like everything you get from the contract is expressed
in the article.
Right? And if there's something if basically if there's a mislead
in the article, if you think the article's wrong, then you should
come to us for a correction. Then of course you come to us for
a correction. Right? With Trump's tax returns, the thing in public
in the public interest is the thing being published is the tax
returns themselves.
The contract isn't like in and of itself the the like object
thing. If somebody just said also, the like there probably is
with a public figure with a somebody running for president, I
think the entire argument is we should be able to go through
every line of that tax return, right? You don't have a substantial
reason that you can't just believe the Wired the Wired editors
Does Desti think every news article that references a contract
publishes the entire contract? How would news orgs even do that?
Well, no, he doesn't think that. He's just he's performing
to try to get a known in this conversation. I don't know why.
He obviously knows like about trusting institutions, especially,
you know, like long long running publications, Conde Nast publications.
He knows about all of >> He's published a contract. Haven't
people gotten contracts from people in Hollywood or big podcast
sales and then publish those contracts? >> No, often the
contract itself is not published for for, you know, various
>> The guy who leaked Trump's tax returns to the press
was caught by the Trump admin and now he's in jail. Oh, well,
that's like a pretty uh-oh. Oops. >> you that you know,
the these I I I feel this frustration. If you remember like for
instance when I did my interview with Hire Right Tracker of Lits
of >> Just wait, Miss Elliott. This reminds me of the Pisco
conversations too. He's not arguing what he actually thinks.
He's just trying to keep her there. I don't know why. If you
think he's trying to keep her there now, I think she at some
point says I'm going to leave and he like immediately goes to
be like, "Well, you take dark money. Good luck with your dark
money." He like starts trying to get her looping on the dark
money thing again where she's like she gets upset about that
cuz she feels like it's an attack on her integrity.
It's very funny. He'll do that like so explicitly coming up at
some point. It's really funny. >> Um I worked so hard
to get my original my actual interview with her, that source
material made public specifically because I think it's really
beneficial >> you could have made it You could have made
it public though, no?
Not without approval from >> you not have just made this
a Substack >> What? Wait, what is a Substack post? >> Instead
of writing this for art for Wired, selling the article to Wired.
>> I'm guessing, so it would be so hot. My guess would
be without knowing for sure, some combination of like the people
who were getting Taylor these contracts probably didn't want
to be found out.
So, they would probably say, "Hey, please don't publish this.
Just like quote from it, but please don't publish this. Like
this is off the record, but here's my proof to you that this
is the contract I got, right?" And so she would agree to that.
And then she'd get the information, she'd look at it, she'd go
to Wired, Wired would say, "No, you can't publish it. You said
you wouldn't." And then they would move on from there, right?
But But she goes to Wired because she can't publish You explicitly
could go to would go to Wired, I think, because these people
I want to publish something, but I can't publish all the information.
And so it would just be my word. So I want a third party, an
institution,
who can validate my word and the word of these people and the
contracts they've given without publishing it. So we go to the
third party, the journalistic the the publisher the institution.
We say, "Hey, journalistic outlet, right? Hey, I want to publish
this story." And then they review it and they're like, "Here,
we'll publish this
>> Which I imagine they paid you for the article, right?
>> I am a freelance I was a freelancer, so I wrote it on
a freelance Yeah, I wrote it for freelance for them. >> Meaning
they paid you for the article, right? Yeah. >> Of course,
yeah. >> then why wouldn't you just publish this on a Substack
where you could release the entire contract? >> want because
I want legal review because I've been sued for defamation by
lunatics before. I've had so many >> for defamation publishing
a contract? How is that defamatory? >> god, because the
thing is with defamation suits, it doesn't matter if if they
have any merit. They They don't, obviously. All the times I've
been sued for defamation, it's, you know, thrown out or dismissed
or whatever. But it doesn't matter. It's a intimidation tactic.
And if >> Well, then wouldn't this one just get thrown
out and dismissed?
>> When you're when you publish something independently
on a Substack, you do not have the legal the level of legal protection
and legal review and editing. I wanted editors I've probably
half a dozen people worked on this story. I know my name is on
the top, but multiple editors, fact-checkers,
um lawyers, you know, people review worked on this story at Wired,
not just me. And I This is a story that was complex enough, and
especially with the amount of source material and the amount
of creators we spoke to and the amount of material that we had
I just don't understand.
Why is he pretending he doesn't get any of this?
>> source material. I wanted to bring it to somewhere that
I knew >> Fantastic play Kennedy caller. Why do you want
Why do you want like insurance? Why do you want a company with
lawyers and like publishers insurance? So that you could, you
know, get protected in the in the
event that somebody sues you. Meanwhile, Destiny paying 100,000
in legal fees per
Uh I have no idea why you'd want to avoid this. Why wouldn't
you just pay >> who had a track record of really just going
with the facts and making sure that absolutely everything I said
was bulletproof, double-checked, triple-checked by I would I
would argue some of the best editors working in media today.
So I would want to trust them with that story instead of me just
going on Twitter or giving it to some, you know, leftist hate
account that could have just made it into some drama and you
>> I don't I'm sorry. I don't I don't I just don't buy
any of that. There are tons of people that are posting incredibly
salacious stuff on Substack. The idea that you thought you would
have been sued by defamation. >> you that. They're not
Tiffany anywhere. I have I I do not have the level of legal protection
that some other people do. And let me tell you, I talked to Ken
Clippenstein, who's a good friend of mine, who does publish a
lot of like the legal stuff. His legal insurance like it it is
something that I certainly cannot afford. I I I don't have that
ability, unfortunately. And I think it's cool that some people
do, but as somebody that reports specifically on censorship campaigns
and reports specifically on, you know, these bad faith efforts
to silence journalists. >> There are people in chat who
are posting this this same article repeatedly or the same like
document repeatedly. BC funds, okay? This right here. So somebody
says this earlier in the conversation. They link this and they
say, "Page 11, private equity from the from the from 2023."
So they link this.
And Destiny doesn't understand
what that is, right? But he thinks it's a gotcha. And so he's
willing to, in conversation, bring it up as a gotcha. Okay? So
let's just listen to this. >> As a reporter, you are bound
by journalistic ethics.
>> Okay, can you sort through this? Can you help me help
me help me understand this, okay? So like on page 11 here, we
can look at the Omidyar Network Fund and we can see that there
is money that they get donated to them from like private equity
and other sorts of people. We don't know who these are. This
is a statement on >> So he says that, right? So it's this
link right here. So he says, "Page 11, you can see that they
get donated money from private equity and stuff." Program and
mission-related investments. Program and mission-related investments
are strategic investments aligned with the foundation's mission.
These investments are primarily composed of equities, equity
funds, and debt. This is literally their holdings in private
equity funds. They literally have investments in certain private
equity funds. I'm guessing private equity funds that either do
philanthropic work or or maybe it's just companies that they
like morally align with them in some way. These are the investments
they hold. This isn't them getting money from anybody else. But
he was willing to take this from chat and try to make an argument
based on it. But he looks completely
If she just felt confident enough to call him on this, he totally
made this up based on some stupid comment from his
Okay? He is a totally fake person. He is a complete
[__]
Okay?
And it's just it's frankly like embarrassing that people take
this guy seriously. It's He just made this up entirely. And it's
just embarrassing watching him take it from the chat, rip it,
and then throw it up, like make the argument, okay? Without actually
looking at this at all. But it sounds like he looked at it.
And he just didn't understand.
She probably didn't even know what he was referring to. Yeah,
but she knows that they're not taking money from a bunch of different
places or she feels confident that. If if they just brought this
up on stream, right? It would have been obvious that he doesn't
know what he's talking about. It's just very, very funny.
It's super funny. Uh if you go to page 11 here, you can see that
they get money from private
No, they don't.
No, they don't. Uh I just wanted to walk through that really
quickly cuz it feels kind of important just to show how fake
this person is in a general sense.
All right.
We have this one.
Close this. I think I can close this. I think this is where we
were, right? Yep, 2 hours 35. Okay, we continue on. >> a
whole story like this, I don't want to do it on my own. I want
the fact-checkers to rigorously go through it. I want lawyers
to tear it apart. I want people that are really the best in the
business to look hard at every single word and say, is this factually
correct? Is this factually >> email? If you email me the
contract, I'll publish it. >> That would be How do you
ask the creators I I certainly cannot do that myself legally.
I absolutely cannot do that. I'm You're asking me to just give
you source material for my story. But I would What I would tell
you is, why don't you go to these creators?
Why don't you go to these creators? >> they're all to the
left of me. They're not going to give me any. I've reached out
to two. They both would hate me. >> They're not They're
not to the left of >> They absolutely are to the left of
me. Absolutely, they are. >> I don't know the political
sort of, you know, breakdowns of everything, but I think there's
some people in there. I mean, Brian Tyler Cohen, if he's so eager
to, you know, share that this is not true, you would think that
he would publish the contract or certainly give it to another
outlet to discredit me. But he hasn't, and they won't because
the contract >> article on August 27th of 2025.
>> Your claim is that nobody was allowed to disclose that
they were part of Chorus.
And that's one of the things that you revealed in your
>> The contract says that they were not allowed to disclose,
and um yeah, there's still no dis- They're They're not They're
not allowed to disclose. They were not at that point. Now >> That
they were not allowed to disclose that they were part of Chorus.
>> No, no, no, no, no. So, you're mistaken. Chorus is the
broader sort of thing, but this is a the funding program is what
there was no disclosure over. The course was public, right? Course
got that whole profile in the New York Times by Ken Bensinger
when they were announced. Course was public. >> Okay, wait.
So just so I can Okay, so I can understand. So then you're saying
that they would all be allowed to say that they were part of
Course. They just weren't allowed to say that they that Course
was funded by 1630.
>> So Course is the bigger entity, but this >> I
don't precisely know what the clause meant that said it was what
they weren't allowed to disclose like funders. I don't know what
that clause meant, to be honest with you. >> specific political
influence funding
which had, you know, they did they're doing different cohorts.
They just started their second cohort, but their last cohort,
right? They were not those creators in that funding program were
not allowed to disclose
>> Watch this get spun into Taylor dunking on Destiny somehow.
I can't tell if that's like saying that people will say Destiny
lost or if that's saying that like somehow Destiny's going to
find a way to fumble this as well. >> track that they were
part of this funding program. And and you will not you I promise
you, but I'd love for you to try, find me any evidence that these
disclosed that they were part of this funding program before
my article. >> As in they were making money or as in that
Course >> they were part of a funding program. >> I
don't know what you say funding program. I don't know what that
means. Like you're like your reporter is in whatever thing like
that funding program >> Um well, that would be an example
>> But she shouldn't even say that. What she should she
should just stick to the article, right? Because again,
she doesn't know that nobody talked about basically being the
incubator program. Somebody could have, and they might have let
it slide. The whole point is that they don't want people to publish
it. They would don't want people to like say that they're a part
of it. Right? She should watch the claims she makes because that's
not actually
even if somebody had said, "Oh, I'm actually I'm proud to announce
I'm a part of the the Course incubator program." Like they it's
possible somebody did that, and then they didn't fire them or
let them go for violating the contract.
Right? It she should just stick to what the contract says and
what she reported.
>> Example of me disclosing funding? Sure. Yeah, that's
an example of me disclosing funding. So, you could say that you
know, any of these creators were saying, "Hey, I'm receiving
money or I'm you know, I'm sponsored
by XYZ. I'm part of this funding program that's giving me money
to you know,
promote whatever XYZ sort of messaging."
None of them disclosed it. >> The I mean, I can go I can
go look for more of this. I don't have all of this offhand, but
um I have no idea why I feel like publishing the contract or
actually publishing parts of the contract I think would have
led a lot to the credibility
to the uh >> I I I I hear you that you want source material
and I empathize with you and I always encourage news organizations
to put as much out as they can publicly. But, in the meantime,
there's 100 creators in that original cohort that can share their
contract with you. One posted publicly. >> keep saying
this, but in my mind >> I feel like she should again, she's
not a debater, but what she should be saying is, "So, you are
you believe that Wired would stake the reputation on this and
not see that this is said in the contract or not like not validate
any of the things I wrote in the article." Like, she should consistently
bring it back to Wired and Wired's editors over and over and
over again and make this guy say that he doesn't trust journalistic
institutions, that he doesn't trust publishers, he doesn't trust
these people. He wouldn't trust the New York Times if they were
reporting something with anonymous sources or from anonymous
sources because he obviously doesn't believe it.
But, because she's not able to like I guess hone in on that one
specific thing, the conversation keeps looping on >> In
good journalism, the onus is on the journalist to substantiate
their claims, not publish some whatever No, you didn't. You did
not. You did not publish any part of the contract. The one that
I was thinking of I guess was a TikTok girl I was publishing.
>> We didn't the source material, but we cite the we cite
>> opinions about it. >> No, we don't. We cite No,
no, we don't. No, we don't. We don't rely on our opinions of
it. No, we don't. >> the source material would be a quote
from the contract. What you're giving is your opinion on the
contract. >> No, no, it's not No, my opinion on the contract
is very different, actually. But But no, we >> Dude, this
is like This is like when again, when the two DOD people give
a comment, you know,
basically like you can publish this, but I don't want you to
know my identity. When they do that, he goes, "Oh, so you're
just giving your like opinion on their statement. You're not
giving me like what they said. You're not giving me anything.
You're just giving me your opinion on their
>> They are citing the contract. Not only are we citing
it sort of as it directly sort of says, but also as the as the
creators themselves were told.
Again, find me I like I'm sorry, you're >> wait, wait,
wait, where in the where in the article Where in your article
do you think you're citing from the contract talking about the
contract? >> "According to copies of the contract viewed
by Wired." We are citing >> It literally does that.
What did Again, he just said that like even when you hear him
say that,
Even when you hear him say that, he sounds confident. Like you
like like Oh, did she not Did Did Wired not review? Did they
not say that in the article? No, they obviously did.
They obviously did. >> I think the copies of the contract.
What is citing When you you're summarizing. You're giving your
opinion. >> No, we're citing No, we're not. No, there's
I have a very different >> opinion on it. >> There
are no quotes in the According to copies of the contract you
said According to copies of the contract to But you're saying
Hold on, you're saying you're giving your opinion on it, right?
They clearly have a group of people who reviewed these things,
including with lawyers, so they can figure out exactly what was
said. According to copies of the contract viewed by Wired that
creators signed, the influencers are not allowed to disclose
their relationship with Chorus or the 1630 Fund or functionally
that they're being paid at all. This is This is them saying what's
in the contract. Now, you could say that's your opinion on the
contract, but they're literally saying they're putting their
reputation on it. They're saying, "We got lawyers to review this.
We reviewed it. This is our opinion." Maybe you could say as
a journalistic outlet, it's the opinion of lawyers. It like you're
saying it's your opinion as in it's like not relevant or not
true.
Or if it is if that's like not the way all journalism works.
You know what I'm
Like sorry, it's saying it's your
as in like possibly if there's different legalities, you could
have lawyers like go toe-to-toe on some arcane legalities in
the contract. But nobody even disputes this stuff. Pretty much
everybody agrees that in the contract it says you're not supposed
to disclose the funding.
Like literally the guy who corrected the one guy who called in
to correct to say he had a Zoom conference with these people
where he said and that's not opinion at all. They quoted right
where he said like you're not allowed to quote this and you also
don't have to disclose anything. Oh sorry, that you don't have
to that you shouldn't disclose this and you don't have to be
disclosed at all. When he was talking about that, he didn't correct
any of that. I'm telling you I'm pretty sure the disagreement
here hinges on the operational use of the word citation.
He thinks you need to in-text cite it with quotes. So, I understand
why he thinks that. I understand like I understand what he's
saying.
again, I think what they think is that if they quote the language
directly that you could possibly have like one of a few different
things. But basically that they could word the the contract slightly
differently and hand them out to people to more narrow to more
narrow down like who could have leaked parts of Like that's somewhat
of a concern,
Right? So, if you do the exact quotes, that would be a problem.
And so, you'd want to like reword it or something, but
yeah, I don't know. I don't know. It's We could go into like
what publishers should be saying or what they should do for proof,
but ultimately what he's saying here is he's trying to make this
about Taylor Lorenz and her
It's not. It is about Wired's reputation. Basically, all of these
arguments he's making about Taylor's writing here, he needs to
equally make them about Wired and their staff.
That's the whole point, right?
So, like we we don't even have to get into like what is appropriate,
what you should be quoting, what you don't. I'm assuming that
the people who run this publication, who are employees of Condé
Nast, one of the oldest and most storied public publishers in
American history, okay? I believe Condé Nast, I believe we looked
it up what 1904 or
They've been in business since?
I think they've been in business since like a really long time.
I hope I'm not wrong on that. Condé Nast.
Condé Nast Wikipedia.
1909,
founded in 1909,
okay? Very old institution. So,
you you are attacking their reputation. You're not attacking
Taylor's.
Right? They're the people who came in and they said, "Well, actually,
we're going to put our name behind this." And do you think they're
unaware that that's how the article is written? That instead
of putting in full quotes or anything like that, they are saying,
"This is our We're putting our reputation on this." Does he really
believe this or is he being bad faith? He's being bad faith,
I think he hates Taylor Lorenz. This is an extension of like
the war against lefties, right? Pesca had a I think Pesca had
like a cordial conversation with her. And so, he needs to come
in and explain why that was wrong to do.
Right? That's why he's saying the thing about harassment campaigns,
which he doesn't believe in, clearly.
Um that's why he's doing all this cuz he's trying to make Pesca
look bad for having a like good faith conversation with Taylor
Lorenz. And he's looking [__] stupid doing it. Yeah,
like I don't know what happened with Taylor before. I certainly
remember some bad articles from her. I remember not liking her.
I remember her reputation being trash. But it doesn't matter
because the only people we have to contend with here are the
editors that put their names all over this article. Put their
their publication's name all over this
That's the authority. Anyway, we continue. By Wired, the creators
signed. The influencers are not allowed to disclose their relationship
with Chorus or the 1630 Fund. Oh, so wait, I'm sorry. It was
with Chorus and the 1630 Fund, not the limited thing that you
just claimed a second ago. So, was that a Is that a misprint
in your article? >> No, no, no, no, no. So, Chorus it the
the Chorus funding program, which is >> No, that's not
what this says. This says, "According to copies of the contract
viewed by Wired the creators signed, the influencers are not
allowed to disclose their relationship with Chorus or the 1630
Fund or functionally >> with their relationship with Chorus
being the funding program that they're part of. The funding program
that >> So, I maybe they have like a correction here or
something. So,
uh relationship with Chorus. Declaring the creators will not
publicize the relationship with Chorus or tell others that they're
members of the of a program without Chorus's
of the program without Chorus's prior consent. So, again, that's
why and again, uh it's very funny. She shouldn't be making the
claim that nobody disclosed cuz I think some people would have
said they've worked with Chorus, right? The entire thing should
be about what the contract says. That's the claim she should
make, that the contract say you cannot disclose this.
Right? Cuz it is it is not making it clear and I don't know if
that's the a failing of the article in terms of oh, they were
only only about the funding or if it was only about um or if
it was about talking about Chorus at all because eventually the
guy comes in and he corrects the Graham Wilson guy and he says,
"No, no, no, we explained how they could talk about Chorus,
right? But not the the program or the
So, it is not entirely clear. I think there's two different points
where they talk about this, right? According to copies of the
contract viewed by Wired the that creators signed, the influencers
are not allowed to disclose their relationship with Chorus or
the 1630 Fund or functionally that they're being paid at all.
Hmm.
I don't I do a parsing this is difficult for what this means
precisely.
But I do believe that the contract would say this. This isn't
saying that they're not allowed to do this or sorry, it's not
saying that they haven't done this. It's saying that the contract
prohibits them from doing so, right? Oh, sure. Operational is
their relationship. Sure, right. Relationship with course in
terms of the relationship of taking money. Yeah, okay.
I think that could be made way more
But regardless,
the reporting and the entire purpose of the reporting is to say
this is what's in the contracts.
It's not saying nobody's done this and like not gotten away with
it. It's just saying that in the contracts it prohibits them
from doing so. Okay. Anyway, we're back to the video. >> that
they're part of. >> That is what we're talking about. >> Okay,
don't necessarily I think that probably should have been I think
that probably should have been spelled out there, but the biggest
problem here is you're not citing the contract. This is your
interpretation of the contract.
>> It's not >> There's no quote It's what the contract
>> So, again,
maybe this is just missing.
What she should be saying here is it's not my interpretation.
It is the interpretation of myself, Wired's lawyers, like lawyers
who have gone over this contract,
and it seems to be the the interpretation of course themselves
because they've not corrected any of the writing in the article
on this topic.
Right? That's That's how this [__] all go. So, it's
not just my opinion, it is the opinion of the editorial staff
at Wired, it's the opinion of the lawyers at Wired, it is the
opinion of course because course has failed to correct any of
these points as well.
>> Well, I'm sorry we didn't put quotes around the sort
of the legalese that >> it means when you cite something.
You say legalese is simple contract language. Nothing here is
that >> Again, I think I I think you got to go to journalism
school. Citing something doesn't mean necessarily that you're
quoting directly from it. You can just say what it says. So So,
for instance, you mentioned Trump's tax returns. You can say,
"According to Trump's tax returns, he paid XYZ." That doesn't
mean that you're directly quoting from his >> the tax return
stuff, they were literally publishing the 1040. >> Yeah,
but Okay, Mr. Pedantic.
Uh so, she could come up with a actually, we're doing um we're
doing Mark Carney's tax returns now. But, they didn't publish
all of Mark Carney's tax returns. What they said was, "Actually,
according to Mark Carney's tax returns, blah blah blah blah blah."
All right? Blah blah blee blah, as Notsoreradic would say.
basically, what you wouldn't have to do is then publish the tax
returns themselves. You could just have the article or the the
institution say, you know, it's the CBC or something, and they
say, "According to contracts, according to the tax returns reviewed
by the CBC."
And nobody would question that. Unless Mark Carney wanted to
say, uh "Actually, the CBC is lying, and I'm going to sue them
for libel."
Cuz that's the way this all works.
>> the front pages and stuff, but >> Sometimes Sometimes
Sometimes. But, I'm saying that you can cite documents without
quoting directly from them. In fact, look at the OpenAI dispute,
right, with the Pentagon. The Atlantic story by Ross Andersen.
It's not >> Oh, yeah, sure. Nobody's citing the actual
contract between Anthropic Nobody is directly quoting the the
contract between Anthropic and the DoD, right? Probably, there's
stuff in there that's actually classified, like conversations
or language in there that's actually >> Citing It's not
quoting throughout the exact nature, you know, the exact language
of the contract. >> I There's a world where I could agree
to you, but you're giving like a you're giving a very huge summary
of what's going into this contract without any underlying quote.
>> You You You You You You. And again, all she needs to
do is reframe, go back to, "Actually, Wired is supporting me
in this supporting me in this. Wired's editors are supporting
me. Wired's lawyers are supporting me. Again, it
She could just totally totally take this and make it like an
institutional thing. She has institutional backing here. >> quotation
at all >> Wait. Oh my god. I'm sorry. Again, I'm sorry
that there's not more quotes in there from you, but again but
there is >> that I really I really wish there was like
good journalism where I could rely on what's being said in the
article instead of your interpretation and you clearly have demonstrated
multiple times in this conversation that you don't understand
the funding structure. You don't understand how these hybrid
entities work. You don't understand You don't know what a 501c3
is. You've discussed this over and over again, but I'm supposed
to I don't know how many fact checkers I don't know how many
fact checkers and what editors were involved on this. I don't
know for this one. I have no idea. Wired has different segments
of their company that report on different things and fact check
in different ways. I don't know what fact checking when it's
at every single part of this. >> you look at what section
it's under? And why don't you why don't you think you if you
think that the Wired politics section is my personal blog that
doesn't >> said it was a personal blog, but I think that
the standards I don't think this article should have been published
without more evidence in the article. I would say that easily,
of course. If you want to get somebody from Wired to argue with
me, you can ask them to come out and say, "Hey, tell Destiny
why he's such an idiot on what the journalistic standards should
be for this article." I would gladly talk to anybody from Wired
about it 100%. >> that if you want to make if you want
to claim that you personally would like more direct quotes and
that would have helped you personally better understand the article
or maybe people >> have helped It would have substantiated
the claims made in the article, which are largely unsubstantiated.
>> They are substantiated by directly from the contract.
We are We are We are You're right that the beginning didn't put
quotes around that language, but that language is is almost It's
It's very similar to >> If it was very similar, then why
don't I just have a quote? >> Because again Well, for many
reasons. One, when you're writing a story like this, the sourcing
is very clear. And when you're continually putting quotes, it's
it's There's editorial reasons not to do that. And again, I just
want >> I think this is an op-ed. I would say that this
is an op-ed. This
This article
is an op-ed. This is an op-ed, guys.
This is just a this is an opinion piece. Let's ignore the fact
that it includes
like half of the staff
at the half of the like like defense reporting staff at The New
York Times. Let's ignore that. Okay, this is just a this is just
an op-ed. This is just someone's opinion. Okay,
this is an op-ed. It's this is clearly an op-ed. This is an opinion
piece. This is an opinion. How can Destiny ever recover? Well,
you see, Orange Kush, the way he could recover is I believe he
hit about 9,000 or 10,000 concurrent viewers for this conversation.
And those people are all trained to like when he signals something
believe it with no critical thought at all.
And they will be totally insular and never argue this with anybody
else ever.
And so then they'll go on Twitter and basically describe how
he totally won or was totally correct in this conversation. And
nobody will ever like
There's like two classes of people. There's people who will like
engage and get overrun by these people. And there's people who
are just like, oh, this is the weird Destiny cult I'm going to
avoid I'm going to avoid entirely. >> There's no opinion
in that. >> It is. Everything is an opinion. You have you
have you don't have the original contract. We can't see it from
the public. You're quoting that your site or you're you're claiming
that you're citing to something a citation to material that we
don't even have. So, I don't know if I can even trust your citations.
Other people of course have come out and differ with what you've
>> right. You don't have my source
I just wish I would love to hear him just answer the question.
Like, do you just not trust Wired? Are you saying this Coda as
publication is actually like they just let me lie? They let me
use their reputation.
I'm Taylor Lorenz. Aren't aren't you going to argue that I'm
untrustworthy? Do you think they just let me like make things
up? >> And you're not quoting from it at all, >> notable
that you don't have source you don't have direct source material
of anything that you're claiming. You're claiming all this without
the contract. You're claiming all this stuff. >> And and
I have the source material which we referenced. >> Yeah,
but we don't have access to it. So, we don't know if your references
are good. Your opinions on it could be >> No, I I know
that you I know that you think that again, this just goes back
to this idea of people like not understanding the process of
journalism. And I think that this is a >> To be clear,
just to be ultra originally clear, this is an example of bad
journalism. This isn't an opinion. It's not. It's just not.
It's It's literally not a Dude, I don't know why these people
fight this so hard. You could totally argue that Course is like
good. You could just argue that. Actually, Course is good because
we are on a super slanted, you know, a super slanted landscape
where Republicans take this kind of funding and Democrats never
have. Republicans do this exact thing. Democrats don't. And we
need to match. And so, while it is dark money and while it is
while it is bad that these people don't disclose. And I would
like if they disclosed actually. I am willing to accept the downsides
of this for the upsides for us being able to compete in this
environment.
Like that's all you have to do, man.
That's a perfectly reasonable argument. Why can't you make that
argument? Why do you have to try to discredit her or the reporting?
That's just factual. They're just trying to get her on tilt.
This is slop journalism. You're like writing op-eds.
opinion You don't understand the journalistic process. You don't
You're referencing a contract that we don't have access to that
we can't verify or validate.
>> It's not in the story. Do You don't You never asked
my opinion. If you want to know my opinion on all of this, I'll
happily share. It's not in the story. It's not anywhere in the
story. But I would happily share my opinion on it if you're interested
to know. >> No, I just wish that the article itself would
have actually like substantiated anything it said with actual
excerpts from the contract. That would be a That would go really
really really far. >> You personally want more quotes?
>> She's like acknowledges This is like the fourth or fifth
time she's acknowledged. You want quotes from the contract. I
would like to do that more often. They said, "No." So, I'm fine
with not posting them cuz I they paid me and they are that their
editorial staff decided no or decided no. Okay? But like I understand
I would argue on your side that we should put more quotes in.
We should have more of the source material. I like that. They
said no. It's not hard to understand, >> What's in the
contract? I I totally accept that that's not an >> the
material that was used to substantiate the op-ed that I wrote.
That's what I want. I want the op-ed to be substantiated with
the actual material. That'd be so nice. That'd be so cool. >> It's
just simply not an op-ed. It's simply not an op-ed. And to And
to dismiss journalism like this is very disappointing. I understand
it's hard for influencers. I I understand this. I understand
that it is a confusing media landscape. I would argue that these
funding schemes could, you know, participate in sort of >> I
just don't know how I feel about somebody like you who gets money
from a dark money fund who's publishing hit
SEE, THAT'S WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT. OH, THAT'S WHAT I'M TALKING
ABOUT. She was getting ready to go and and he has to go, "Oh,
look. You get You take dark money actually. You take dark money
actually."
It's It's so funny, man.
Uh you actually take dark money. >> And to dismiss journalism
like this is very disappointing. I understand it's hard for influencers.
I I understand this. I understand that it is a confusing media
landscape. I would argue that these funding schemes could, you
know, participate in sort of >> I just don't know how I
feel about somebody like you who gets money from a dark money
fund who's publishing hit pieces on other influencers and Again,
uh she could just attack the foundation of this statement immediately.
I don't know how I feel like about you taking money from a dark
money fund.
Wired. Wired. Wired's reputation.
Wired published this. I didn't publish it on my own. If she took
money from the immediate thing she was doing a Substack post
and it played into a bunch of biases, you could probably ask
for more material, more information, right? And that would be
okay.
She explicitly avoided any of these allegations, any of these
exact critiques. I wonder if she went to Wired if if you asked
her in her heart of hearts, "Did you go to Wired because you
knew you'd get like [__] on by all these people and
you needed some kind of institutional backing?" I feel like she
would say yes.
Like, oh, there's going to be a whole bunch of people who come
after me and my reputation over this, so I need somebody else's
reputation to bolster it. Cuz if I just report on this, they're
going to go, "Oh, you're attacking You're attacking Democrats
cuz you're left-wing You're You're unhinged and
So, now she she just go Wired's
Wired's reputation. Not my reputation, Wired's reputation.
>> political orgs without disclosing any of the source
material that stuff came from because you wanted to get paid
by Wired instead of publishing it independently. That's just
a lot >> Yeah, dude. Like, Wired is just jumping at the
chopping at the bit. Wired, the magazine, okay? Condé Nast publication.
They're chopping at the bit to publish some totally
and pay somebody for the privilege. Yeah, 100%.
100% in their new section. Yep. Yep, that sounds like Wired.
That sounds like a Condé That sounds like a publication that
could run for more than 100 years, right? Without getting sued
in the [__] dirt. >> Absolutely. A lot of stuff
that's all coming together that makes me a little bit nervous
about the sourcing of the >> I would get paid more if I
published it independently. I would have made way more than what
I made from Wired for >> did you get paid by Wired for
it? >> Not very much, let me tell you. For months and months
of recording, I don't think I can share my rate, but >> Oh,
so you're not allowed to disclose Do you know what Wired's funding
mechanism is for everything? Is this Wired
>> Dude, is Wired a dark money organization?
Is Wired dark money? >> Publicly public >> Every
every like straw man people could have used to attack Destiny
like and his points here, he's actually just validating. Like,
the it wasn't a straw man. That he thinks somebody getting paid
by McDonald's is literally someone taking dark money cuz he's
an actual
Give me 1 second. I'm going to use the bathroom and get some
more water. Can you publish where they get all their money from?
>> Wired gets money from subscriptions and advertising.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure they're I don't know. You'll have to look
at Conde Nast tax filings. I don't >> All of their all
of their sources are are publicly available cuz otherwise wouldn't
that make Wired a dark money fund? And you're not even disclosing
the amount that you're receiving from Wired for it.
>> Do you think that Do you think that journalists should
have to report how much money they get paid to write articles
for companies that they don't work for? >> Oh, I actually
would love transparency. >> Well, then why don't you start?
Wait, then why don't you publish it? >> Because we agreed
not to share rates.
So, then what's the problem with companies like Chorus if they
have their agreements, but they're all obeying the law? They're
all doing what's legally required of them. >> I'm publicly
I am public What is the difference between a journalist publicly
writing for a news outlet and a influencer taking part in a secret
political influence scheme? >> It's not a secret influence
scheme. You yourself said they they were already public about
Chorus. You just >> No, it was The funding scheme that
I wrote about, the 1630s fund stuff, was not public. The funding
The political influence scheme was not public. I'm sorry, it
was not public. >> The fact that creators are part of Chorus,
were part of this group, that was public information.
No. Most of the creators >> That's not public information
at all. Some people decided to share that they had partnered
with Chorus, but it is not like automatic public information.
He's going to make the argument again about public disclosures
based on like FEC filings, maybe.
But that's just not true. And he should know that from again
PV. >> It was mentioned actually it was not public at all.
>> Hold on. No, no, no, no. I'm saying that there were
there were people Nothing about it was mandated to be private
that they were in Chorus. They have YouTube videos of themselves
on Chorus panels and talking about stuff. None of this was not
>> Chorus itself was public, but not everyone affiliated
with Chorus is in
the the the funding scheme with 1630 fund. So, there are people
that were affiliated with Chorus that were not part of the funding
scheme. The funding scheme is what was secret. It was a secret
political influence funding >> Weren't they all part of
the same thing but just some were getting paid and some
>> No, some were not part of that. >> Some some are
some also like are moving >> It's all about the incubator
program. That's again, specific language would help here. Incubator
program. >> forward with the second cohort, some were not.
I would love if they would publish a full roster, but regardless
>> And are they legally required to? >> No, and that's
that's again, that's what I have a problem I point out in the
article. Um but journalists freelancing for a public for a news
outlet is nothing like a political influencer taking part in
a secret political influence campaign. A journalist freelancing
and I totally >> not required, they're not required to
publicly disclose, right?
>> No, that's that's what I point out in the article is
that they're not required to by law and that's a huge problem
in our political ecosystem and something that I wish that both
parties would work to address cuz I think transparency is good,
which is why >> I I mean, we know Destiny of all people
is not confusing the difference between like a moral imperative
and a legal imperative, right? Like he's like obviously he's
not confusing these things. Obviously he knows the difference.
It's he's it's literally the thing he's done for like 15 years
on the internet. >> Why, as I said to you before, I wish
that um pay rates across the board for freelancers were also
all equal. I mean, I've worked at places where I found out that
the person next to me is making thousands of dollars more for
the same work as I do. Pay transparency overall >> And
you still maintain that the people that were part of Chorus that
they were they had content restrictions on the types of things
that they could say?
>> What we cite in the article
is that content and and correct me if I'm wrong cuz you have
the article in front of you, content produced with Chorus funds
was under restriction, I think. If it says in the article, you
have to read the exact language that we use in the
>> I'm sorry. So, your headline as part of your headline
here you say that an initiative aimed at boosting Democrats online
influencers uh at boosting Democrats online offers influencers
up to $8,000 a month to push the party line. All they have to
do is keep it secret and agree to restrictions on their content.
The implication there being the type of content that they make
yeah, so you can read you can read kind of like it where you
know those instances were sort of outlined.
>> So you think that so you so you still maintain that
Course was telling people that they couldn't talk about the the
genocide in Palestine?
>> No, that's ever been the thing. Although they could
they could do that if that was over it was at a Course funded
event. They could.
>> Or that they were >> No, we our article doesn't
say anything like that. That's >> What were the content
restrictions implied by the headline?
>> That nowhere does it say anything about >> What were
the content restrictions implied by the headline then? >> It
said why don't you read >> I think this is the one this
is maybe the one argument they had was that the headline the
the subheading or whatever
was like possibly possibly a little
The clickbait part is possibly a little bit misleading. >> Read
further in the article >> I did read any article. You don't
substantiate anything though, so I'm just curious what you think
the content >> cite We cite the contract. We cite the >> You
don't though. >> Why don't you read that Why don't I not
read it for you? I don't have time. I need to get back to doing
actual work today. Now hold on. Let's see. Um so let's read exactly
the portion that you're asking about. >> I hate Taylor,
but how does Destiny always flop so hard when he debates her?
Um because he is debating her on something that she didn't do.
He's basically trying to argue that she's lying about something
where she's telling the truth.
So he picked something also he's trying to argue with her like
a journalist about journalistic ethics and what she's required
to do and what it means to publish something through a like an
actual publisher. Like he's trying to argue all of the things
she would actually know.
Right? It's It's just very goofy. It's Dude, I'm trying to think
of an example. But it be like if I tried to debate Hasan on like
Chinese like the the history of the CCP or something, right?
It's like maybe the one topic where I be totally blown out by
Hasan. Like he would know every little detail of the CCP's history.
You don't go at somebody on like the one thing they know. It's
just it's goofy.
>> It's one of the restrictions on what sort of policies
content could produce.
program with us monthly. Creators were told that they didn't
post their side of the Wired. I'm just reading it. Some creators
also raised concerns about a slew of restrictive clauses in the
contract. Influencers included in communication about the program
and in some cases on onboarding session. This is all us again
citing our sources. For those receiving payments include that
that that that that that we mentioned a bunch of people. A recording
of contract of copies of the contract viewed by Wired and that
that the creator signed, the influencers are not allowed to disclose
their relationship with Chorus or the 1630 fund or functionally
that they're being paid at all.
>> So we know that they could disclose Hasan would rape
you in economics. You're too green as a socialist. It's cuz I'm
not a socialist.
The [__] are you talking about, [__]
Why would you think I'm a socialist?
What have I ever said something that would lead you to believe
I'm a socialist on this stream?
disclose their relationship with Chorus. What you're saying at
this point in the article what you meant was they couldn't disclose
at that point of the Chorus creator program. >> Yeah, their
relationship in the funding program, which is what this article
is about, the funding program.
Chorus itself is public. We linked to the Chorus the news article
about Chorus and we cite Ken Klippenstein. >> have been
That might have been even less trolling to be honest with you.
>> report public reporting of Chorus. >> Maybe. Maybe.
>> Following initial outreach, many creators expressed
concern about stipulations. According to copies of the contract
viewed by Wired, creators in the program must funnel all bookings
with lawmakers and political leaders through Chorus. Creators
also have to loop Chorus in on any independently organized engagements
with government officials or political leaders. >> They
also have to
>> This just isn't true. I know someone So, Tabor says,
"This just isn't true. I know someone at Chorus."
He's literally talking about what they're reporting from the
contract. By the way, I think I've cleared this up with everybody
that I don't think Chorus is necessarily doing these things.
All they had to do was come out and say, "Oh, we're going to
clean up the contract, so these things aren't in "Oh, this is
just boilerplate. That was our fuck-up. We don't want these things
in there. That's not a part of our values. We're going to get
them all out, and then we're good to go."
Easy. So easy. If that was the response, dude, it's over right
there. It's like, "Oh, all of the bad things are gone. All the
bad things are gone. We're fine
>> And on any independently organized engagements with
government officials or political leaders. Leaders. If I want
to work with another politician, I have to fully collaborate
with them, said one creator was offered the contract but ultimately
declined and asked not to be named. If I get Zoran and he wants
to do an interview with me, I don't want to give that to them.
>> So, you're citing his opinion on his contract there,
yes? >> No, not his opinion. No, not his opinion. That's
>> I mean, the published section of the contract literally
validates this. It's what they say. Yeah, it's literally it's
literally what's said in the contract. We can go grab the image.
>> was told by Chorus. So, he he was told that by Chorus.
And we're saying that he's telling >> you this, right?
This is not a direct >> No, we have the original. We also
have the Zoom calls and we have text messages and everything
that back up all of our >> text messages or Zoom calls
with with a Chorus representative saying, "You are not allowed
to book your own political um interviews or whatever." They say
>> The That's actually just directly written in the contract.
>> Okay. Sure would be nice if you could put that in a
quotation anywhere, but >> Well, again, >> That part's
all Wait, that part's all
>> Sorry that we didn't put more quotes. >> Well,
I know it'd be great putting it in the journal wasn't to do so,
but I understand we're just on a nebulous world of opinions here.
That's okay. My standard for evidence is a lot lower. That's
fine. >> There's no other side of the story. Destiny, are
you going to actually engage with this or not? You're >> There's
to actually >> engage with anything. You're telling me
to just believe you and trust you on the contracts that you read
that aren't available publicly anywhere. I don't I can't anything.
I can't do anything. >> don't understand how source material.
>> But you don't understand how contracts work. So, I mean,
I'd rather see the source material than have to go on your opinion
about the contract. >> Here's some quotes. Here's some
quotes for you. Uh creators >> I don't know. I don't know
why she doesn't just Why doesn't she just start leaning on Wired?
I still get it. >> use any funds or resources that they
receive as part of the program to make content that supports
or opposes any political candidate or campaign without express
from Corus in advance in writing per the contract. The contract
reviewed by Wired prohibits standard partners >> That first
paragraph you read, that's like that's by law, right? That makes
sense. That if I'm paying somebody for something, they can't
take that money directly and support because that could be seen
as a um that would be a campaign contribution violation. >> about
to read a quote >> um where we mention some of this. So,
we say creators will quote not publicize their relationship with
Corus or tell others that they're members in the program quote
>> Wait, real quick. I'm sorry. Yeah. So, you have to do
the end quote as well for people, right? You so you say quote
not publicized end quote. So, that that quote was two words.
Go ahead. >> No, we haven't gotten to the quote. >> Well,
that was one quote. You had two words quoted there. Yes, go ahead.
>> We have We have two what two words. >> That's
okay. >> Folks, without Corus's prior express consent,
a screenshot from a slideshow was shared with Wired following
this article's publication by Graham, a lawyer working with Corus
that offers several talking points if a member of the cohort
wanted to discuss Corus publicly. They also forbid creators from
quote disclosing the identity of any funder and give Corus the
ability to end quote and give Corus the ability to force creators
to remove or correct
>> It's just funny how like um how pedantic he's getting
cuz he's losing the >> be solely on the organization's
discretion if that project is made >> All this conversation
cost him was like every single principled stance he took on trusting
institutions for the entirety of his streaming career.
Is this from today or is this from when they talked? This is
from today.
This is from today. >> at a Chorus organized event. >> Okay.
So, if we read through So, first of all, we're we're very sparsely
working with actual quoted material here, but
>> I All right. I'm done. >> that we have I see that
we have Hold on.
She's trying to leave. She's trying to leave. So, we said that
creators will not publish publicize their relationship with Chorus,
but they could do that, but you meant the Chorus funding mechanism,
I think, right? >> The Chorus itself was a public program.
Chorus is a non-profit. >> But, it's real confusing reading
this article cuz you never you seem to not really differentiate
with that. You just say Chorus, not the Chorus funding
>> All right, Destiny. I'm done with this. >> And then
it says, quote, "Without Chorus's prior express consent." End
quote. So, it seems like they could. They just needed to check
clear it with them first. >> This is exhausting. >> And
then they forbid creators from You can't leave. You can't leave.
You can't leave. You can't leave. As long as I keep talking about
this, you can't leave. As long as I keep talking about this,
you can't leave. Look, I'm reading the article now. According
to Chorus, according to contracts reviewed by Wired and the
Dude, hold on. Wait. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. I need
a soundboard for this. I need a soundboard for this.
POV, you try to leave a con POV, you try to leave a conversation
with Destiny. >> identity of any funder. Well, that makes
sense, right? If the if 1630 is a is a LLC that doesn't have
to disclose who their donors are, then you also probably wouldn't
be allowed to disclose who you think is funding them, right?
That makes sense, right? >> a waste of time. >> no
It was actually It was actually really illuminating. There is
There So, there are no content restrictions. >> grants
about What are you talking about? We just mentioned a bunch of
content
>> As in political content. As in like opinions they're
allowed to have, stories they're allowed Remember, in the second
paragraph of your article, you said they had restrictions on
what sort of Let me do this for you. Quote, "It mandated extensive
secrecy about disclosing their payments and had restrictions
on what sort of political content the creators could produce."
End quote. That's from your article. >> Yes. Yes.
>> So, I I what he's going to argue, and this is another
point that actually he could be correct on this, that it's not
really saying what kind of political content they can make, it's
really just saying that you have to follow campaign finance law.
That if you go and you like basically talk to a politician, or
you lobby for some politician, that that could be seen as an
in-kind contribution or something, right? Like that is a that
could be seen as some kind of contribution some earned some media
contribution that could be used against them to say, "Oh, you
guys are actually politically partisan."
So like I do think they're not trying to say you can't talk about
Israel, although they leave that like sort of opaque in a way
that I I think if you read it a certain way, it does sound like
they're saying, "Oh, you shouldn't talk about Israel." Or some
other topics specifically, right? So, I do think there's like
some argument there that it is like possibly misleading
or like it's easy to read into it. But I don't think that's like
a failing of the article, and you can not like that. But I think,
you know, as long as she's clear about it when she's talking
about it afterward or sorry, uh
after she's published it, as long as she's clear about it when
she talks about it, I don't think it's a huge problem. Which
I actually don't think she was totally clear every single time.
it is what it is. This is like the one tenuous argument you might
have is is it sort of implies more restrictions than than are
than actually exist in the contract, and the restrictions that
do exist in the contract probably are to make sure they're in
line with campaign finance law.
I'll read it again, and that's what we're citing. >> I
don't know what you're An arguable chill speech? Yeah, I I would
agree with that that it does kind of it seems to I wouldn't say
chill speech on like an issue or something though. It probably
it probably just makes people not like avoid certain things that
they could easily do otherwise or could possibly do with permission.
>> We're citing that your opinion about what was said but
>> There is no opinion. I'm sorry, there's no opinion.
I have a lot of opinions, none of them are reflected in this
article. I'll tell you that. Because if it was my opinion, I
would be putting a lot of opinions into this piece, none of which
are reflected.
>> I I think her opinion is that it's probably shaping
like rhetoric for
Right? I think that is her opinion
That like they're going to pay people broadly who are pro-Israel.
And that's going to reflect the opinions of the people who of
David Pakman and Brian Tyler Cohen, that's okay. And the Midas
brothers, it's like all the people who went to go start this.
I think that's what she actually thinks, but she doesn't put
it in the article, okay? I'm not joking. If you watch her [__]
her interview with Glenn Greenwald, I'm pretty sure she hints
in this exact direction. I think that's what she She probably
thinks that they pay more pro-Israel creators, that they have
a couple token ones who aren't pro-Israel
>> Again, this article was worked on by so many different
people. Well, anyway, the article outlines uh some of the restrictions,
so
now you can just read the article over and over and over again
until you die. >> The MySealus the MySealus brothers, right?
Not the Midas brothers, the the MySealus brothers. >> I'm
sorry. If you get If you know If you want to go and you know,
you personally don't like the quotes here, go look at that report,
you know, that one TikToker who posted part of the contract.
The portion of the contract that she showed validated exactly
what we reported. But if you don't believe that and you want
to go >> That's not true. >> Yes, it is. Yes, it
is. >> No, it's not. >> Yes, it is. Yes, it is, Ali.
Yes, it is. >> No, it's not. It's probably not. I promise.
>> Pull it up right now. Pull it up right >> Uh
unfortunate. >> Pull it up. >> It's just She's getting
continuously baited just staying on the call. I don't
This guy got to get some friends or something, dog. >> right
now. And I will show you exactly how it validates exactly what
we reported. >> Are you talking about this thing right
>> Yep. Here we go. Course contractor agrees to utilize
the Course newsroom to book engagements.
>> Disclose to Course newsroom personnel any engagements
with government officials or on or others on topics related to
Course's policy agenda. Interesting, what's their policy agenda?
That contractor is >> publicly listed? But go ahead. They
don't have a specific policy agenda that's publicly listed somewhere.
They have like broad, I think, pillars they stand for. They're
like fighting for democracy or something, but >> No, it's
not. >> Again, that's FEC language. They basically want
to know if you're going to talk to a specific politician, they
need to make sure that they're not going like above some certain
threshold that could be labeled, you know, political campaign
like campaign donations that could make them a partisan PAC.
That's why those rules are in there. >> So, what Course
supports is not publicly listed on their website? If I go to
the Course website, I'm not going to know like publicly what
their policy agenda >> No, if you go actually and this
was a big thing cuz if you remember afterwards,
if you if afterwards, right after, one thing that they tried
to claim for a minute before it was ridiculous was that they
were actually
And then of course that would fall out the window as soon as
their decks
>> Wait, Course initially ever advertises as a non-partisan
>> They have claimed
>> They because of their funding structure, they have to
be a non-partisan like issue focus issues focus PAC. They can
be on like one specific issue, but they're not allowed to just
explicitly like campaign for Democrats.
That's the whole point of like their funding structure of the
sorry their their corporate structure or whatever they [__]
Is they need to be a non-partisan PAC.
So, that's why they're claiming that, but they're not a non-partisan
PAC. >> they have tried to claim falsely, I would argue,
because we have their positioning decks and also they're in an
article on the New York Times where they're talking about how
>> And also Brian Tyler Cohen went on Desi's stream like
a week before he started Course. He was like, "I'm looking at
starting something new and I want to make sure we're like we're
like having a Monday morning meeting just like Republicans. That
we all get in a meeting, we have the same messaging, and it's
all about getting Democrat messaging out there and then he like
a week later he's like, "And now I'm starting Courier's." >> helping
Democrats. But after the article came out they tried to claim
that they were non-partisan.
Now they basically admit that >> Did they claim that they
were non-partisan or did they claim that they didn't explicitly
support a political candidate or something?
>> Um no, the can No, they never talked about candidates.
They claimed that they were non-partisan. >> Okay, I'd
be I'd be interested in seeing that but >> Well, you can
look at it You can look it up online. It's all right there. >> So
what what about this quote do you supports or reinforces anything
you said in your
>> disclose to Courier's newsroom personnel any engagement
with government officials or others on topics related to Courier's
policy agenda? >> That That contract or arranges through
other means, yes. >> Yeah, so that's exactly what we're
talking about in this article. >> What What do you mean?
>> We cite we talked Read the article again and you'll
see. >> And again, I It'd be cool if he had any idea what
he was talking about before he goes into these conversations.
Like it'd just be awesome cuz you could ask good questions here.
Like it's like, "Okay, well the the newsroom stuff, that's like
software, right?" Cuz what I think it is what they're trying
to do is they're trying to get contacts for politicians. So if
you get a meeting with a politician through a means other than
the Courier's newsroom through their software, they want you
to sort of like file that contact into the software so that they
can contact that politician and network with them, right? And
introduce them to other creators and get them to do more media.
That's what they want. Yes, and
But they I don't think that's going to be asked so I don't know
if we're going to get clarification there or not. What is the
content restriction here? >> Well, she doesn't disclose
She's not showing. She's talking about the engagement booking
stuff. She's not showing the full contract. I wish she >> Well,
no we wouldn't want that cuz Destiny, she's going to be super
pedantic about everything. You should too. Courier's is non-partisan
because they aren't officially connected to the Democratic Party.
Um no, tons of super packs are explicitly like
uh basically going in one direction for one party.
they're also uh sorry, they're also not officially tied.
That's not the distinction. The the whole non-partisan thing
is because they want to be a 501c4. >> Cuz apparently that
would be bad journalism. Okay, so then thank you. So then we
move back. So this doesn't actually reinforce anything you said
in the in the article in the article. Okay. >> Sorry. No,
no, no, sorry. It does validate what we said. Literally right
here. So we said, remember how we said um we literally say in
the in the article that creators must funnel all bookings with
lawmakers and political leaders through through Chorus, again
through Chorus Newsroom. Creators also have to loop in Chorus
in on any independently organized engagements with government
officials or political leaders. Then we have the quote from the
>> like this is for this is for people that they meet through
the Chorus Newsroom, not any random person. Like >> It's
a funnel all bookings through the Chorus Newsroom. Look at >> I
I think it's only I think it's only I think this is only
>> Nope, look at the contract. >> I'm looking at
the contract. I'm reading it. Yes.
Hold on. What is he >> Okay. Contractor agrees to utilize
the Chorus Newsroom to book engagements.
>> They have to use the Chorus Newsroom to book their engagements.
They have to >> Exclusively all of them? Where's the word
ex- No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No.
Taylor's [__] this up. She just hasn't talked about
this a long time. She's [__] it up. She's totally
correct again. Exclusive there. But she's This is I don't know
what this is a section section up, but the subsection is book
engagements. Chorus will provide contractors with access to the
Chorus Newsroom, which coordinates booking and engagement opportunities
for creators with government officials, policy and non-profit
experts, and others whose expertise and experience are relevant
to Chorus's progressive policy agenda. Oh, progressive policy
agenda. Contractor agrees to one, utilize the Chorus Newsroom
to book engagements. So it sounds like if you're part of this
program, you have to utilize it to some extent. It doesn't say
exclusive in here, which I would absolutely expect to see in
a contract if they expected some kind of non-compete or some
exclusive
Well, it's It's to come up in the next part where they have to
use it.
Number one, yeah, but you I don't think you have either, to be
honest. They just You wouldn't make the exclusive argument because
obviously it's not exclusive because there's a clause for what
happens when you don't use the Corus newsroom, right? So, like
it's pretty obvious nobody would make the exclusive argument.
And then part two here it says >> I have multiple copies
of the full contract as we know >> Oh, okay. Can I get
a definitive statement from you then? Does the Corus contract
forbid you? It means that you have to exclusively, and they use
the word exclusive in that contract, you have to exclusively
do all of your bookings through the Corus newsroom.
>> Where is the word exclusive in our >> Oh, then
it's not exclusive. Thank you, then we agree. So, it says that
you one, you have to utilize the Corus newsroom to book engagements
if you're part of So, I think the claim is that they to funnel
contacts through, right?
They have to funnel bookings through. Is that the word, funnel?
Funnel, funnel? Creators in the program must funnel all bookings
with lawmakers and political leaders through Corus. Creators
also have to loop Corus in on any independently organized engagements
with government officials or political
Yep. Oh, the other thing I was thinking is it's probably scheduling
software. It probably is literally saying like, "Oh, you are
talking to this person at this And they want to keep track of
that.
The hell was that? This the Was that maybe the
>> contract, you have Yes, not exclusive. Thank you, then
we agree. So, it says that you one, you have to utilize the Corus
newsroom to book engagements if you're part of some program.
I imagine they have something they're running, this newsroom
thing that they want you to participate in. So, okay. And then
two, disclose to Corus newsroom personnel any engagements with
government officials or others on topics related to Corus's policy
agenda that the contractor arranges through other means. So,
it sounds like if you >> So, nobody would have claimed
it was exclusive because it's literally in the language that
it's not >> It sounds like if you meet somebody through
this Corus newsroom thing and you want to do like an interview
or some kind of engagement with them, you need to go through
the Corus newsroom people in order to do it. This makes sense,
but this isn't a restriction on your content in so far as like
I couldn't arrange my own meeting with Zoran Mondani. >> We're
not talk We're talking about booking engagements. That's the
portion that she told >> for people that you meet through
the Course Newsroom.
>> Well, so the way that it was the way that it was described
to the creator who we quote is that you have to >> Sounds
like if you meet somebody through the new news exclusive. Thank
you. Then we agree. We do all Okay, and then two, disclose to
Course Newsroom personnel any engagements with government officials
or others on topics related to Course Policy Agenda the contractor
arranges through other means. So, it sounds like if you It sounds
like >> So, he just makes something up here.
Like he's going to introduce that only if you meet them through
the Course thing, but that's not a part of it, right? That's
not a part of it at all. It doesn't say anything about oh, if
you meet them through Course, then you have to do this thing.
Did he just make that up? >> Like if you meet somebody
through this Course Newsroom thing and you want to do like an
interview or some kind of engagement with them, you need to go
through the Course Newsroom people in order to do it. This makes
sense, but this isn't a restriction on your content in so far
as like I couldn't arrange my own meeting with Zoran Mondani.
>> It's saying if you arrange a meeting with somebody outside
of this, it needs to be tracked through the software. >> We're
talking about booking engagements. That's the portion that she
>> for people that you meet through the Course Newsroom.
>> Well, so the way that it was the way that it was described
to the creator who we quote is that you have to funnel your bookings
through the Course Newsroom.
>> No, no, no, no, no, no, no. You You guys Somebody just
give me the the picture.
This is not it, You You guys. No, no, no, no, no. I know I'm
correct. I just need somebody give me the picture. >> So,
you see earlier how I said this is why I don't want people's
opinions on the material that I rather It was his opinion. That
definitionally that's hearsay. That's his opinion on the contract.
And now that I'm reading the actual contract, seems like he was
just a little bit too stupid to understand it. It sounds like
this is saying that the people that you meet through the Course
Newsroom must be communicated with the Course Newsroom if you
want to book an engagement with them. That's what this reads
like to me as somebody who's seen probably as many contracts
as you. Maybe not >> Oh, he's invoking he's invoking his
contract expertise.
Wow. >> quite as many. I I sounds like you've done a lot
of stuff. But like if there was an extensive thing in here since
like you've been there
>> No, no, he's he's actually like explicitly gotten brain
damage or something. It was much better than this. I think what
used to happen was he consistently had conversations with people
who are super in the loop and so he always had their opinions
in the back of his head. And he is good at taking the information
presented to him, especially when he's like stewing in it for
a long time, and making good arguments. But now he doesn't have
those same people constantly like operating around him and arguing
with him and bringing the best arguments. And so it would be
a lot more work to go and find them. He doesn't have that anymore.
And it just doesn't it doesn't work the same way anymore.
Or he did like a bunch of drugs during his whole like when he
first got sued and broke his brain literally. >> Cuz I
No one is even disputing this. This is how Corus's own This is
how Corus's own lawyer on the Zoom call. And again, I'm sorry
that we can't share these calls with you. I would love >> No,
it's so convenient for you. >> I don't know what to tell
you. This is just a huge waste of time. >> Sure. Well,
you want to I was asking so then on that Zoom call you're saying
on the Zoom call
Well, can I just ask you a question? I'm just asking a question.
>> On that Zoom call >> I am. It's a simple question.
On the Zoom call did the lawyer say you're scared of the question?
That's why you don't want to ask it. >> No, I'm not. You're
just ranting and ranting and ranting and ranting and you just
barrel down and you don't understand basic >> Super easy.
Super easy. That's easy. So on the Zoom call the lawyer said
you're not allowed to arrange any independent political bookings.
All of it has to go through the Corus newsroom. >> Oh my
god.
>> Dude, it's really >> sad that these people are
like, "Oh, this is going Somebody says >> Hold on. Can
I find this again? This is going on the
uh ba ba ba ba the playlist with like Anna and Joel
>> barrel down and you don't understand basic facts >> easy
super They're basically saying Taylor's mentally ill and she's
like 100% correct in this conversation. Like
Did I Did I cover this on stream? Hold on. Hold on. I just love
a good backdrop to this. Please still be pinned to the subreddit.
No.
Now it's gone. Hold on. I don't think I covered this, but where
is it? There it
This journalist this journalist woman is mentally ill. Also,
guys, don't forget the March 8th DGG ladies night in celebration
of International Women's Day. NATO air ride Ukrainian Anna Aresian,
Sushi Z, all your favorites. All your favorites are here. You
think if Destiny had leaked of these people to someone, they
would still show up?
Or do you think it's like they're the ones who didn't get leaked
of them, so they're just like, "Yeah, it's it's actually awesome
still."
I did That's when I'll know this guy is actually just one of
the women who had leaked of them that they show up.
I just think it's like very funny that It's very funny that people
try to make it seem like this is a community friendly to women
when here's like a woman who's done good work. Um she's not misrepresented
the work, and now they're basically going to call her mentally
ill on the >> the Zoom call, the lawyer said, "You're not
allowed to arrange >> right here. Uh this is going on the
playlist with Kelly Jean and Anna.
So cool. >> arrange any independent political bookings.
All of it has to go through the Corus newsroom." >> Oh
my god. I I don't know what to tell you other than every single
thing in our >> that because Well, that means you do have
the call, and you know that's not >> Okay, hold on. What
did he >> and you just barrel down and you don't understand
basic facts. >> easy Super easy So on the Zoom call, the
lawyer said, "You're not allowed to arrange any independent political
bookings. All of it has to go through the Corus newsroom." >> Oh
my god.
>> Where's Hold on. Let me see. I need to try to find I
think Would I have Oh, there it is.
I got it. Okay. One, utilize the Corus newsroom to book engagements.
Two, disclose to Corus newsroom personnel any engagements with
government officials or others on topics related to Corus's policy
agenda that contractor arranges through other means. Three, fully
collaborate fully with Corus. Wait, is he Is he to do three?
Three is collaborate fully with Chorus regarding all such separate
arranged engagements. Contractor further agrees to participate
in newsroom events or booking opportunities at least twice per
month. Collaborate fully with Is he Is he just going to leave
out three? Is he just going to leave out number three? We're
just going to leave out number three, I guess, entirely? We're
going to pretend number three doesn't exist or we're just totally
leaving that part out, I guess.
Pretending that don't exist at all.
Okay. Okay. Cool. >> I I don't know what to tell you other
than every single thing in our story >> acknowledge that
because Well, that means you do have the call and you know that's
not true. It's not true. Your Your article is using misrepresentation.
Your article misrepresents a ton of this contract. You probably
know it. >> No, it Again, I'm sorry that you make these
You're making these beliefs. I just want people to understand,
you're making these assumptions.
>> When you have never
seen a single copy of this contract. You have no access to any
>> have to though because I can see by the way you lie
about it. >> Can I stop interrupting? Stop interrupting.
Let me finish. Otherwise, I will get off the call. >> Okay,
tell her. >> You are making these accusations, claiming
that my story is wrong when you have zero access to any of the
group chats that we have, to zero access of all the recordings
of the Zoom calls that we have, you have zero copies of the contracts,
and you have conducted zero interviews with people that are in
>> So, I get that she's trying not to pass the buck off
to Wired here. That like that seems to be her like what she's
trying attempting not to do, right? But, she does have to. That's
That is literally the authority by which you are speaking.
Like you You couldn't if you were just making this claim by yourself
with no other thing, you would have to show something more for
people to believe you, right? The thing that allows us to just
take the characterizations and say, "I believe these." is the
fact that a team of editors and lawyers validated these statements.
So, when she's trying to avoid it, it's like it doesn't make
sense to avoid it. She does just need to She does just need to
lean on Wired over and over again. >> in the program. You
have not spoken to anyone at the 1635
and you have not spoken to any lawyers that were involved in
in in signing these contracts. Lawyers for the creators themselves.
Oh, also, sorry, talent agents and managers as well who also
understood that they and were involved in these contract negotiations.
I just want people to understand that we did all of that before
the story and all of that is reflected in our story. I understand
that you don't believe that and that's fine. Okay, you don't
have to trust journalism. But it is a fact that we did all of
that work and it is a fact that there is zero corrections on
that story because in it's in the wake of the story, not a single
one of those creators has privately or publicly debunked
anything that we have said. I'm sorry, they haven't. And privately
it has been confirmed and they are still my sources and I still
talk to them. I don't know what to tell you. But if you want
to disprove this, I highly encourage you to do your own reporting.
Do your own reporting and make your own report on the course
program. Why don't you join the course program? Okay, and then
you can see, you know, if you think it's accurate or whatever.
>> that you would go through the effort of doing so many
interviews, so many Zoom calls, so many contracts, so many emails
and there's just so little quotation or display of of anything.
>> you feel we should have quoted directly. I I would argue
>> me what what that means is I'm I'm just curious why
he thinks the editorial staff at Wired decided to take this approach.
Like I would just love to know that. Why does he think that's
the case? What Like they they decided to do this. Like I I understand
Taylor Lorenz is not highly respected in the DGG community, but
it again, just imagine she's publishing with the New York Times
cuz I don't really see a huge differentiation between the two.
Like the New York Times is a little more
But what if she just pub published with the New York Times? Like
how would you explain this away? >> is and I won't give
my opinion, I'll just say it as a fact. But what that means is
that you know that that material doesn't support this >> No,
that's not true. >> that this story is I Please, please,
for the love of God, just lean on probably Please, probably misleading
or a lie. And if you don't want to say that, then either you
or Wired can sue me for it if you think that I'm because I'm
accusing you of lying on it. That's fine. If you want to do that,
then we can all hash it out and figure it out that way, but
>> First of all, I would never sue you. I don't believe
in suing over speech in that way. That is something that I speak
about constantly which you refuse to engage with.
>> This is, by the way, the exact logic that Trump supporters
used to go against like and with the same level of like I looked
into contract law without going to school. I have no real background,
but I've I've read a couple legal documents, so I know what I'm
talking about with regards to vaccines.
Yeah, I I read some like biology Wikipedia articles, so I know
what I'm talking about with vaccines. It's like the exact Trump
supporter logic of doubting the institution because you can't
validate stuff yourself. It's really funny, man. >> refuse
to engage with it. Okay. >> Well, you're making you're
just making these ridiculous claims. Second of all, again, Destiny,
you have
I'll say it again. You did not do any interviews. You do not
have any copies of the contract. You do not I encourage you to
go out and do your own reporting. Until you go out and do your
own reporting, this is a very circular
conversation that we are frankly never going to agree on and
I'm sorry that you feel it's very funny cuz when I originally
filed my first copy of the story, I actually had block quotes
from the contract. And then when I was editing it, I was like
putting the block quotes on each single word again for fact checking.
But I understand as a >> Hold on, wait a minute. So, I
understand what you just said. You're saying that you had more
citations, actual citations to the original material, and then
Wired forced you to remove those citations?
>> No, they didn't force me to remove
>> Very tricky. You're very tricky. You're very tricky.
I appreciate that about you, but go ahead. >> There's no
trickiness. >> Uh-huh. That is poor That is poor journalism.
It is bad journalism to have massive block quotes every other
paragraph quoting from a contract. It's a bad unreadable story.
>> I see. >> And so of course, when you write and
I've written about many contracts, right? You don't necessarily
quote from it. Now, should more source material be put online?
I totally am with you. I'm That's my whole thing as a journalist
is to be more transparent. That's why I'm sitting here on a [__]
Twitch stream or whatever app Kick, I don't know what we're on.
If we're on anything, if you're even recording. I don't know.
But the point is is that I I really try to be an open book and
I >> I feel like she definitely knows she's on stream.
Get the [__] out of here. >> to engage in good
faith. And I'm sorry that we're not going to agree on some things.
I am not out for the Democrats in the way that you think I am.
I I don't know what to tell you. We're going to have to agree
to disagree. I wish you would spend your time, since you care
so much about transparency,
fighting some of these laws in Congress engaging >> it
seemed like you said earlier that the original article was lawyer-checked,
but now you're saying these were just editorial decisions that
you made cuz you didn't like the block quotes. So, >> No,
no, no, no, certainly not. Certainly not. Certainly not. No,
no, no, no, no. You go through edits where you go through extensive
fact-checking, extensive legal review. Editors all up and down
the chain will make tweaks and changes based on their reviews.
Again, >> Sure, but was there any point in this where a
Wired editor or lawyer was telling you you need to restrict the
amount of actual source material shown in this
>> Well, of course, that's the natural editing process
is cutting it down. I think the original I think the original
story I filed was like twice as long I I was very long. >> time
where an editor or legal person explicitly told you that you
could not cite you could not display the original source material
in parts of this >> Well, we agreed collectively not >> Well,
I Hold on. I think No, no, no, no, no, no. I feel like Okay,
she's going to say collectively decided we couldn't publish direct
quotes or something. But that's not really
That's not really Did you miss the joke? I don't know if you're
recording this. That wasn't a joke on her part. She's legitimately
saying she doesn't know if she's on stream right now. That wasn't
a joke. That wasn't her joking. I understand the double meaning.
But that wasn't her joking. I just lost what I was saying. >> story
I filed was like twice as long.
>> She's going to say the thing about like protecting identities.
It's like, dude, of course somebody could have easily come along
and said, "Oh, you don't need this. Just like just summarize.
Don't like do this whole thing. Like we don't have all that You
know, it's not going to The article's not going to flow well.
Just summarize." Like it says all these things, just summarize.
It's fine. >> Was there a time where an editor or legal
person explicitly told you that you could not cite you could
not display the original source material in parts of this article?
>> Well, we agreed collectively not to >> I know
even because without you answering I know the answer now, right?
Cuz you're refusing to engage with it. I know that's how these
work, but yeah. >> Sure. Sure. Yeah, sure. Sure.
Well, it yes. Sure. >> No, you cuz you would have said
you would have said you would have very easily answered. Well,
of course yes, there were parts where I wanted to include stuff,
but they said that this wouldn't fly. >> I know because
I agree with them. No, because I I agree with them that it I
agree with them. I agree with them that it would be a it would
it would be very bad experience for for the reader to read my
original copy because I'm a bad writer. You read my original
copy, you would also see that I am like I overly quote. That's
like a thing that I do is I overly quote from sources and I overly
quote things directly cuz I started as a But I'm sorry again.
I'm sorry that we're going to have to agree to disagree on all
of this stuff. I think ultimately this is a huge waste of time.
We're seeing one of the biggest rollbacks of civil liberties
I would argue in our lifetime right now making its way through
Congress with the Kids Act and some of the other stuff. And I
really, really wish that you would spend your time covering that
stuff. And I wish that you would spend your time really fighting
these laws and getting involved politically instead of litigating
and fighting nonsense with journalists. >> Well, I think
the important part for if you want to fight stuff like this,
the important thing the most important thing you need is to get
legislators in Congress. And as As as there are people like you
that are constantly stabbing from the left and trying to undermine
democratic people getting elected. >> See, this is what
I told This is what I was saying is I'm pretty sure this is why
the conversation took place is cuz he's doing his whole thing
with like Hutch. Right? Him and Hutch, they're going to get everybody
every lefty getting them out of the coalition.
Sonna's bad. Yeah, it is a little bit of a Sonna's bad moment.
Unfortunate. Unfortunate. >> sides are the same no matter
what basically makes that job impossible. >> never say
both sides are the same no matter what. Donald Trump is obvious
The Repub- What are you talking about? >> Oh, dude, there's
actually such a bad dude, he is so slimy.
I There's one more thing and then after this one, we're we're
pretty much done. But yeah, tankie [__] dude. There's
There's one more slimy moment here where she's like, I don't
at all say that. I've never said the parties were the same. I
don't say that to you at all. >> are obviously worse and
more evil than the Democrats. What are you talking about? I would
never say that and I never have said that. >> Okay. I heard
you I heard you say on Pesca's stream multiple times that both
parties were largely supportive of these particular free speech
acts that you >> Both parties are are absolutely
>> That's like a descriptive statement
of one tiny piece of legislation.
Yeah, both parties are support
Do you see how that's like clearly not at all
the same thing?
Saying something descrip- Both parties are largely supportive
of Israel. Oh, so like Republicans and Democrats are just the
same, are they? Well, really? You're going to say You're just
going to say Republicans and Democrats are the same because they
both support Israel? No, I'm just saying they both support Israel.
Are you
You like categorically
What is your problem?
Dude, it's
it's so obviously bad faith on his part. I just don't get I guess
to get through the lawsuit stuff, to get through the crime stuff,
people just had to like let their brains break entirely. >> absolutely
supportive of these really dangerous restrictive speech laws,
that doesn't mean that Donald that Donald Trump administration
is the same as what would have been a Kamala Harris administration.
That's ridiculous. And that doesn't mean that they can't both
support very harmful policies, but we should critique their support
of those policies and not make false equivalences.
Like which >> Obviously, like literally everybody every
single person
in Destiny's chat should agree with that >> I don't make.
>> I am so disappointed by any Democrats that are supporting
these >> Classic both sides. Classic both sides. >> censorship
laws. And what I would hope that you would talk about that would
be a far better use of your time instead of fighting about some
stupid influencer story, which is so just nothing in in the grand
scheme of things. When again, we are about to see identity verification
rolled out mass internet. And by the way, this is going to affect
you your your own platform as a content creator. Don't you want
your your followers and your supporters to be >> Sorry,
that is the last kind of super slimy moment right there. Okay.